Wow, there we go.
Fall into your hand, I commend your spirit.
Oh, my God.
Testing, testing.
Uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, cinco, seis.
I know it's kind of hard just to get off one, two, three.
He asked for a thirteen, yeah?
He drew a thirty-one, so he's trying to hard.
Good morning, good evening, good after.
Below the name.
Okay?
I am none other than Shony Culls and I am playing...
It took me a really long time to be able to screen capture
my legitimate Game Boy Advance that I own.
Oh, it's fantastic.
Really, really fantastic technology.
May or may not, I have just softlocked my PC
and that is why I had such trouble getting on fucking line.
But lo and behold, we are here.
I'm just gonna make sure...
Oh.
Okay, so this...
This thing.
Okay, we're good.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I should become an opera singer.
I'm that bloody good.
What's that?
I have smoke up my ass.
Okay, my little reeflings.
Today on the agendination.
Are you doing okay?
Yes, I'm farting up a storm, so alcohol definitely makes you fart more,
if you want to know.
Um...
Uh, what's my sentence?
Um, in four hours time,
we're gonna do a membership stream,
which isn't actually up right now.
Cause...
I maybe didn't put it up yet.
Me?
I've been able to get something up?
Impossible, impossible.
Um...
Wait, what's our name in Zelda gonna be then?
Oh, sorry.
The legend of long.
Wait.
Was it AB?
Uh, right.
Ah.
Oh wait, the in-game character is gonna call us Anon.
No, call us Link.
Link.
We came to town.
We came to save.
Uh, yes, we are doing the forbidden tier list ring.
I am gonna need a kind reefling to send me the Link
and marshmallow, cause I actually don't even have the Link.
Uh, cartoffel of doom.
Thank you very much for coming to member.
Yeah, everyone's need to go and show the number.
Oh!
Why would you never?
Save file.
Do not touch the completely legitimate Nintendo.
Wow.
Damn plane.
The controls are a bit wrong, but...
Wah, I'll read it.
Don't worry if you can't read.
I'll read it for you.
A long, long time ago.
When the world was on the verge of being swallowed by shadow.
A tiny picori appeared from the sky, bringing the hero of men a sword and a golden light.
With wisdom and courage, the hero drove out the darkness.
When peace had been restored, the people enshrined that blade with care.
You've never played Minish Cap?
The funny thing is, Minish Cap is the only Zelda game I've actually played.
Look, it's Zelda!
This is what the entire series is named after.
This little pink pixel here.
The entire series is named after her.
Because everyone...
Ah, made the mistake of thinking that Link is called Zelda as well.
Good morning, meh.
Good morning, meh, meh.
Good morning, Princess Zelda.
Did you sneak out of the castle and come all this way alone?
The moon is so sure to be worried about you.
You know how he gets.
Oh, don't worry about him. He'll be fine. Where's Link?
The whole town is bustling for an annual picori festival.
I thought he and I might go together.
Would you mind? Terribly.
Oh, is that what you're here for?
Well, Link was up late helping me last night and he's still asleep.
But I don't have an errand at the castle.
Yes. Oh, but I do have an errand at the castle.
Yes, that should be fine.
Ah, yes, Legend of Zelda.
Kinks of Weakening, Ike, Void Sword...
Void Sword, sure.
Thank you for the tip. I don't think I was going with Void Sword.
But yes, that should be fine, yes.
Link! Time to get up!
Did I see Nintendo Direct today? No.
Link! Link, I said it's time to get up!
Eh?
Man, I was fapping.
Goddamn, got that morning wooden shit.
I just love these pixel games.
Oh my god, did you know in the VTuber community, someone is making a Legend of Zelda inspired like little fucking Cedar game?
Like, you're at a cafe and shit? I'm gonna be all over that stuff.
Hold on, funding it right now.
Huh?
Oh shit, my freaking tea.
Hey, Link!
Princess, then it lies how I should like to know if you'd like to join her at the festival.
Yeah Link, come on, let's go check out the festival together.
Master Sith already gave me permission to take you.
Well, handed off like a dog.
Yes, after all, the festival only comes once a year. God, have fun.
And while you're there, you can do me a favor.
I just finished making the sword for the minister at Hyrule Castle.
I'd like you to deliver it to him.
You, you accepted the sword.
Make sure you don't lose this extremely important delivery. I won't.
This is the blade that will be presented to the winner of the competition.
Don't lose it. And while the two of you may be childhood friends, remember...
Are you?
Remember, Zelda is the princess of Hyrule.
You watch over her, don't let anything bad happen to her.
Master Smith, quit worrying. I'll be perfectly safe.
Come on, Link, let's go. Check out the festival.
Hold on, let me take a little flip.
Friends owned. Are you joking me?
Do you remember that meme that went really viral?
And it was like, a knight. It was like a princess and a knight
and the princess was getting like booed by the crowd or something.
Now sell it. You can't sell a sword.
Oh, you called me a sell sword, exactly. I got you. 4k.
Check out the festival under her skirt.
Rifle ends. You're feeling it the day you knocked in Ellie's.
Now, if I'm not mistaken, if you're a snowberry,
there should be a membership ASMR going on right now.
Question mark. I have no idea.
I think that's from Aces schedule.
Mercy's off the day. I'm trying to use my autism.
Azura is also off today.
Emmy and Sheebie is on.
Sheebie has a collab and Emmy has a collab
and a day's time with people not in real life.
Thank you, question mark. I can't remember what they're playing today.
That's right. She had to reschedule.
She pushed it to tomorrow. It's delayed.
Oh, probably Aces' call. Alright, okay.
Je comprends, je comprends. Right, let me try and host this honey tea down.
Next week, we're going to write the honey tea plot together,
so I see exactly what you want me to say and I was so fucking excited.
Wow, listen to that music.
This is a Game Boy Advance game.
Oh, listen to that harp, that harmonious.
Wow.
It's so good.
I saw it.
I was going to actually consider making the songs for Jin to be still for this game.
I don't know.
The rules are, if there's any more background music that gets produced,
it has to be a childhood game or a game that I really like.
But Zelda is very peaceful, but I'm not actually sure we have any peaceful concept.
And Jin too.
So far, I don't think anyone is peaceful.
I don't think we have one peaceful person at all.
Azura. Azura is peaceful. She's peaceful.
This would do Azura with a harp.
I maybe should have gone with a harp.
I would be real. I don't even remember all from yesterday.
Turns out chugging a ball. Oh my God, you did not have a football ball.
Strony, what's your opinion on the new Zelda game?
Whatever your opinion is, because I've never played it.
This is the only Legend of Zelda game I have ever had access to and played.
What about Earthbound? I don't know what Earthbound is.
I'm sorry, I'm just getting used to the controls on my...
I'm not going to open this chest because it's got money in it,
and I don't want to waste that opportunity to have that money.
But look how freaking adorable this pixel art is.
Is this not freaking precious?
I'm going to give it to the princess like this.
Yeah, you take that.
Wait, can I do it over the bed?
Hold on. Oh my God, there's two beds for me in the print.
Yeah, you like that. Oh look, I'm making my bed.
Oh look, I need to get all the sheets all smoothed out.
I don't want any creases.
Oh yeah, you like that princess.
I need to practice and I need to get my practice in
for what happens after the festival.
Yeah, teach you that better lesson.
Yo, is that the master sword?
Earthbound is a game...
is a game Ness is from.
Might have seen it in Smash Bros. It's an old Nintendo game.
Oh, come with us.
Making the views.
Link, over here.
Oh, sorry, sorry, Zelda was just pumping.
Sorry, I was just having a cheeky pump.
Right, how's the roll button? Oh, there it is.
Link, hurry, let's go.
You moan in like every sentence.
Is that how you normally talk?
Over here. Come on, hurry up.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Princess, what's going on here?
Well, here we are.
I'm trying to play.
Princess, princess, it's first thing in the morning, hen.
Wah!
Here we are, Link. Doesn't this look fun?
Come on, let's look around.
Wow, look all the free colors.
I'm getting stimulated.
Welcome to the PCORI Festival.
They say that every 100 years, the PCORI comma high rule.
And this is the 100th year to the day
since the last time the PCORI were here.
Wah, hello, princess.
Link, here's the storyteller here.
We should stop and listen to...
I wonder what's over there.
Jeez, you got ADHD, princess.
You don't need a little stimulant.
I can stimulate you.
So the PCORI are real.
My father always told me they were.
Oh, look at that.
I know.
As long as she's happy, that's the main thing.
Hey, wasn't there going to be
a sword fighting tournament at the castle?
I wonder who won this year.
Oh, wow, over here.
Oh, it is this.
Oh, pardon me.
We have a winner.
Oh my.
Oh my, Princess Zelda.
You won the grand prize in her drawing.
Wow, that's totally not rigged against everyone.
You get your choice of any of these wonderful prizes.
What will it be?
First, we have this lovely heart-shaped stone.
Next, we have...
This magnificent gem.
And finally, there's this tiny shield.
So which one will you like?
Let me guess.
The jewel?
Oh, but this heart-stone is very cute, too.
Choose whichever one you like.
This shield is so adorable.
I heard that.
She likes a small tiny.
I think I'll take it.
Following Strony around the convention
late to the school arts alley.
What?
I'm looking for Rebecca art.
What? Why?
Why would you want that ugly thing?
What about the heart-stone?
It's cute.
Oh, or this giant gem. It's pretty.
Honestly, they're both much nicer
than that nasty little shield thing.
Jeez.
Can I put this in a script?
Nope, I want the shield.
Can I have it?
What a strange princess you are.
Well, okay.
Here's your teeny tiny shield.
Here, I want to give you a present.
It'll match the size of your...
Doesn't the shield suit you perfectly?
Like...
Give you a small shield.
Hold the button to protect yourself.
It is a little embarrassing though.
It's so tiny.
What the heck is going on here?
Oh, he's stutting on him.
Yep, just as I thought.
You look great.
Now, if anything happens,
you can protect me with that shield.
Oh, I almost forgot.
We have to take Master Smith's sword to the castle.
Let's go, Link.
How do I do this?
What?
I will protect you, my lady.
My lady, come, come, my lady.
You must sugar fly.
My bunny, my heady.
That's not the words.
Oh, what the fuck?
Sorry.
This game explains your first outing on Patreon.
Come on, Link.
Let's hurry to the castle.
Wa-wa-wa-wa-wa.
Bonk.
Oh!
Hey!
Ouch!
Not to be the business scrub...
Business scrub.
That's me.
Wait, that is the same.
It must be the business scrub.
I heard the soldiers talking about it.
They were just saying a dicky scrub
had been hassled in all the passages by...
Link, do something about it.
Otherwise, we can't get to the castle.
If only we had some way to defend ourselves
against those nuts of his.
Wait, what?
It's too early in the morning.
It's too early.
Please forgive me, sir.
I heard that was a festival
and I came to town helping my...
to hawk my words.
Unfortunately, we scrubs have a tendency
to spit nuts as we speak.
Everyone's got scared and ran away
and no one would buy anything.
This is a terrible place to do business.
I'm going back to my cave.
I actually feel a little sorry for that business scrub.
But that net hurt!
Oh well, he won't be hassling anyone now.
We better hurry to the castle.
Wow.
I'm getting Australia overload.
That's kind of the part of the plan, you know?
You see, we've not executed the plan yet
but there's many ways to main break them.
I'm sorry, Link, but I'd better go.
I have to prepare for the ceremony.
I had a good time at the festival.
Thanks for coming with me.
Since you're here, Link,
why didn't you join us for the award ceremony?
No point in going home, old chap.
Just join us.
Why not? You're here anyway.
Oh, look, it's me and the boy, Potho.
I do know about that sword, Link.
It is called the PCORI BLADE
and it looks much evil.
What?
And it locks much evil away in that chest.
Sorry, it's a bit early in the morning
to be talking about Gothic architecture.
The PCORI BLADE is sacred among the people of Hyrule.
The legend has it that, long ago,
the PCORI gave us this blade.
Whoever wins the competition
earns the honor of touching the sacred blade.
Would you let me touch your sacred blade?
Whoa, big daddy in the horse.
Fuck's it, he's truly twice the size of his elder.
Let the award ceremony commence.
Avati, champion of the competition,
you may approach the blade.
Was that Conqueror's Bad Ferdy?
It absolutely was.
King Chonk of Hyrule.
To think things would go this well,
the PCORI BLADE and the bone chests
spoken of the Hyrllian Reborn.
This chest must hold that which I seek.
I relieve you of its contents now.
Do not interfere with that.
Me?
As Victor, I earned this right to approach the PCORI BLADE.
I've been waiting for this moment.
I don't know why Scottish people are evil, but...
Oh wait, maybe they'd be British, like English.
I've been waiting for this moment.
Okay, okay, sorry.
Protecta Zelda?
Eh, yeah, no, let's do it.
Wait, what's the British voice?
Who are you?
Why are you doing this?
Oh wait, that's Zelda.
Who are you? Why are you doing this?
The princess with the mystic aura.
The power that was gifted to the people of Hyrule
still flows within the veins of that lady.
The veins of the ladies of its royal family.
Interesting.
If I leave you now, you will only cause me trouble later.
That will never do.
To stone with you!
Run now!
Ah, Zelda now!
All who stand in my way shall share this fate.
Now to find out what power awaits me in the chest.
Ete!
There is nothing in there but a rabble of monsters.
What's the meaning of this?
Well, I know the force and I'm after it's somewhere out there.
I'm in no hurry.
I can take my time searching for it.
Classic British stealing things.
Exactly, yes.
I thought Star Wars reference too, but I'm probably just...
Oh my god, we're in a castello!
Oh my god, this is the Borgia Castle, clearly.
Wake up, wake up.
Put on a little bit of makeup.
Oh, we need to make the bed for the maid.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, you want to take over?
Oh, hold on.
Oh shit, I interact with people when you do that.
I was gonna hump her, but I interact with people when you do that.
Erlink, you're awake.
Are you feeling alright?
Stand at my side.
The king of Hyrule is about to speak.
It is as you have all heard.
A sorcerer named Vati has cursed my fair Zelda and turned her to stone.
If we had the sacred PCORI blade, we likely could have broken the curse.
But Vati shattered the blade.
However, I have not given up hope.
What do you know about the PCORI?
Er, the PCORI, not much.
Beyond what?
Oh fuck, these both have the same voice.
Beyond what the fairytales say, they're supposed to be very tiny if I remember correctly.
It is the ones from the fairytales, but the PCORI are no mere legend.
They are certain exists.
No one outside of the royal family knows the truth about them.
The PCORI who forged the sacred blade lived deeper than the Minish Wars.
They should be able to repair the broken blade and reforge the sword.
What?
There must be dispatch the soldiers there at once.
No, soldiers will not do.
The PCORI do not show themselves to anyone but children.
Our soldiers could search for days and still fight no cycle.
I see.
That's the case, then why not send Link?
If Link has recovered then yes, I would like to ask him of this.
Please, turn my precious Zelda back to normal.
The PCORI should know how to create a new sacred sword.
It will be a dangerous journey, now that those monsters have been freed.
Please, take the sword with you along with the broken PCORI blade.
Broken PCORI blade!
This is part of the sword needed to be forged with sacred sword. Do not lose it.
Smith sword!
It's a sharp blade made by your grandfather.
Very well then.
Very well then. Send the soldiers to search for that in the world.
Deep within the Minish Woods you will find the place called Deepwood Shrine.
Once, humans and PCORI ship that shrine as a meeting place.
I think it would be best if you started your search there.
Take this map with you.
If you get lost on your way to the forest then please check your map.
Just press start and then this stuff.
And I've marked it on the location of the forest view.
Gluck and be careful.
You got the map of Hyrule!
Now you'll never get lost.
Bottom right.
You have to go bottom right, okay?
The child will learn to kill. Send the child.
The child and yearn for the mines.
I am counting on you, Link.
Only you can break Barty's curse of free princess.
Okay, let's unprofessionally roll out of this castle.
I like the game. What's the name of the country?
This is based in America? What?
The Chales will become a man.
Be a man.
You must be slipped as the Corsing River.
Man, you must just take off that dress.
Fire through the mouth.
Miss...
You're in my way, you're in my way, you're in my way.
That's fine. I'll forgive you.
Oh, we got coins!
You've got one rupee. It's green. Don't spend all in one place.
You guys wouldn't spend me all in one place, would you?
I've not accidentally left reverb on, have I?
One coin, let's go.
You guys will have to remind me at the four-hour mark I'm to get off,
because we're playing the rest of the game tomorrow.
I'm doing the Forbidden Tearless, and I already didn't forget.
Yes, I have played this game in childhood a couple of times,
so I'm not too terrible.
Watch me eat my words in about an hour's time, but...
You can't do anything yet.
I'm not in one place, but I'm sure you can.
You're awesome.
Multiple, but multiple, please.
I know, I can't believe that I'm not finishing a game in one go.
It's absolutely crazy. It's terrible.
Help! Help me!
Ouch!
Want somebody stop him?
Ow! Ow! Help! Somebody!
Can't anyone hear me?
I don't want boys to get these guys.
No, it's definitely a guy-hat.
There are many hats in the world.
But this is a guy-hat.
Hey, kid, you there!
Hey, don't just stand there, do something!
Ow!
What's wrong with you?
Do you like watching me take this piss?
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Well done, that was close.
Now that I couldn't handle that myself.
But that's beside the point.
What in the world is a lone child doing so deep in the woods?
I see.
The PCORI, you say, in Vati?
Vati's curse someone what?
The Sacred Blade?
Is that so? I see, I see.
Okay, you know, you know, I have quite a lot in common.
You see, I too am on a quest to break the curse of Vati's.
And you say they reforged the Sacred Blade can break...
That reforging the Sacred Blade can break his curse, eh?
Well, then you have found yourself a companion, my boy.
My name's Ezlo.
It's a pleasure to make your acquaintance.
Speak.
What? Is there something on my face?
Quit staring, it's rude.
Wait, wait, wait, I said.
You walk so quickly, too quick in fact.
Can you go any slower?
Certainly you've noticed that I have no legs.
Boy, take a good look at me.
Do you really think I can walk that fast?
Eugh!
If this isn't one thing, it's another.
You're a troublesome boy.
There, now you can't possibly leave me behind.
My, it's actually quite comfortable up here.
More comfortable than it looks, surely?
And much easier on me.
Hey, quit your squirming, can't you sit still?
See, there, there, there you go.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's it, much better.
Now, I suppose a boy like you still has much to learn about the world.
If ever you needed my insight, press select.
I'll be happy to help.
Eh, such a hopeless child.
Ta-da!
We have hats.
Look at the drip.
Read the drip.
Read it.
Is it posing?
Is it starting on the floor?
Look at the drip.
Look at that hat physics.
Look at the physics.
When I go forward, the hat doesn't sing.
Hold on for a moment.
My boy will stumble across something important.
The world of the Minish is very small
and you're far too big to meet them now.
Eh?
Where's the Minish?
Ah, yes, silly me.
Allow me to explain.
You humans call them Bakori,
but they refer to themselves as the Minish.
Strange how, in the world of humans,
only this forest has kept the name.
Anywho, deep in the forest, they built a tiny village.
They were many who...
Oh, a good woman.
Live now.
But if they're where to enter the village,
we'll have to make you a touch smaller first.
Look at that.
At first glance, it appears to be a mere stump, yes?
No.
That stump is the portal used by people long ago
to adjust their size.
With my help, you can use it to shrink down to Minish size.
Just stand at the stump and press this button.
To return to normal, stand again and press the button.
Get me up there and we'll give it a try.
Humana, humana, humana, humana, humana, humana.
Oh my god, we're in a tiny...
Oh, look, we're doing butt bouncing on the wee mushrooms.
Always so pretty cute.
Welcome to the world through the eyes of the Minish.
Now, aren't you glad you saved me?
No need to thank me, though.
Portals that reduce your size are all around
in different shapes and sizes.
If you want to return to normal,
stand next to the portal and press N.
But there is one thing you must know.
Being Minish-sized is full of dangers.
With mere puddles at your normal size are bottomless pits.
And as your companion, if anything bad happens to you,
it happens to me, too.
So proceed with caution, my lad.
If not for your sake, then for my own,
why is the heck is he starting to scandinavian?
Anus bibanus?
What? Anus bibanus?
Thank you for the tip.
Wah! Oh, sorry, sorry.
Neat timing, neat timing.
Wah, wah, wah, wah!
Red voice speedrun?
Oh.
Ah!
Nando desu.
I was there, I was there.
Okay.
Look, it's an acorn.
Look, it's a leaf.
Acorn.
And there's clover.
Minnish village.
Wow.
Hmm.
It appears we have found the minnish village.
We don't understand them yet,
so they're just gonna go...
I gather it's been quite some time since they last saw a human.
What's that?
You don't understand what they were saying just now?
Ah, yes.
That was the language of the minnish.
That's a little different from the dialect I'm most familiar with.
I'm afraid I didn't catch most of what they said myself.
But perhaps there is someone here who understands your language.
We should look around.
So we need to find the village elder,
which he should be up here for now.
Oh.
You got a heart.
They replenish your life a little bit.
I never played this.
It's so pretty.
It's a cute little pixel thing.
Good voice acting thing.
Fried my voice.
Ah, Denpa.
I finally recorded my side of the line,
so I need to edit it.
Soon.
Soon I will update you, Denpa.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Pick up the heart here.
You got a piece of heart.
Select four to make a new heart container
for even more life energy.
One of the best pixel art games,
they put their whole penussy in this.
That's what we see.
Right, we're now talking to the elder.
I've never seen an outfit like that before.
Are you a human?
Oh my, it's been some quite some time
since any human has come here.
My name is Faustari.
I watch the abbey as well as the shrine in the north.
You seem to be having some trouble with our language, aren't you?
Yeah.
You could use the jabbernut.
It will allow you to understand our tongue.
You should be able to find one in the barrel else,
just selfie.
I'll make them cockney.
I need to start using the cockney accent
because I'm starting to blend all the guys' voices together.
I think this is above or below?
I think it's below.
Oh, no. Don't climb that again.
Check.
Uh, like, this must be the jabbernut.
I don't know what voice I gave him.
This must be the jabbernut for Starry, told you about.
Well, you'd be better eat it if you plan on making any progress at all.
That's what I'm just making, I'm Scottish.
You ate the jabbernut, now you can understand the language of the Minnish.
I think I'm just going to have to make my hat Scottish
because I can't for the life of my mix of these.
Make sure it's all the...
Wait, what do I need dinner?
I can eat, do I go back to the abbey?
So you've eaten the jabbernut,
is you're eating the jabbernut yet?
And now you can understand us.
Yeah, sorry, but I know a little bit about the sewers.
I'm just the elder.
I'm sure the elder can help.
Yeah, yeah, head over to the elder.
Yeah, you're not my problem anymore.
Now you've got the jabbernut inside you.
Okay, to the elder.
Hello.
Bro, I'm out of accents.
Well, I'm making French.
Oh, you must...
You speak our language?
It's been quite a while since we've heard of outsiders
speak our tongue.
We have a little to offer you in these woods.
But please enjoy your stay.
Thank you for your...
Thanks for your offer,
but we have no time to relax.
My name is Ezlo.
This trial is link.
We need to break a curse
that has been cast on the Princess of Hyrule.
To do so, we'll need to reforge the broken PCORI blade.
Yes, you have come.
You're now hoping to have the blade reforged.
I will...
If that is what you are after,
you need firm mystic elements.
We...
Wait, wait.
These elements are the chrysaline
firms of the energies of this world.
Only by infusing the blade with these energies
can a new blade be forged.
Yes, so here.
Give me your map.
I can mark out where these three elements are.
Three elements can be found as three elements.
Oh!
Oh, these elements, not three.
I've not got my glasses on.
The earth element can be found in the shrine
to the enough of Fastari's army.
Speak with the Fastari.
He will show you the path to the shrine's entrance.
Go without caution.
Go with caution.
Evil creatures have a little middle home in our shrine.
Yes.
Wait.
Speak to me at once,
if you have found the earth element.
Okay.
As a French, that makes sense.
Perfect.
Forget it.
French people cannot stop themselves from going...
That's the only...
If you ever want to assimilate as a French person,
just go...
In between your sentences
and instantly you're French.
You used to go to the shrine very well this way then.
I will be settled in recently.
Just be careful.
It's a bit dangerous.
We need an Aussie accent somewhere.
Oh!
Oh, sugar.
I forgot to pick this up.
We'll pick it up.
We'll pick it up on the way back.
Don't let me forget this.
Equals French.
You can hug the upper right side of the tower for a heart.
Yeah.
I was talking about there being monsters inside, didn't I?
Hey, now.
There's no reason to be afraid of anything.
I'll be waiting right here though.
No, wait.
What am I saying?
I'm not letting you leave me alone out here.
No, because you're not being myself.
Right, I can't...
I don't have the sucky pot yet.
But there should...
There is a heart piece in here.
Can you guys see that fine?
Does the brightness seem fine?
Because I keep mentioning this.
My Crash Bandicoot stream.
The display was correct for me, but wrong on stream.
You've got a small key.
Use it to open lock doors and blocks.
You can use it only in this dungeon though.
It's all good.
Good to go.
Okay.
There's a lock door here.
See if you can find the key to...
I'm a few steps ahead of you, but it's okay.
Maybe just a little bit drop on you.
Honestly, I thought that was really creative.
Do you see that level?
I think you should be able to pull it.
Just stand in front of it and press and then grab it.
Then use...
Pull it.
Look at this detail.
If you keep pushing, the space turns red.
Like, come on.
I have to admit, Nintendo cooked a little bit for this one.
Mug.
Not today.
Wait, is this...
Yeah, if you want to do a little backtrack and just do that.
Well, they'll have a grunk.
Right, you cannot hurt these guys yet.
Whoa, look at the size of that barrel.
Yeah, how silly, but sorry.
It's not big, we're just small.
Sorry, sorry.
Forgot about that perspective and everything.
You know what I mean?
I mean, you've got to respect him.
Sorry about that.
You cannot hurt these guys yet,
but you have to like push them out of your way, basically.
Is there anything up here?
No.
I love the Game Boy Zelda games.
They're fire.
What's the other Game Boy Zelda games?
I might have to give it a try.
So don't mind us.
Just scoo...
scoozy me.
A little bit of scoochy cream.
Push it in.
That's the budget.
Push it real good.
So we have now unlocked the barrel,
so it can now rotate when we're inside.
So all we need to do is...
Oh, here, I think.
I think.
What?
Hey, be careful.
I'm allowed to barrel just moved.
Wait, maybe?
Is this one quick?
Is it?
No, I'm getting rabied.
Is this one first?
Is it?
No.
Wait.
Ah, it was that one.
I knew it was that one.
I'm just thinking of you.
The link to the path.
I played the hiccup.
Link's awake.
Maybe we should give it a shot.
Is it easy?
This is supposed to be a kids game,
but I have to admit,
the boss fight at the end...
God, it's three hits now.
The boss fight at the end?
No bueno.
So we just want to do...
I see the heart.
So we're going to push that out
so we have access to what was here.
I don't know.
No.
Ah, don't destroy this paw.
What we need now
is starting to hold down the switch.
Wait, I'm on it.
I'm on it.
Then you worry.
Just don't play Metroid Fusion.
10 out of 10.
I hate it.
What?
Oh, 10 out of 10.
You hate.
Wait, is this a shortcut as well?
Yeah.
I'm just going to make sure
we've unlocked all the way
shortcut things along the way,
because...
Once you take hold of Sotun
with mm-mm-mm-mm,
you can push a pill
that should be extremely important.
So I hope you take these pointers.
There you go.
I will.
I'm taking the pointers.
There we go.
Sorry.
I'm having a stroke there.
Hold on a minute.
Use it to unlock the doors.
Absolutely.
2D Zelda game
didn't really change anything.
I already...
I pushed that, but it reset.
They announced a new 2D Zelda game
where you play as Zelda.
Okay, wait.
Maybe I will have to check out
Nintendo Direct,
because if it's cute,
but it's kawaii-nee,
they've got me in a choke hole.
I can't believe the stereotype
of girls playing games
because they're cute is real.
You found the dungeon map.
Okay, let's go.
Now what?
Oh, we got...
Oh, did I just swap that around?
I'll survive.
It's Ogre, the new Zelda.
Literally, these gender norms have hands.
I can't believe it.
What do you mean I'm only going to play a game
because it's cute?
What do you mean that
Viva Pina is the most adorable thing
and they should remaster it?
They're just the perfect little...
Open...
Cuman.
What's the plan?
What's up here?
Is there something up here?
Is there something down there?
Is there something for everyone?
Right.
Will we go that way first?
We'll go down first since this...
I like how they were like,
no, you're not going to lose any health
for not being able to judge the...
the distance.
Nice to see you play a classic.
Yeah.
I'm like trying to do
one childhood game
so I can show you guys
like how I'm cultured.
Oh!
I actually lost some health for once.
So you need to move this one out of me.
Yes, I'm trying to do at least one
childhood game every week.
Did I say a month?
I think I might have said a month.
Every week type thing.
This is just exciting.
You...
The one thing I like about this game
is you can spam the sword
and nothing can hit you
because they have to bounce back.
It's actually a really good design.
I'm sorry.
I said it.
It's a really good design.
Okay, we've got Pina.
Any Halo players?
Absolutely.
So a Halo campaign
can be played multiplayer,
which I'm interested about
possibly grabbing some worlds for.
I don't know
if I'll need to hunt for each of them.
That play Halo or maybe.
Azura really surprised me.
Oh, there's a heart.
I got freaking jumped here.
See you, you wee bam.
Oh, fuck I missed.
Sorry, hold on.
See you, you wee bam.
There.
Right, I'm pretty sure
we get this weapon in here.
So I want to go in here.
It's Black Ops to the childhood game.
I'd say Black Ops one hour.
Oh my god, maybe.
So this wiggly worm,
he becomes enraged,
but don't worry.
You just need a boofy snoop.
I just got booped in.
Aha, you know that.
And you need to hit his butt.
Take this.
Take his spanking.
And he just runs around
like a wiggly worm.
And he spank his nose.
And then you go get his boinkins.
Spank that boink.
And now
we have the gust jar.
Hold the button to draw things in
and release to fire them out.
Set it to air B in the tail screen.
So the one thing that's a bit
hard about this game
is there should be a heart down here.
Yes!
I got a piece of heart.
I only need two more.
And I think there's one more in here.
I mean, I guess we could open up this,
but I just don't like doing anything.
Give him the souk jar.
Now
I don't know what one it is.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, you can like find hidden things.
Ten mysterious shells.
We don't know what the shells are for yet.
Oh, I don't know.
So all those tiles that are like dusty
basically
we want to clean them up
because I think they give like hidden
rewarding stuff.
But we can just do it like that.
It's up.
Oh, we've unlocked a portal to that heart.
That's so good.
Okay, so when they have no dust on them,
they're vulnerable.
When they have no dust on them,
Did we get anything
if we could perish them all in this room though?
No, we didn't.
I think there's a chest under this one
because look at the fireplace.
Yeah, look at the fireplace, man.
The game like literally screaming in your face
like there's something hidden here.
Please look for it.
Okay, I don't think we have to do them all.
I guess super suck.
Can I suck them?
Oh, I can.
Man, push it.
Now there's a puzzler.
I suspect there's not much more we can do here right now.
Let's press on.
Perhaps we can work this from another angle later on.
So the game, right, I got a bit...
Wait, wait, wait.
Can I touch that chest?
Sorry, let me touch that chest.
I never even tried.
The game is very nice.
Yeah, okay, we can touch it.
Listen here then.
I thought remember.
You got a compass.
Use it to find locations of hidden items.
I don't remember this in childhood.
Oh!
Wow, big.
Big, big, big, big.
Okay, head up back out.
Okay, just start again.
I almost certainly touched the chest.
A new hand touches the chest.
Do you want to touch the chest?
Wow!
Oh, I will say one thing about these older games.
It hurts my soul when you, like,
defeat the enemies, but they don't stay defeated.
That's the only thing that hurts me.
Okay, we've got our mysterious shells.
Oh, mysterious shells.
Wait, wait.
No, we need to fall down in here.
Are you ready for Lily Padling?
Can I hurt you from here?
I can!
The game actually registers as a different height.
No war.
Unless you find a way to travel by water,
we want to be going much farther.
We are now going down Lily Pad Lover's Lane.
And then I just pop it.
I'm actually surprised the game registers height like that.
I thought I could kill that, but I don't know.
I can't believe it.
They actually made a quality game.
I don't know how close they need to be.
Yeah, there we go.
Um, I think it's just a reward if we go this way.
Oh, no, it's not.
There's a key.
We need a key, but we don't have it.
Lover's Boatwright Destroyer.
Literally, we're on Lily Pad Lover's Lane or something.
All the raids are always called that Lover's Lane.
It comes to those romantical ones.
A bit romantical.
Right, this one.
Oh, I could probably actually use that one.
Oh, Lover.
We just need a classic pot on the switch.
Very good game.
Yeah, like, see how I wasn't even facing that enemy,
but the game was still like, yeah, you got him.
Have I got my blank?
Ah, my blank is not here.
I'm gonna have to come back.
I'm gonna have to go get him.
Because I'm hurting my leg.
I'm killing the circulation.
Oh, this is not looking good.
Got a small key.
Yeah, you don't have to specify it small
every time you talk about it, okay?
I'm starting to feel personally attacked
and I don't even have any in there.
And the game cannot stop.
Yay.
Set properly.
Literally, my legs are against the table
and it's caught in circulation.
I should take a picture of my legs
to show you how severe it is.
I'll maybe do that.
Oh!
Link.
Buddy.
Small key to go with that
embarrassingly small shield.
Literally, I was like, wait a minute.
This is the dialogue I was...
Oh!
I thought, I thought, I was just like,
have I done that wrong?
No, I can suck on this.
Oh, dude.
What did we get?
You got the big key.
Oh, thank you, game.
You're so nice.
Thank you for complimenting me.
I appreciate it.
Oh, we can get that other heart piece.
I think I got it.
Okay, let's grab that now.
See, if I grabbed that one at the freaking start,
we would have had a new heart container.
Link is the reason there's a main-the-gap scene.
I don't really remember if it's left or right.
Oh, oh, it doesn't matter.
We got 20 rupees!
We're rich!
Gold!
We're rich.
Okay.
That's an impressive amount of suction.
Thanks!
I'm sure if I was more awake,
I could probably do something right now.
Was that a joke?
Oh, wait!
Something, something, suck.
Oh, no, it didn't open up my little sound thing.
You guys can't hear it.
Hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
Let me open it up.
Sorry, sorry.
Something, something, suck.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
You're far too kind.
Right, you ready for first boss fight?
Wow, that was really funny.
Yes, exactly.
No, please laugh.
Wow!
It's a little slamer.
Right, you ready for first boss fight?
Can we do it?
Oh, no.
He's coming through into the temple.
So you have to suck his bottom.
And then he'll get a wobbly head like that.
And he'll follow you and like collapse on you.
And then you just...
Okay, and then he gets back up again.
That boss literally being...
Is that how I would defeat you?
Just give it a little cheeky.
And then he gets quite a bit strong...
Oops, sorry.
I pointed the wrong way there.
Okay, and then, yeah.
It's a really good boss fight.
I think it's really...
Oh!
I can't hit the button any faster.
I think he jumps for a bit now.
You don't want to...
Oh, wait, no.
I think he infinitely jumps.
Oh, no, he doesn't.
I lied.
He doesn't infinitely jump.
I don't know why I thought he did.
Oh, he's almost there.
He's so skinny.
Oh.
Now, if we have done it correctly,
he should be down when he foxes we had done.
There we go.
Spam, spam, spam!
Hey!
We did it!
Yippee!
First boss down.
He'll send it to the music.
Okay.
Danny turned the game up.
We have gained the earth.
You got the earth element.
The power of the earth is the source of all living things.
The earth element is the embodiment of that power.
Sounds like a lean acquire.
You got a heart container.
Your life energy has increased and has been replenished.
Pushybee, strongy shoots down the slime.
I just...
Right, I'm happy to discuss this.
No, there is absolutely no slime in development for Gen 2 or Gen 3.
I have no interest in the slime.
Slimes are incredibly hard to design.
Like, if you think of Sue from Monster Musume and all of that,
it's just...
There's nothing to it.
There's nothing fun about it.
Just any...
Now, for a Halloween outfit, sure.
The girls can go nuts if they all want to slime variations.
Sure, knock yourself out because there's going to be nothing to it.
Ah, we've got the earth element.
We've got the earth element.
You must go and tell the elder at once.
Unfortunately, I don't think we can come back and get this heart until later,
which is fine.
It's not actually a big deal.
But I know for a fact I'm going to forget it's there.
And then I'm going to be like,
Eh, where are all these hearts hiding?
That doesn't...
Okay, well, we'll have to do that then.
Yeah, so there's no slime in production.
So, you have found the earth element.
You are blessed with much courage and strength for once young.
If you are...
If you are conviction and strong,
head to Mount Crennel.
There, you will find a man named Meliari among all of the Minish.
There is no one more able to repair your sword.
If you ask him,
I am certain you will reforge your broken pecorri blade.
I shall send the world to him in advance.
Travel safely, you are brave,
but there are so many evil in the world.
I'm so sorry if there's any French.
Dsol, Franais.
People.
If you screw the door here,
it will take you out of the forest.
Great Eldor, we are in your debt.
We shall head for Mount Crennel at once.
Oh, excuse me.
Sorry, excuse me.
Oh my God!
Oh my God, we need to...
We need to make our village like
hobbit and Minish related and
like this is so cute.
Imagine everyone had their own bedroom
and then like one by one I come and wake you up
and maybe not wake you up
but just in my room.
Alright, what's going on in this mushroom?
Hi!
Hello!
Green clothes
and a mystical eye.
Can we hear Brian?
I'm one of the reeflings you beat in Connect 4,
so I'm dumb,
but I'll catch up tonight either way.
Enjoy it strongly.
The members stream is a tier list.
It's not like any game player or anything.
Thank you, Tiny Spiny, for the tip.
I appreciate it.
Strongie is so anti-slim
because she wants to turn herself into a slim cutfish.
Just feel like reeflings look so slim now.
Green clothes and a mystical hat.
Sir, would you have a chance to be linked,
the one who found the earth element?
Surely you are.
I've heard so many tales about you.
I am Belary,
researcher of antiques.
I am also, oh well, a bit of an inventor.
You know, you won't be able to get back to your town
due to all the debris.
Here, I have something that might come in handy.
Bomb bag!
And it has 10 bombs in it.
Now you can blow up lots of stuff.
For free?
Let me know if you find it useful.
Sure, thank you so much.
That was so kind of you.
I appreciate that.
I now have Bomba.
The child now has access to C4.
We will check these.
Holder of the Sacred Powers.
We grant you the power of wind.
Well, it blew up.
Hey kid, look where that stone marker used to be.
There's some strange symbol on the ground.
Yes, of course, why this must be...
Well, I haven't the foggy, to be honest with you.
We will learn later what that does.
If I go up, what's up?
Minish stuff.
Minish stuff, don't mind me.
We are not ready.
So we're going to equip our Chicky Bomb.
Chicky Bomb de la.
We cannot use our sword against that,
so we're just going to have our freakin' C4 out.
Um...
Where did you come from?
I can't remember what's over here.
So let's go for it.
Oh, Bomba.
Okay, what's in here?
Thank you, Meat Man 53, for becoming a Mimble.
Hello.
Hey, look at this Kinstone piece.
Have you ever seen one like this?
What?
You don't know what a Kinstone piece is?
Well, I'll tell you what.
Why don't you come back and see me when you get one, okay?
Okay, we need to go into town
and unlock Kinstone pieces next.
And then we'll come back to this nice little...
Oh, there's a Bomba.
There's a lot of things that need bombs.
Holy crap.
They were like, yeah, you unlock bombs now?
Oh, there's bats!
I don't want it to hurt me.
I got 20.
Whoa.
Mysterious shells.
I don't want to fight those guys because they're stinky.
I will bomb this though, just so we have access to the path.
Oh, you know what?
Well, we're here.
We're actually at the start of the forest.
I'm going to pick up that other heart
because that will be our fifth heart container.
Sorry, sorry.
I know I'm backtracking better than I know.
I know, I'm sorry.
Hey, you forgive me?
Oh, I just made that fall off.
What was up here again?
I already forgot.
Did I even check?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Can't swim yet.
Can't swim.
That comes later.
We'll very quickly grab the heart of...
Peter, Andre, Jumpscare.
Was that his song?
Like, Mysterious Girl.
I remember...
Right, this is just so British, yeah?
So if you have no idea who Peter, Andre, or Katie price is.
Ta-da!
We now have five heart stones.
That's magnificent.
Magnificent.
This game only has four dungeons, right?
Yeah, we are technically one fourth of the way through the game.
Because once you pick up all the elements,
things go very quickly after that.
Like, very, very quickly.
Okay, we are now going to hit the town, boys.
And now that we have a sword,
we can clear out any stuff that's in the way.
High rule town, so it's no longer in celebration mode.
Oh.
Come one, come all!
See how many kingstone pieces you can collect.
You never know what fusing kingstones will do,
but it's sure to be good.
Come on up and get your free kingstone bag
for holding your kingstone pieces.
Don't miss out on this incredible
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity.
Yes, yes, you're here for your free kingstone bag, aren't you?
That's right, maybe you didn't hear me,
but they're free for all kids right now.
You got king, kingstone bag.
You can now carry kingstone pieces,
so we're going to go back to that other one.
This guy looks like a scumbazer.
Fitting two kingstone pieces together
is called kingstone fusion.
If you get two pieces to fit perfectly,
great happiness will come your way.
I'll put the kingstone pieces in your kingstone bag
so you can give it...
If I read kingstone one more time, you're done.
You're done.
Nah, I'm not reading that.
Anyone who's willing to fuse the stones
would look like how I do.
When you see that look in their eyes,
that's when you press the left trigger.
Use to choose the kingstone pieces
and press this button.
Did you catch all of that?
Yes, do not ever repeat that again.
Yes.
Then stand in front of me and press E.
Yes, yes, that's it. Press E.
What does it do?
The pieces fit together.
Maybe something good will happen.
Free kidney stones?
Wow, where's that?
I think that's bottom right of our house.
So we'll give it a little check.
We'll give it a check.
It is bottom right of our house.
I knew it. I knew it.
I recognise it.
A perfect fit.
That means we're both dudes for happiness soon.
I'll see you.
Okay.
Now, in order to acquire these pieces,
you basically just get them naturally
from cutting grass and stuff
and doing your chores.
They appear out of the bushes.
And you can buy them in a shop as well.
But of course, none of them are spawning.
That would be far too easy.
Maybe in the grass?
Hello, is anyone hating the grass?
Nothing is spawning.
I wonder if we have to progress again a bit more.
Not one piece in the grass.
Oh, spider!
We're fine, we're safe.
Bruh.
Nothing is spawning.
I mean, I'm not going to say no to the rupees
because we're going to have to end up buying them.
They're a rare drop.
Oh, we got a heart!
You got a piece of a heart.
Collect four to make energy.
I didn't think they were that rare.
Oh!
There we go.
These mystic stones bring happiness.
Yes.
I didn't think they were that rare.
I think they're relative.
Holder of the sacred powers,
we grant you the power of the wind.
Hey!
Oh, sorry.
You know what?
No matter how many times I see that,
it still rouses me
because he doesn't know what the symbol is.
Right, we're going to go back to that little guy
because he was really excited
to tell us about Kin Stones or something.
Where was he?
He was down here.
Hi, buddy!
We're back!
Just like you asked.
Right, what would you like to tell us
about these magical Kin Stones pieces?
Hello!
I just planted a big old bean.
It hasn't sprouted yet
but when it does, I'm going to be...
If it hasn't sprouted,
but when it does,
it's going to be a big sucker.
Don't say it.
Don't say it, chat.
Don't say it, refunds.
Okay, I guess he's telling us
that the bean stalks
will grow
via Kin Stones.
That's the only thing I can...
Shut up!
Wow, there's so many enemies in that area.
Right, I'm not bothering.
Oh!
That's what I get for not paying attention.
I'm just getting absolutely
blasted at what it was.
Is there anything else in town we can do?
We might be able to speak to the martial artists.
Do you know that?
Hello!
Oh my god, it's the wee chickadee!
Oh my god, he's so cute!
He's a thing.
Hello?
Speak.
I am Swiftblade,
finest swordman in all of Hyrule.
If you train with me,
I guarantee that you will increase your skills dramatically.
So, would you like to train here?
Yes, please.
We shall start with the most basic of all techniques.
I shall teach you
the spin attack.
First, press and hold your sword button.
Second, build up enough power.
Third, release your destructive might.
That's all, young swordsman.
Do you understand?
Yes.
Ha ha ha!
Very good.
You are a very quick student.
But you must feel the technique,
not just hear about it.
That's why I will now possess your body,
so as you demonstrate the technique,
I call this the
Swiftblade Position Technique of Training.
Watch this!
Position!
Yeah!
Phew!
Now you must try it yourself.
Press and hold your sword button.
Build up enough power.
Then release your destructive might.
That's all there is to it.
Yeah!
Yes, fine work.
You're a quick study.
I will now give you this Tiger Scroll.
If you ever forget this technique,
you can review it with the scroll.
You may view it at any time from the quest screen.
You learned the secret spin attack,
baiting technique.
This is the first sword technique
you've learned from Master Swiftblade.
Right, we're going to leave and come back in
because he might teach me something new
because I unlocked the Earthstone.
There are no more techniques I can teach you
with your current sword.
Okay, okay, when we upgrade your sword.
This guy is treating us like the kings
under a prana.
Aw, that's so cute!
Oh, I just remembered.
If you clear this up,
there should be a new guy that comes in.
Aw, I think it's a kinsome guy, actually.
Oh my god, there's a bakery?
Oh my god, reeflings!
What do you want to eat?
Sniffs it?
Mmm, doesn't that smell spectacular?
Perhaps they give you free samples.
I say, would you ask for me?
Do reeflings want sandwich,
a pie,
a croissant,
or a bread?
Sand.
Oh, you want sand?
Okay, sand.
Sand.
Good morning.
Uh, Ichi-sando?
Please?
Welcome!
You've come to the one and only
bakery of Wheaton & Pitter!
As in, Wheat & Pitterbread?
Wheat on Pitter!
Whoa, you don't need to jump on her in the bakery.
This tasty slice of cake,
which may or may not have something special inside,
it's a moist and cream filled
bargain. It's only 60!
I don't have 60 rupees on my...
I'm a child!
Jeez, how much is this then?
How much is the pie?
Welcome, you've come? Yeah, no, no.
A slice of her fantastic fruit pie,
which may or may not have something inside.
40!
I'm a child, lady!
Jeez, Louise!
Right, you guys are getting a croissant and taking it, right?
Yes, yes, yes.
Right, how much is a croissant?
Okay, it's there.
You guys can eat the croissant,
sit down, shut up, and eat it,
because I know you didn't want it,
but you can still get it.
Oh, you got a kid's stone face!
Thank you, refling!
Thank you for not swallowing it.
I didn't really want it if it came out long ago.
Hmm, hmm.
Must make deliciousness.
Aww, it's so cute.
Did you enjoy it?
I want its anger.
I'm too poor, okay?
Look,
you gave me an entire generation.
I have five kids to look after.
I have reflings to look after.
And I might currently be pregnant
with Gen 2.
I don't know yet what's happening.
Uh, right.
Is there anything else?
The dog's in the way, so that's locked off.
We can give you more generations,
but my pie!
I'm not money enough.
I don't have enough money.
What do you think?
Speak.
Well, if it isn't Link,
it is good to see you again.
The school is in session.
I'm afraid I can't let you in.
Oh my god, that's right.
He's like a literal child
going about the map health.
What are you?
Buggy buggy boo.
Did I scare you?
No.
Oh, there's like this silly chicken game.
Oh no, this is horrible.
My cocoons have gotten out.
Can you help me catch them?
Try to catch two of them, please.
Yoink!
Get back in the pen!
Okay, we only need two, so that's fine.
Is that making a weird noise?
It sounds like scratching.
Weird.
Oh, there's a golden one.
I got a golden ch-
Ah!
Get back here!
No, you're going back in your pen.
Naughty chicken.
Okay, time's up, that's it.
Thanks, here's your reward.
Ten seers-
What did I do with the shells?
Oh, she gave me 30 rupees.
Maybe I can get your sandwich.
A literal child being sent to just kill a wizard.
I love those memes that are like,
summarise the game in one sentence,
like completely out of context.
Child sent to kill wizard is pretty accurate.
Alright, what do I even need to do?
Sorry.
I am having a fun time just giving off
and enjoying this game for what it's worth.
Oh!
Sorry, I got a little excited looking at the water there.
Bees!
I don't want to take them yet
because I don't have anything to put them in.
There was an enemy up ahead.
Next time we go back to town,
I will get your cake.
Even though-
Oh!
Well, we can't go that way.
Hold on.
We need to go up.
Every additional chicken gets you more money
even if it's for going on.
Ah, okay, okay.
So I should get going.
Oh!
He wants to do that thing.
You want to fuse Kinstone?
Yeah, but-
Ah, I don't have what you need.
What about you?
I don't have what both of them needs?
What are the odds of that?
Now we're getting there.
You fuse.
Come.
Ah, come.
But they aren't open yet.
Hmm.
Okay.
Hello, can I get that?
Ho, ho.
So you've learned to spin attack.
It's still dangerous, but maybe you can handle it.
Oh, I didn't even know I needed that to progress.
Yeah, that's the one.
But there are monsters out there, kid.
Please just be careful.
I think he blocks you from going anywhere.
Okay.
It's two hits.
That's fine.
What are these?
Can I break them?
I can!
Well, I'm not fucking picking them all up manually.
Just down here.
Oh, Bomba!
They have got some timer on them.
Hello!
Oh, this is a merchant.
Hold on.
You need a dinkum.
Okay, you got me.
Let me make it up to you.
You can have this.
Do you have lots of bottles for 20?
Sure.
Give me up.
You got an empty bowl.
Thanks a lot.
Yes, we needed the bowl for...
Actually, we need...
This was...
I didn't even remember it was down here.
We needed the bowl for...
If not, we'll just have to make do with your cake instead.
How the frickin...
How did you guys do that?
That's really coordinated.
I'm sorry.
That's really coordinated doing that.
Here.
No, literally.
The only time you guys are like mega-coordinated is...
What's that?
Which is actually really funny.
Okay, there's nothing up here that we can do yet.
Reefling?
Hive?
Main?
I can't believe it.
Main broken?
I'm not even spanked at the first one yet,
where I get you to rename yourself for an hour or so.
Okay, this is why we need water.
Because it grows the beanstalk!
And then we'll grab more,
because I'm like,
God, we're really low on bombs.
I actually don't know how to get more.
Sure, grab.
Put this one out for now.
We used our single brain cell for the forces to do.
Oh, I need it.
Sorry, there is a lot of menus, like, speak.
Okay, you got me.
I'll make it up to you.
A friend of mine in the cave just east of here in the Highlands
has an item if you're planning to ongoing.
It won't let you get to the top,
but it might just help you get started.
Okay, that's fine.
I need more Keith down peep heads.
What?
Hmm.
Right, we're gonna grab this money up here.
I guess like 20.
Oh, we're at 40.
I still don't have enough for your signage though.
Look up here, nothing.
Luckily, I already did that, literally.
I'm doing everything in the right order by accident.
Right, we can't grip the walls yet.
I might just...
Oh, wait, there's something hidden under these.
Whoa, they hardly get affected.
There's a lot of enemies in this area.
Geez, whoa, wait!
Is there not a hidden thing around here?
Is it this?
Wow, there's a lot of enemies.
Is this just a secret bomb place?
It looks like we should do something here.
I'll just stay here.
Yeah, I was gonna say, that looks so...
Like, there's totally not a hidden thing here.
Oh, jelly blobs.
There's a question about the mysterious shells.
I can't remember what they're for.
Geez, I have one bomb left.
Why am I going here?
I think I might need to put it in the bottle.
I hope you're having a good time.
I'm in the middle of the hammer, I need to play childing again.
Oh, I don't think jumping on a gem would feel that good on your butt, but...
I guess the smaller you...
So this perfectly normal looking...
So this perfectly normal looking stone was another portal of the Minish world.
There may be other rock portals.
Keep your eyes peeled, boy.
Increase your chances when going for a figurine.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I can't.
If the enemies aren't attacking me, there's no point in...
Okay, yeah, I definitely need this liquid.
Why is it...
You've got Mount Serial's mineral water in your bottle.
It's piping hot?
Hmm.
Right, I'm going to detach it because I don't want to accidentally use it
because I definitely have to use it for something coming up.
Green mineral water.
You've got acid, literally.
See you, Yibi.
I know you can.
I only have one bomb left.
I don't want to use it on...
Oh, I'm sick.
There's a lot of merches nearby.
Hello.
Okay, you got me.
I'll make up to you by selling your bombs.
Wait, I've only got one bomb left?
Right, right.
Give me the freaking bombs over.
Yeah.
Thanks a lot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm confused.
I have it!
The two pieces fit perfectly together.
Yibi!
A chest?
Okay, that's fine.
We do not have access to that area.
Unfortunately.
That's okay.
I might have to start scraping by and trying to pick up coins
because it's not looking good.
Okay, I see they purposely put that bomb there
because...
Hey, that guy.
Yeah, literally, they put a nice bomb cellar nearby
in case you're out,
and I'm like, yes, think of it.
It's so smart.
Oh, I don't know how far this goes.
Either a lot of acid or that's plankton.
Oh, I think...
Once you've pulled off their iron mask,
those guys are no trouble whatsoever.
I think we'll just avoid them, to be honest.
We don't really need to fight everything.
Of course, I'm silly of me.
Hey, my boy.
Jump into that whirlwind over there for me.
I wonder, is this a great idea or a terrible one?
I'll beat the crap out of this one.
Okay, now this becomes the fun part.
We're really...
Oh, I can't go up.
Oh, there we go.
I can't go up.
What's...
Ow!
What's over here?
Where's some more?
Eh?
There's a path.
Oh, well.
Tell me a bomb doesn't belong there.
You can't...
What's in here?
Okay, I'm gonna bomb for that.
Wow!
It'll take us down to five bombs.
Getting this, but we're gonna do it.
We're gonna send it.
Oh, a special Kingston piece.
It was blue, so I guess...
I'm 50!
I can buy your sandwich even though it's a cake!
But it looks like a sandwich,
but it makes sense that it was a cake because it's a bakery.
Leave me be, fellow beast.
Okay, this one looks like a succumon.
Oh, that's where the deco's!
That's where the slain...
I knew something had to be sucked up over here.
Wow!
150 rupees for a sanda.
Oh, hi!
See that?
See how we just sucked it up,
but it's already spun back in?
I wish they didn't do that.
Oh, wait!
I can't do that yet.
I need to move it.
Oh!
Wait, do I need to go there then?
Into the hole!
Okay.
We're gonna do it!
Oh!
Sorry, I got a bit excited there.
My biggest downfall in video games is just gaps.
I can't do it.
Who is putting this kind of shit?
Wait!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, this can't be.
I think I have missed a very detrimental item question mark.
Oh, I'm done again.
Sorry, sorry.
There was a gap.
I am 99.9% sure I need some sort of weight lifting thing here
to move the plant over.
Oh, sorry, I'm getting caught.
And I don't have a...
Where is it?
Lift!
Wait!
Link!
You can just straight up lift that?
I thought there was some sort of item.
Is that later in the game?
Fuck it now, he's at time!
Sorry.
Oh, well, I did what I needed to do,
even if I sacrificed some of my health for it.
I did what needed to be done.
I don't even know how he's this strong.
I can't believe it.
Sorry, I'm wasting all my health.
Right, the reason why we need the green is this.
And now we are on Mount Creronell,
not to be confused with Mount Serials.
I used to see as a child.
I'm so funny as a child.
Okay, this is definitely a bomb.
Sorry, my stomach's making funky noises.
Let's hear it.
Weakest wiefling.
Oh, no way that dodged that.
That was like really good timing.
I wasn't here.
Another piece.
Curious.
Curious?
Hmm, curious.
Another piece.
Is the game telling me I should probably trade?
Whoa!
New enemy unlocked.
Okay, yes, I would like that heart very much, please.
I should have done that in the middle.
I just realized I wasted that.
Bomb bomb!
Oh, of course they have it in here.
Oh, wait, no!
I should have picked up.
Silly Billy.
Great.
I wonder if they always won.
I'm curious.
Well, I still have nightmares of the snake enemies that suck your money.
Give me your...
Aren't those just called women?
I'm sorry.
I tried so hard to make that joke really quickly.
It didn't work.
I don't need the wool.
I tried so hard to do that quickly and it completely started over my words
because my brain was like,
Yes, yes, the joke's there!
Say it, say it!
And, yeah.
Well, I tried, I tried, okay, I tried.
L'Bomba!
Wah.
Is he gonna give me the ring?
Are you kidding me right now?
Okay, fine, no, my money's getting sucked.
Okay, you got me.
I'll give you a fabulous grip ring.
It is perfect for a young mountaineer.
Climb 48.
Okay, lucky we got money on the way.
Thanks a lot.
Okay, now we can climb the wall.
Oh, we got five bombs again.
Oh, this is perfect.
Thank you.
K.F.P. Spidey.
Right, what way?
Short cut to bomb.
No, so what's up here?
Oh.
We can't do that.
So, this is not the right way to go.
Shawnee doesn't need the grip ring.
She has that cover!
It's the...
Lip set.
It's the R slash lip set grip.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, what?
So, where am I supposed to go?
Okay.
Huh?
Am I supposed to go to the left?
I don't want to go...
Okay, there.
This is it.
You know that subreddit?
Yeah, I'm featured on it right now.
I'm trolling before anyone fucking goes and knocks me in.
Like, oh my god!
No, no, really.
Right, definitely.
Ahoy!
It's Emmy!
Any embers?
Any pen pals?
Me.
Please talk to me.
Talk to me.
Why don't you talk to me then?
Wait.
No!
You put water in your bottle,
and then you give her water.
You take her water,
then you give her water.
Oh!
Welcome to the Adventure Spring.
Did you throw the golden bomb
into the spring or the silver bomb?
Neither?
You are honest.
I must reward such an honest adventure
with some of my power.
You got a big bomb bag!
Now you can carry more bombah!
Thank you, mysterious lady.
May light shine on your quest.
Oh, she's so ethereal.
I love her.
This song sounds so familiar.
Yes, it is.
It's like, pretty much the default, like...
Hey, Zelda.
Take her water, and give her water.
She was just happy to get a bubble.
They have a spring cone.
She just wanted to do a spring cone.
Ah!
I can't believe I suck.
Why is this...
I got a cavern.
I have a cavern.
There's a cavern.
I'm the Cranel, I'm the Cranel Hermit! I left the world to pursue a life of quiet reflection.
You seem to be but a child and yet you climb this forbidden mountain alone. I must reward
your courage with information. I have not seen a s- have you not seen strange patterned walls
as you climb this mountain? No? Bombs, bombs are the- oh he's telling me to nuke the fricking walls.
Yeah that's fine. The two kinstom pieces fit perfectly together, maybe something good will happen.
I didn't know you could take the water from the fairy town.
You learn something new every time you replay a childhood game.
What? How is that good?
How is that good? You've just- you've just created problems for me.
Okay, those are aggressive.
Ah! I don't know if I'll be able to- no I'm not gonna be able to in time, hold on.
Okay, suck them off. Get in my P.O.B.
Let's go. We are very high up if the- the fricking mountain top isn't even there.
Oh my goodness. All right, we can't do anything, we have to go- man we gotta go small.
Gotta take all off. Money? Oh is that what the golden snakes are?
They got Mario and Marshmallow doing here.
Oh, mushrooms-y owned by Nintendo.
These raindrops are like folders of water tails kid.
Watch out! If one of them hits us, it'll sting something fierce.
I'm getting rolled! Another good kind, I literally need new hearts.
I've only got three hearts. I'm drying them- wait can I push these? No I can't, I'm too small.
I'm just a baby. I'm gonna do a marshmallow.
Right, what do I need to do with this?
All right, I definitely need to push it that way. Then up. Then up again. Then a cheeky.
Left. Then up again. Then up again. Then a cheeky left. Then a left. Then a left.
Then a left. Then a no- then a down. And then a straight ahead.
Keep her going, keep her moving. Come on Link, you're so strong! You can do it! Link, you came to turn!
You came to save the Princess Zelda!
He's so strong. Oh, there's enemies at the bomb. Yeah, I knew it. I knew it.
We'll go this way, I think.
Uh, right, can I do this? No, let's do that one.
Oh my god, I'm literally guessing the freaking designer there lay out before- I've even activated it.
SHIT! I messed up. Oh, then he got all the way back because I messed up the last one I did.
Unless? No. What? Wait, unless. Hold on, unless we're being misled. Unless we're being misled!
It's your maiden smash force. I've never played it before. Should I play it before? Should I play it?
Thank you for the five delay lovers. Don't think I don't know your bleeding heart.
It's not a club, true name. I just think it's blood. Yes. I've never played it. I think Bayonetta.
Hold on a minute. Yeah, I saw that. I saw the pots and I was like, hold on a minute.
Is there pots on the other side? I think Bayonetta's in it, so I would probably play her when I play smash.
Wait, why are you lip-biting to that? Is that a game? Is that a sexy game? I thought it was Nintendo.
I was saying that Nintendo produced Bayonetta, which is like the most bomb shell. Is there something special in here?
Why are you hiding these pots from me? Oh, there's like a bomb behind them. Okay, that's fine.
I guess we need a bomb up ahead.
You can manually throw bombs if you need to. Okay, I don't really want to fight because I'm
pretty low health and not new health is spawning. Oh no, not another one of these, right? Okay.
Down, two left, and then down.
Okay, okay, okay, we're getting there. We're doing it. Then one, then up one, then left,
then north, then west, then push! We did it!
A scrawny can use her brain? Something.
Sugar, I might start up. Hold on, let me try that again. Wait, no.
Yeah, I can do it though. Okay, we did it, we did it, we did it, we did it.
Anagong, a special console piece. Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry. Easy as connect for my life,
honestly. Oh, we did it! Look, look, look, this is a Minish camp. We're going to the Dwarven Minish.
The Dwarves of Erebor. I may be a bleeding heart now, but after that carry on,
oh, you can be. I'm not like one of those streamers that kind of get uncomfortable. As long as you're
happy, I'm happy. You enjoy the content and enjoy the content, you know?
But yeah, you guys, guys, did you know you have an infestation out there? Yeah?
Thank you for the five again, Delay Lover. Hello! Ting-a-long, tong-a-long, dig-a-long,
fer-eye. Wait, they're actually Scottish? Ting-a-long, tong-a-long, dig-a-long, fer-eye,
and they're Scottish? Ting-a-long, tong-a-long, dig-a-long, dig-a-long, dig-a-long,
dig-a-long, fer-eye, and they're Scottish? In here? Oh my god, they have communal,
they have communal bedding. Reflings, this is what I want. Oh my god, they're Scottish!
Hi! Hello, everyone! Oh my god, it's the kitchen where I make all the fit for the
reflings. What's that? We're having chicken again tonight? That's right, I'll let you use chicken.
Are you Scottish? Wait, I think, wait, is it in here? No, this is just a smith's room.
Okay, I think it might be down in here. Okay, definitely not there, that's how to progress.
Hello! Hello, everyone!
Green Clays, and an old hat! Sir, may you be young Link? I am Mellari, Master Smith. I hear you want
me to reforge the sacred sword and help break a curse. I'll be needing that old sword, which holds
the power of the elements first. Show me that broken PCORI blades. I love all this adventure,
with what's with the rescuing of princesses and such. I'd be happy to reforge this thing into a
brand new sacred blade for you. It'll take me a while to rework that sword. In the meantime,
you should try doing the missing elements. One of them should be in the mind of the human
dog. It's not far from here. All right, let's get started. Bunk!
Eh, there'll probably be a wee while, Link. Let's leave him to it and find the element.
Oh my god, Scotland kind of mentioned, even though it's just in the dialogue,
but I'll take it Scotland mentioned. What? You're going to the mine? If you talk to the
boss, I'm no storm here, but just be careful, laddie. Who goes there? Samwise! What nice name!
Well, welcome to the members, gang. I'm so sorry about, please forgive me.
Okay, hopefully we can get a heart in the mine. Holder of the sacred powers.
We grant you the power of the elements. Wow! Hey, that stone marker crumbled,
and there's another one of those symbols! You know what? No matter how many times I see this
happen, it still rattles me a bit. Who's the 10 out of 12? That's a bit of a hi.
Whoa! It's hot in here. Come on, let's not stand around wasting time. Find that element so we can
get the heck out here. I'm going to smash these for heart. Yeah, normally the game is very forgiving
and gives you what you need before you go next. Bums! What happens?
Okay, hit them! Oh!
Oh, so they do blow themselves up.
Whoa, the bomb bag is there, eh? Where are you?
Your sword won't make a dent in their thorny. Flip them over before you strike.
With a shield? With a shield? I'm remembering! I'm remembering!
Oh, I need the money so I can get cake.
Okay, after this one, I'll call a break and I'm going to make another honey tea to help my
throat, okay? But we're about to get the second element, okay? That's right, we're just so MLG
poor. I knew it! He's humping me! He's humping me!
Jeez, Louise! That was sheebie and a half right there.
How is sheebie and a half? That's like sheebie doing it.
Dude, do I upset the bombs if I do? Oh, I don't even upset the bombs.
Okay, I upset the bombs when I do that. Okay, okay. Wow, more bomb back.
These snakes, I hate them, literally.
Oh! You know the Binding of Isaac, right? So Eddie McMuffin, the guy that made the game,
Big Eddie McMuffin, he said that he was inspired by Legend of Zelda and he also mentioned...
Oh! This might be where the humans who built the mines used to be around here,
maybe we should hop in. Wait, what, after all this? There's nothing to be afraid of here,
come on, let's go!
Um, sweet jumpin' jellyfish! That was awful! Hey, kid, what are you smiling about? I knew it was
madness to risk our lives in that rickety human contraption. From now on, let's just stick to
our feet. Well, I mean, your feet. Um, yeah, he said that he was inspired. Isaac was inspired by
Legend of Zelda and if you ever do the alt path and the mines and all that, this exactly reminds me
of it. Uh, it's very... Ah, you can't go behind me, that's cheating! Let me equip my bomb buck.
Just wanted to do it to get in here. I'll put my shield back on though, right, right over here.
The snakes are called like, like, more like...
Ooh! Wait, that bombies guys? I know I'm supposed to spank their butts, but they're kind of, they're
kind of winning. Okay, hold on. Okay, two hits and they're gone. What? You're not supposed to actually
charge me. I heard that roofie drop. Don't think I didn't hear that roofie drop.
I'm interested. So there was a portal heading away in here. Hmm. Whenever you want me to shrink
you down, just hop on there and press the button. You know the drill. Right, give me that. Oh, I
thought it was a roofie. It was a hot, it was a hot. You can suck their masks away. Oh, okay, okay.
Will we get an Isaac stream anytime soon? Like an Eden run? Probably Eden run, maybe on a shorter
day. My dad is coming to visit. I am so tiny right now. I can't go in that, can I? I think that
kills me. Okay, I'm not going there. My dad's coming home, my dad's coming home. So July,
first two weeks are going to be relatively, I say relatively short streams, depending on
how cool my dad is because I'm pretty loud when I stream, let's be honest. Jump down there?
That seems dangerous. I do see the thing though. Okay, no, it is done there. So yes, July is kind
of maybe like two to four hour streams for the first two weeks and then we just get straight
back into, again, straight back into Endurance. Don't mind me. We'll be careful at these fires.
They do restore health, so I'm not going to, I'm going to beat around the bush. Got a dungeon map,
so if I ever get a old discombobulated and where I need to go, right, these time out, oh,
I'm terribly, these time out, but they do come back. Hold on, let me aim this a bit better.
Probably keeping them with the blue ones. I think the blue ones must be a vent or something. Oh my,
it looks really, really hot in that lava. Trust me, me who'd literally just perish two seconds
in four. Trust me, falling into that would be a bad idea. I'm sure you'd agree.
Yeah, you'll find you'll be able to watch other lives consistent. Well, because I stream like a
normal streamer, like, okay, thank you. Thank you for the two hours. I'm all flying now.
I am. It does mean, I will say one thing, it does mean a lot of like Ace Marble plays in that.
It'll be easier to make. Wait, this crumbles? Well, I need to pick it up. Pick up the booze.
Oh, sorry. Oh, well, that worked out really well actually. I need to get rid of the fire.
Oh, I just spanked. I missed it perfectly. Oh my God, reflings, I can get your Sango.
Go away. Go away. Oh, no, I need money for a sign, bitch. Okay, then.
Um.
What did I do? I go all the way around? Oh, I must do. Okay, we use the worldwinds
for all the way around on a big U-turn. Did you see the new Zelda trailer? Not yet, no.
I would play it, but I'm pretty sure trailers get copyright. Like, I used to...
Wait, did I? Oh, right, I push it all the way over. I used to think trailers and like anything
gameplay related was like non-copyrightable because they like purposely make it not that way,
but I've got two false copyright notifications on my Skyrim stream and on my Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood stream. Oh. Um, but because it's a Skamas, I can't actually counteract it without
putting like the channel at risk. So like I'm not counterclaimed or anything. Um, it just is just
a bit sucky. Um, we are eating. Okay, we've changed the tracks' pathing now, so we're gonna get back
in the mine cart and I'm gonna explore the mineshaft. Oh, I saw that horrible. Oh, sorry,
I need shields for these guys. Yeah, yeah, yeah, take that muck. Triple... Well, double kill.
Not triple, because there's not three enemies.
Okay, definitely don't want to get pooped by the bats because the bats will shove you off that
map. No hesitation. Aren't these kind of strikes automatic because someone sampled it? Yes, I just
like, I looked it up like who claimed it because it looked like it looked like nothing from Bethesda
or anything of that nature. I was like, this looks so unofficial and then I found this reddit and it
was like filled with people saying that, oh god, we're hot. I didn't actually know it was down here.
Can I just one more? Okay, good, good, good. Um, yeah, it was just filled with this reddit and
everyone was taping the same thing. Like I was just casually playing this like game. Oh no, battle arena.
Oh no, it's the spakey cane. Oh, I'm scared. Oh no, please leave me alone. Can I get the
bill? Oh my god, I'm getting demolished. I'm just gonna spam. How about that? I'll just spam.
I'll just spam. Okay, I win. I win, no. I win, I win.
Okay, we did it. We did it, we did it. I didn't know I expected a freaking battle down there.
You've got the cane of a, I am not gonna say that. This mystical rod has the power to flip
things over. Use it to charge up energy and walls and fill it out. I don't, actually wait, I think I,
I think it's Passy, like pacifist and not the other word. If you are British, you know exactly.
Hey kid, why don't you take the cane of Passy and fire it at the hole? I mean,
you never know what'll happen until you try it, right?
These people living, why are you giving me a blue portal here?
Ah, we can flip this over. Let's go!
Oh, poor Link. He's so stressed.
Strony has found the rod. Everyone run. It's too late. It's too late.
I want to make sure I hit it from the right angle though.
Ah, okay, okay, okay, okay. Right, let's just go straight back then. Super easy,
peasy, lemon, squeezy. Oh, I tell you what we could do. We're gonna go back to the start to
pick up hearts and then come right back again. There should be, hearts always regenerate like
these. Yeah, let's play it nice and safe. I actually can't remember the boss fight in this one, you know that.
I always remember the slime one because I used to get stuck as a child all the time.
Am I supposed to flip this? No, there's no main shaft, crap. Okay, I'm to do this.
Okay, okay, it's fine. It's fine, relax. Well, on earth with those spiders though, I have no idea.
Or am I too small to activate them? I think I'm too small to activate the spiders, which is good.
We don't want to do that because I think they take some health. Time to get flipped with some
What? Oh my god.
Aye, those aren't spiders anyway. I can tell you that much. Let's get out of here.
Okay, and then flip the track and then let's go.
I love his little... Oh, sorry, I walked into it.
And then we just need to do this one like that. No.
Oh, I need... Can you come here? Oh, I've done it now, haven't I?
Okay, there we go, there we go. I was like, oh, we're gonna be stuck. Let's try a wee bit.
Beyblades, yeah, those Beyblades.
A horrendous evil nasty thing. Okay, let's get this switch in order and then we can
progress. I think we're almost at the boss. I feel like we've done enough.
Am I going crazy, but I can't do that because if I push that one, it blocks it.
I'm going mental, right? Oh, because I'm not to push it at all. I understand. I understand from
the other side. Sorry. I was like, my brain was like trying its best to figure out what on earth
the game was asking for me there. I was like, pretty sure this was impossible. Yay, we're getting so
many kinstones. Right, we can go this way.
My booty. Okay, we'll need to try that again. Sorry, a bit of a panic there. Let's let the game
do its thing, do its wee cheeky beeset.
Okay, it's just the...
You are wobbling a bit too quick for Malik and...
Oh, I didn't have time to react. I need to move the pots out the way.
Okay, let's go. There was a switch back there, which I didn't do. Hold on, I need to go back.
Oh no, I can't get this switch from that side.
If you could play one on one with a recently, what game would you absolutely beat as that Black Ops
one? Absolutely no contest. Absolutely not one of you has a Black Ops one skill like me.
Absolutely no contest. No hesitation. Oh shit, is this going to break by the time we get there?
No, I don't. Thank you.
Lies, you get smoke. Oh no, you do not understand. You do not understand. When I was peak like
try hard sweat on like S&D, Team Deathmatch domination, you do not understand. You have no
comprehension. And thank you for the tip again. What the fuck am I supposed to do? Sorry, I just...
Hold on. Oh, there wasn't even anything related to things in here. Thank you for the tip again.
But no, you genuinely have no comprehension how terrible you are at the game if you go against
me on it. So right now, smile. As for any other game that I'm good at, Black Ops 2, I was pretty
decent at. I'm pretty confident the MSC, that was pretty... I bloody enjoyed that.
Can I get up? Can I get up? Yes, I can get up. On PCS, I still think I destroy on an FES.
Halo terrible, halo. Oh goodness me, where am I supposed to go? Right, follow the wind. Follow
the wind and follow the rocks. The rocks are putting me here. Oh wait, there's like... Ah,
go back, go back, go back. There's a chest here. Cancel. Wait, oh, I can't get up there. Right,
sorry, my apologies. I was diamond in Overwatch. Oh, I was terrible. Wait, I definitely cannot go
past those rocks. So let's do this. I'm not very strong at Overwatch. It was... I just never
got good at it. I just played it for fun. I like being a heal bot on Mercy. But unfortunately,
Overwatch 2 happened and I completely fell out of love with the game, which is such a shame.
But I wouldn't mind doing like a... We all play it as refling. I wouldn't mind that just casually.
And I'll be screaming at you like, God, do this. Marvel, everyone was kind of dogging on it and
yes, yes, haha, funny. But Marvel rivals, I believe the game's called, actually looked pretty decent.
So as I did, I said it, it looked decent. I got a big key. Oh, I did it! We're here! Right, we're
going to go back and fill up our health. I just realized we did it. I was too busy rambling away
that we're actually at the boss. Right, we need to try hard.
The first Overwatch 2 trailer happened. Literally, we all should have seen it come in when Papa Jeff
left because Overwatch was his baby. Okay, whoa, I'm like a pixel off of getting Mars burnt.
Whoa, ready? Ready for a boss fight? I guess these are just hearts, yeah. Oh wow, okay.
I can't remember what happens in here.
Oh no.
Whoa!
Honestly, it looks like a really cool level of Pokemon.
Oh, you can throw fire at me? That's not very nice.
Take this! Okay, I missed. I think I'm supposed to flip his arse. No, no, clearly not.
I did! You are supposed to flip his arse. Okay, okay, okay.
Tapping his horn! Okay, that's the best I can do. Ow, I just freaking hurt myself.
Uh, I don't have a lava spell to save me. Hello?
Bruh, you better calm down with that lava spread. I don't know what you want from me.
Okay, boom! Get ready. No, okay, he's not vulnerable.
Have he's vulnerable? Vulnerable? No, not yet.
Vulnerable? Yes!
With all your might!
Yes! Okay, we did it, we did it, we did it, we did it.
This is all fire. Wait, oh, ow, my freaking head.
Okay, I'll take that. Yeah, this is all fire, which is not good for us,
because we need to be able to have mobility around the map, or we're in trouble.
Okay, okay, vulnerable. Okay, through your fire, that's fine.
We are too early, we are too early, we are too not in the right direction.
Nope, he's already adjusted. Stop adjusting! Bruh, that's a bit...
Bruh, I literally have no nubut, no nubut. Take that.
Okay, okay, one...
Okay, wow. I like it to teleport me on the fire, like rain between it.
Appreciate that, please don't do it again.
Oh, we did it!
Hello? Oh, I thought my game paused there, I was like,
I think we have an encounter technical difficulties.
We did it! What's the element? The fire?
Heat element? It must be heat. It must be, surely it's heat element.
You got the fire element. Flames bring light to darkness and warmth to all.
The fire element is the embodiment of that power. Fire girl confirmed for Jintu?
You got a heart container, absolutely gorgeous. I love me a heart container.
So you must get a heart container every boss you dealt with.
Oh, that was so hot, and I, it was... Oh, that was hot. It was so hot,
I thought my fibers would catch fire. Ah, but it's over now.
I suppose we should get back and speak to Malari.
Like Malari, or should I say we Malari?
Hello? Hello? Americano?
Wow, that was fast work, but not so fast that I didn't finish your sword.
Here, take a look. I call this new blade the white sword.
Well, it's green clearly by the handle, but whatever.
You got the white sword. It's, you got the white sword.
It's beautiful white blade sparkles with light.
You can put away your grandfather's sword now.
Oh, once you infuse it with the power of the elements,
it will become a sacred blade. The forest elder no doubt told you this part,
but if you want to infuse the sword, you must go to the elemental sanctuary.
The sanctuary is a strange realm, sorry I keep forgetting the voices,
trapped between two worlds. It is the bridge between the Minish world and the human world.
The doorway to the sanctuary opens only once every hundred years.
You'll find that door hidden within the castle.
Once that blade has been filled with the power of the four elements,
you should be able to break the curse of the princess,
and I know that you can do it. After all, you made short work of that human mind.
Let me tell you about a shortcut that you can get down through the mountain.
You'll find it right in front of the entrance of the mine you just explored.
You'll follow, just follow that and you'll be down in no time in the park.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you very much.
Thanks for making the sword, I appreciate it.
I appreciate it, love good sword moment.
Short cut through the mountain, that's in through the mountain.
Secret, secret, secret, secret, short cut.
Short cut to the bottom, a little to the right, okay.
To reflink, well no.
Short cut to the bottom, no, it's not to reflink.
To, ah, to lovers, forbidden from one another.
I mentioned divides their people, and the day didn't end.
Oh wait, I've said that wrong.
Wait, post the lyrics, post the lyrics so I can say it right.
I've messed it up, I've messed it up.
To reflink, well am I technically a reflink?
Yeah, I think so.
I love the environmental kills, they're quite sad.
Right, we need to go to the castello.
Hydration check, no, because then I have to make a cup of tea and I'll be awake.
Straining herself is the shortcut to the bottom.
Um, we got loads of stones, do you guys want to trade?
Wait, none of them?
No one wants to do kingstone pieces?
You want a fuse, yes please.
Wow, I've got it, I've got it, I've got it.
The two fit perfectly.
Two lovers, forbidden from one another.
A war divides their people, and a mountain divides them apart.
Built a path to be together, and yeah, I can never forget the next couple of lines,
and then it goes secret tunnel, secret tunnel through the mountain, secret, secret, secret tunnel.
And then everyone clapped as a mule.
I'd like to go down the stream.
Wah, chest?
Chest, yes chest.
So green is like money rewards, I guess?
Oh my god, who are you?
How can they make pixels so sexy?
We hear all sorts of interesting gossip in here.
Stop by from time to time.
Hello lady, I want a fuse canstone.
Whoa, how am I miraculously having the pieces that they want?
That looks like the cow farm, because of that little pitch on the side.
And everyone too.
She's got a mule too sharp, did they pixelate a mule on her?
No way, they freaking pixelated the milk mule, that's hilarious.
Right, what happens if I go tiny?
Please shrink me down, please shrink me down.
I have been educated, I've now learned where secret tunnel comes from.
Yes, it comes from Avatar The Last Airbender.
Did Emmy get to that episode?
I'm not sure.
She might have.
That's right, even human objects are porous in the Minish world.
These Minish may not look like much, but they are quite crafty.
Unfortunately, I think I need something to push that.
Oh hello, hi.
This cafe is so busy, you can hear all sorts of stuff from the people here.
Oh my god, their bed is a freaking take off!
Ah, I can't handle how cute this game is.
It's hard not to get stepped on when there are so many people here.
Their posters are stamps!
So cute, and look at their little light.
It's a wee globey thing.
And they got like a little baby!
Oh my god, they have baby pottery.
Look at the tiny plates and everything.
Oh my god, the floor is a menu!
Oh come on, you cannot tell me this game wasn't a passion,
a project of love from the development team.
It's so cute.
It's so kawaii.
How am I supposed to...
How am I supposed to do this?
It's so cute.
Wait, hold on a minute.
Are you squidding me right now?
Look at your avatar then asked the question again.
If you can look sexy...
It's the pixel girl can do.
Thank you.
You like my watermelon hair?
Thank you very much for the tip.
All right, the super chat.
Sorry, I'm not supposed to get them confused.
Wait, I want to talk to the chickadee!
Hello!
Hi, little baby.
Eep!
One of the menace.
Peep!
I'm not like my brothers.
I won't chase you around and pick you.
Not only that, I have some good info for you.
Somewhere in Hyrule, there's a great fairy
who helps honest adventures.
If you hear her, answer her every question truthfully.
You want to chit chit use kensun?
Oh, I'm so sorry!
Oh my god, look at this fucking wee icon!
That's the cutest thing ever!
Oh my god!
I'm so sorry!
I'll come back with kensun soon.
Go menace, sorry!
All right, what's over here?
I don't know.
There's a bush.
We can go inside this building.
Oh!
What is this?
There's construction men.
Hello!
The boss makes him rough,
but he's a real softy at heart.
Aww.
Now this kid is trying to eat stuff, though.
Hello!
Oh, you want to trade?
Yeah, let's view it.
Oh, I don't have any green.
Sorry.
Listen up.
I'm a skilled carpenter
and I'm looking for a challenge.
Uh, okay.
Hi!
I'm really quite good at tracking down rare figurines.
Okay.
Hi!
Hello, puppy!
Hello!
What is all this?
I'm busy.
Don't you see?
Do not disturb my research.
If you have no business, be gone!
Sorry, please.
Can I get any green kensun from here?
One green kensun.
One.
Fine.
I'll get a rupee.
I'll take it.
Hello!
Speak!
I collected those mysterious shells.
Ah!
I collect those mysterious shells
you've been scattered all over the place.
If you bring these shells,
I'll trade you these figurines I've made.
Ah, what is that mysterious shell?
Hmm, I've got an offer I'd like to make you.
What do you say for trading it
for a chance of winning a figurine?
Sure.
How many shells would you like to use?
The more shells you use,
the more likely to have a figurine.
Probability, 100%.
Well, I'll just use one.
You're going to trade one of them?
Great.
Now just pull the lever on the figure dispensing machine.
I will pull the lever.
Ego de...
Oh no!
Gacha!
This is gacha pawn.
Pesto.
Appears in Minish Road's dungeons.
They are red and blue ones.
The blue ones are stronger
and throw things down on your head.
Congratulations!
I'll keep the figures in this case
on the left for you.
You can see them anytime.
Oh, that's so cute!
We'll come back and do that.
I think that's going to be quite time consuming,
to be honest.
Can I have a figurine?
Or is the answer no?
Hey, I can still.
Pardon me.
I don't think I'm allowed it.
Okay.
Let's jump on this.
This is mainly a same quest for 100%.
Okay, okay.
Uh, I might...
Oh, hello!
Oh, sorry.
Am I in the way?
I just wanted to...
Anyway, it's nice of you to say hi.
Sorry for the trouble.
Move now.
Aw.
Yeah, I want to...
Aw, don't have green!
I'm sorry.
I don't have green.
Wow!
What's going on here?
Well, we can't go up,
so we can go...
Hello!
Hey, do you know the clothes that reveal the location of treasure?
Cross the bridge that spans the rapid flow
through the land of the fearsome beast
until you reach the misty falls
where treasure sleeps on the other side of this bridge?
Um, okay.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
I am getting a memory.
Oh, I can't use the stairs!
Sugar.
There's...
So, there is a push ring item.
Um...
Wow.
Okay, so the dog moves now,
so we can, like, get access to this area,
which is good.
Hi, Popper!
You okay?
Oh, he's happy now, which is good.
Wait, so why can't I get into this guy's house?
What is all this?
I'm busy.
Do not disturb my research.
If you have no business, be gone.
Excuse me, doggy.
You're still in the way.
You're still in...
Excuse me, doggy.
Thank you.
Hello?
Dev team?
Okay, there.
There, jeez.
I think we have to do a library quest,
or not yet.
But, sure, I'll use Ken's stuff.
Red!
I won't even have a red one.
I'll get the ring later.
Okay, that's fine.
Right, Reeflings.
Time to feed you.
Who's hungry?
Let's get the cake.
Hello.
Welcome.
You've come.
I have a pretty tasty slice.
60 rupees!
That's a bit of a rip off, hey,
and I'm gonna be honest.
All right, we did get a Ken's stone piece, though,
and we did get a Ken's stone piece.
Is that how you farm Ken's stone pieces?
Hello?
Howdy.
Come get your fresh veggies.
They're fresher than fresh.
Straight out of the ground.
Uh, what are you?
Ah, that's unfortunate.
They're not opening it.
We'll come back later.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, excuse me, Mr. Postman.
You're in my way.
Oh, now you're both in my way.
Oh, okay, everyone's in my way.
That's fine.
The door's shut.
We can't open it from this side.
How bizarre.
Finally, a sandwich.
Yeah.
Well, we go get some food and...
Open.
Open sesame.
Right, we can't seem to do the ring yet.
This is the ring.
Oh, there's a child in one of you.
I don't have your pace.
Stop asking for pieces that I don't have.
Don't be so selfish.
Hello?
I really wanna play a game,
but this place isn't open yet.
Guess I got here too early.
Okay, that's fine.
What's this?
Oh, wait, I can make my shield bigger?
What's for you?
What are you?
Hello?
What is this?
For only 80 rupees for a wallet.
Oh, I don't have enough.
Oh, we maybe could have had enough
if I didn't spend it on the cake.
But you know what?
I'm happy I got to treat you.
And we already got five back.
It was like an investment.
Go in here.
Go in the well.
In the well.
Exactly.
Oh, why is it giving demon noises?
Oh, I can't swim yet.
I'm not good enough.
The snakes can also steal your shield.
So you have to get it back.
That's unfortunate.
They're not open yet.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm getting the picture that nothing's open
because I'm trying to do stuff a bit too early
in the sections.
Right, let's go to the castle.
We will infuse our lovely sword.
And then we will have a quick break
and I will make a cup of tea.
So my voice doesn't shatter into a thousand different pieces.
Is there something to the right?
Oh, I've not unlocked it.
Whoa, gammy.
Gammy's aggro.
Gammy, that's not it.
Don't be aggro, gammy.
It's bad.
It's bombless.
What's over here?
I can't swim.
Whoa, he's got a bomb in his hand.
Whoa, look at the size of that waterfall.
Beautiful, simply beautiful, my boy.
I'm glad he appreciates.
All right, we can't swim.
So there's absolutely nothing we can do in this area.
Don't forget the golden snakes.
So they got money.
Oh, it's like a little minch thing here.
Oh, I'm glad I picked that up for whatever future use I mean to have for it.
I know, gammy's feeling a bit possessed right now and it's fine.
What's this?
Royal Valley.
Well, bombless since we've got full bomb anyway,
so it's probably going to be a waste of a bomb.
What the heck is this place?
Whoa, I'll take it.
A piece of part.
Oh, we've got a new heart container.
That's fantastic.
Okay, we can't swim.
We can't swim.
So it's fine.
Fantastico.
We have a new heart container.
We love tea in this house.
Just got here.
What's happened so far?
We have got the earth element.
We've just picked up the fire element
and we're about to infuse the sword.
Are you sure I look all right?
I never know what to wear for formal occasions.
My guy, you're a hat.
We basically just need to go under the castle to find the secret room.
And then we can learn a new technique from the sword master.
But yeah, very beautiful.
Link, look, see that doorway goes?
Could that be the door that leads to the sanctuary?
Nobody in this castle seems to be able to see it,
but you and me.
Let's go quickly.
It's elemental sanctuary.
Wow, the music, the music.
The music, please.
Wow.
Okay, there it is.
Hmm.
So this is the elemental sanctuary then.
This is where we can infuse your blade with the power of the elements.
Yes, that seems to be the pedestal for it.
Let's shove it in.
Bump.
There we go.
Two element and some fears.
We're doing it.
It's perfect.
It glows.
The powers of earthen fire elements have infused your blade.
Let's see if I can read that tablet for you.
Fill your sword with the power and walk over the glowing tail.
Perhaps it refers to those flashing spots on the floor around you.
Well, what are you waiting for?
Try it, Link.
Oh, not yet.
There's two of us.
You just split in two.
So this is the power of the white sword?
I guess you can double yourself like that
anytime when you see those panels.
Okay, now we have a few more abilities, which is good.
Um, there was a few things back the way that we did overlook.
We're going to go back and hit the town
because I want to learn what the master possession will teach us.
Um, right, we'll run back into town
and then we'll run and get snacks and go for a pee.
Okay.
What dungeon?
This is the Castello.
We're getting the elements infused
and we're about to go for the third element.
Oh, wait, there's a snake to the right, isn't there?
Oh, I can't get access to it because of the guards.
I don't know.
I tried.
Um, oh!
Oh, they're English.
Wait, what's an English voice?
Interesting.
You're the last person I expected to find here
and just as I was wondering who could be behind this,
I find my old master.
Wow.
Vati!
Oh, and as always, you are dressed in the shabbiest of rags.
My curses are not to be mocked.
The one I cast on you is the most powerful.
No matter what power you wield, you will never break it.
You have me changed in the slightest, yabam.
I should never have created that cap.
It only fueled your insane desires.
Thank you for becoming a member, Sortar.
Sortar B'lain.
Fool.
A hat that grants the wishes of its wearer
as a spectacular creation.
Thanks to you, I have gone from being a meek miniscule,
nothing to the greatest sorcerer alive.
You cannot stop me now and I have you to thank for it.
Accept the small gesture of gratitude from me.
Wait, Vati, wait, you fucking bam.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, bitch!
I'm just sp- I'm just spamming, I'm just spamming.
Okay, it's not that bad.
It's not that bad.
Okay, we're fine.
I wasn't as bad as I anticipated.
That foul Vati.
What could he be?
He?
Question mark.
Is it not a lady?
What could he be scheming now?
Link, I feel I owe you an explanation for what just happened.
You see, Vati and I are actually both menish.
I was once a famous sage and a renowned menish craftsman.
Vati was only a boy.
Okay, it's definitely a guy.
Vati was only a boy when it took him in as my apprentice,
but he became enchanted by the wickedness in the hearts of men.
One day, Vati took a hat I made for the humans.
My pride and joy.
It granted the wishes of its wearer.
He put it on without my permission, though.
Am I going to flashback?
Okay, it's a guy.
I thought Vati was a chick.
Vati, what are you doing here?
Oh my god, that's her hat.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, what a vile form you've taken.
Vio, I can't do an English male voice.
I need to sound like Phil from EastEnders.
Vio, I am a sorcerer now,
and my power is beyond compare.
No longer will I tire away as your apprentice.
Now, all shall call me master.
Wait, Vati, what are you plotting?
This year, on the day that comes,
but once a century, the portal opens.
And when it does, I shall claim the life force as my own.
I will be transformed, perfect,
and there will be none who can stop me.
Oh no, so that's who we have.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Tell me, how does it feel, why sorcerers kiss?
Do you see, Eslo?
I am truly your master now.
You cannot stop me, and with that, I must believe it.
And that's how Eslo came to be.
You know the legends, of course.
The gift the Pokori gave the humans.
What you call the Pokori Blade was the first of these gifts.
The second, well, you call it the light force,
but it is the source of limitless magic, power.
If Vati were to be able to get it now, it would be devastating.
I came to the world of men, hoping to stop Vati,
and I came to you in the woods.
You did want that?
But it seems we won't be breaking the curse any time soon.
However, with the Sacred Blade,
we can certainly restore the Princess Zelda.
I'm sorry, all that has happened has been due to my pride, my folly.
I must rely on you, on your power, until we put an end to Vati.
Monk.
Well, Link, enough fairy tales.
We must search for the next element.
I don't know where to go.
Right, we'll go into town, and then I'll have a little break,
and I'll go make a tea, okay?
And you guys can stretch your...
No.
Your legs to prevent any issues with your penis.
Okay.
Sorry.
Set that the wrong way around.
You're to stretch your legs so you don't have any issues.
I will leave the game running in the background,
whilst I go get my Koopa save.
Already lost.
We didn't even get started.
Stretch the tentacle.
Right, I'll leave the game so you guys can appreciate the music
for what it's worth.
This game is very adorable.
We are already two elements.
We are about to go for the third.
If I'm not mistaken, the shoe shop should be open,
because I've just remembered where we're heading next.
Please do grab a snack, get some hydration,
do go for a tinkle as well.
It's not good to hold in your bladder.
The only reason I don't need to pee a lot
is because I am severely dehydrated.
Let's go.
We love severely dehydrated.
I mean, you never have to go for breaks.
But yes, get some snacks.
I will get some too.
I will be a couple of minutes,
but I shan't be long.
Okay, I shan't be long.
T-minus warning for
Emi?
Question mark?
Emi coming on in one hour 20?
I think.
I'm not sure.
I should be able to redirect,
whichever issue it is.
I can't remember what game you're playing, Emi.
I know you've got a collab this week on...
No, don't talk.
Nobody explodes.
Yes, I'll be back in a moment.
Give me a few minutes, okay?
Are you squinting me right now?
Do you want me to do it again?
Do you want to do it again?
....
Give me future
You are too f**king thrown in a border
Where my god?
Gimli and Beato came flying around the corner
I was like ooo
I may or may not have forgotten to feed them this morning
Eps
Have back
So, I'm eating leftovers, and I was like,
hurry, hurry, hurry, the ruffles are waiting,
the ruffles are waiting, and I was pouring cheese,
like a wee bit of grated cheese on it,
the entire bag fell out on the meal,
and I'm like, are you effing kidding me right now?
Like the kettle's boiling, cats are body-me-amming.
I'm like, oh my god, the poor ruffles
are just sitting on this freaking title screen.
I didn't understand a single word by a gray,
thank you, thank you for agreeing.
Right, I'm saying something like that too.
Okay, T minus one hour 30,
and then part one of Minish Cap is complete.
I do have a warm, I've actually got a cola.
Love me cola, I do, I do.
I was so scared, well, because I was away.
Right, we need to check out the shoe shop,
because I believe this is where we're heading next.
Yes, hello, was that, oh, welcome,
welcome to Rem's shoe shop.
Lately, whenever I take a nap,
all my shoes are done when I wake up,
you know, if I can make shoes in my sleep,
I must be in the right job.
However, things are not as it seems, no, no, no.
We're gonna take out, oh yeah, piss.
Yeah, I can't reach it.
Okay, 70 AM cola, literally.
Actually, I can't believe I'm saying this.
I have to actually work after I finish the stream.
Well, the other stream as well.
Wait, is everything open now?
No.
Okay, it's not open.
Oh, right, is the library open now?
Question mark.
No, that's the school.
No, it's not open.
There's a little mini-pot up there, oh yeah.
Am I supposed to go down and discover the swamp
and then come back to the town, possibly?
Very probable.
So you don't consider streaming work.
This ain't work.
I thought this ain't work.
This is not work.
I absolutely, hello.
Oh, hello, my brother's at school, okay.
Failed the bench delt test or whatever the freaking thing is.
I can't remember what it was, but I was laughing my ass off
because Lord of the Rings fails the bench delt test.
And I was like, oh, it's still a good movie, who cares?
I was like, where the heck am I supposed to do it?
Right, I think we're just to go to the swamp
and discover that we can walk in.
The bench delt test, it's like a test
and it's like, if two lambs speak to each other,
but it's not about a man, then it passes.
And it seems like such a small thing,
but it never happens in movies
because obviously movies have to be centered around the plot.
Right, I guess I have to go all the way up and into the thing.
So it's quite humorous.
Don't take it too seriously.
People don't really take it too seriously.
It's fucking relax, it's not that serious.
Two named women characters talk to each other
something other than that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's like something funny like that.
And it's like, a lot of things fail it, which is hilarious.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, double drop.
Hello, is the game feeling nice?
Is there like more under here?
I'll start picking these up if I get a piece.
Is the game feeling bad for not giving me them?
Good, because it should feel bad.
Mummy, can we do a Lord of the Rings watch long?
Yes, you're actually doing it with me
on Christmas Day and Boxing Day.
We're doing Lord of the Rings first,
and then we're doing the Hobbit.
Just because I am aware that
Crumble Time can be a bit sore, a bit not fun.
Whoa, blue.
Whoa, you got those guys.
Wait, I'm cutting the grass, I'm cutting the grass.
Oh my God, oh my God,
the game's feeling so nice right now, what the heck?
I'm cutting the grass, I'm cutting the grass.
Hold on, let me cut the grass.
You don't understand, I need to cut all the grass right now.
I'll grab that shell though.
And we're getting money for doing it too.
I wasn't kidding when this,
this is literally grass cut simulator.
Oh my God, there's so many.
Hold on, we might actually have to go back to town
if it's given me that much.
What's in here?
A red piece, oh, someone wanted to trade us a red piece.
Oh no, but I can't remember the location.
Hey, it's me, it's the two-year reefing badge, no it's not.
Oh right, cause it's a, sorry, sorry, I was like,
I was like, that is impossible,
unless we've got time traveling here.
We're cutting the grass.
I assume if it stops giving us stones,
then it stops, right, what's in here?
Oh hello, hello, I am Percy,
poet literature of Hyrule,
and you are Link, sorry I skip that.
I travel all over the realm,
writing verses wherever I go,
but here I am, returning after a long absence,
only to find the road blocked.
It wouldn't feel like such a waste
if I hadn't lost half of my kinstone,
where misfortune rains down upon my head
at pores and torrents.
I think I may have dropped it in the inn
I stayed in last night.
I see no other course than to put
these tragic events to verse.
I see stars beyond the rainbow,
but I cannot reach them.
Through the stone, though the stone out,
I lost a small, large wizards placing my heart.
Okay, I need to go back to the inn.
Is that why it's giving me all these kinstone pieces?
Ah, looks like my drop rate's changed,
so I think I might have to go trade people.
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, pal.
Right, we're gonna unlock this route,
because that's literally in my way, it's in my way,
it's in my way.
Please, I need to pick up.
Maybe there's a hidden thing.
No, it was an old man.
All right, drop rate is definitely changed.
Oh, oh, we've got a little cutscene moment.
Eh, what a strange feeling.
I sense something from the castle's direction,
or was it just me?
Oh, we need to go back to the castle?
Oh, Phil from EastEnders, right, let's go.
Oh, who's there?
Eh, Vati, how did you get in here?
I don't know how to do an English voice.
Monka, instead of walking the teleport,
talk about being lazy.
Uh, what are you doing?
Eh, given that sloppy toppy, clearly.
Jesus.
What did he do?
Eh?
Oh, he infected the...
It looks like you're all here.
Very well, the king of Hyrule has words for you.
You all know the power of the Pokora gave to mankind,
do you not?
The golden light force of limitless magical power.
I want it, it's somewhere here in Hyrule,
go now and bring me this power.
Waste no time, go forth at once and bring me the light force.
Oh no, Vati made the king go crazy.
Fling anyone who refuses into the dungeon,
him and his family too, oh, North Korea.
I will tolerate no disobedience,
now search high and low throughout the lands of Hyrule.
What do they think?
Maybe it's just the wind, but I hope nothing bad has happened.
Anyway, we need to look for the next element.
The map says it should be around here somewhere.
Yes, it must be around here.
Pinstone pieces?
Nope.
Gami is getting poised to attack me and see...
Did they just keep flying or did they go...
Whoa, you don't even have to do anything to them?
Hold on, that's money.
Oh wait, I can get a new wallet if I get 80.
Hold on, let's see if I can get 80 coins,
that might go down quite well.
Okay, we're gonna go get a new wallet and trade the people,
because there was quite a few trades that I couldn't do.
Well, I think I'm not...
He's really unruly.
So the light force is some kind of treasure,
I can get anywhere, the king must be looking for it.
Right, not you.
You?
You.
Yes.
Can I have this one please?
Two pinstones, but carefully together.
Hold on, I'm gonna bring my food over
because I don't want it to get too cold.
Whoa, chest, just a chest, okay, that's fine.
Okay, I'm mixing in my stupendous amount of cheese
for the pasta, hold here.
It's not looking good.
Hey, they fit perfectly, I wonder what's gonna happen.
I get a chest.
Do you trade me?
No, you're done.
How about you?
Everyone still relies here, it's a good thing.
My ideal cafe is a place where everyone can just hang out, yeah.
How about you?
You wanna fuse pinstone?
Yeah!
Like a four-leaf clover,
where did you end up meeting a spaghetti?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
That wasn't what we needed.
When he said N,
oh, the postman!
Oh, wait, wait, I'm not a Mr. Postman.
Baby, I'm a Mr. Postman.
Oh!
What's this?
I really wish I could do more to help people.
Wait, I've got it, I'll ask swiftly
to start up a newsletter for adventures.
That'll be a great way to create a useful service
for everyone, hmm.
It's going to be a lot of work though.
I should get Marcy to help me.
Marcy?
Help, a fish quiz.
I have no, I don't have no recollection.
Whoa, there's a new guy in town.
We've got so much fusing.
Hey, did you talk to your mage?
Oh, is a Wind Waker reference?
I don't know.
Another chess, okay.
Delicious.
I'm nutritious.
Hey, they fit perfectly, this will be good.
Hello, what do you sell?
Why, hello there, thanks for coming by.
I sell all kinds of pickle, like,
I just put in your bottle and get some patterns
when you drink it.
Hmm, I only drink stuff that reeflings give me,
if I'm gonna be honest.
Oh no, I don't have it, ugh.
Um, no, there was.
Oh man.
Ah, I don't have it, it's not that red piece, draught.
Ah, not you.
There was someone here that wanted to,
oh, I just put a bomb down in front of this guy's house.
Sorry mate, it didn't mean that.
Ah, do apologize, don't have it either.
It's not a change of heart.
I'm just committing war crimes, okay, geez.
Oh, can I fuse you?
No.
Oh wait, did I go back to the sword master?
Can I, was it you?
Well, I can fuse with them, so I'll take it.
Oh, the money bag, yes, sorry, I already forgot, geez.
Hmm, I'll grab that now.
Ooh, what's this, quite nice.
A chest.
Oh, oh, move on, move on, move on, move on.
They fit perfectly, time to celebrate.
I don't think these guys can do anything for me.
Right, we'll go get the,
sorry, I'm playing one handed right now,
I would go faster if I'm eating.
I'm trying to eat and progress the story at the same time.
Um, right, first get the rupee bag,
because then we can hold more rupees in general.
No, not that one.
No.
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm.
Hello, may I please have this?
Only 80 rupees for a wallet,
it can hold a king's ransom by, yes.
Yo, now you can carry more rupees, perfect.
Much obliged, my good lad.
Much obliged, I have more, I do have more.
Whoa, I didn't realize you could even go and see
inside the bag.
The reason why I'm asking if I have water is this.
Literally, you'd never figure it out on your own,
it's impossible.
Do you want to trade?
My dog's real smart and a little spoiled too.
Aw, that's what you're supposed to do.
You're supposed to, let's go talk to the dog.
Hello, oh, you want to, the dog has a fricking,
aw, it's always the one I don't have.
Some might even take a swipe at you.
Okay, this dog's nice.
Oh, God.
See, this is why you're supposed to go like that.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Whoa, did you see that cat looking at me?
I know it wants a piece of me.
This is for a later quest, which we're not on right now
because I'm going too far ahead of the plot.
Oops.
He's a good boy.
Just like a replay.
You're such a good doggy replay, you're the one.
Can I go in now?
Finally.
Right, I'm to trade someone in the end.
Must be upstairs.
Is it you?
And you asked for the one I don't have.
Is it one of the children?
Stop asking for the ones I don't have.
Right now.
What's going to happen?
I need to inhale my food, it's getting cold.
Okay, that's a later platform.
Okay, is that...
Oh, you?
Okay, can do it, can do it.
I'm gonna have to go in the grass
and look for more pinstone.
Hmm.
A chest again?
Okay, it looks like green is all chest.
Oh, wait.
Some sort of monetary gain as I choke on my food.
Gah.
Okay, can't go out there yet
because we don't have a light, which is fine.
Is there anyone in here?
No, there's not, okay.
Right, we need to go get pinstones
so we can unlock this next section.
Because we can't frickin' progress.
I'm even sure what to do.
I'm pretty sure there's a tingle man down here.
What?
Yeah, there he is.
Let's go see this tingle man.
Hello, tingle man.
Yeah, I wanna fuse pinstone.
And do you want the one I actually have?
I like it here.
I'm like maneuver.
Oh.
Okay, we'll definitely go investigate that
because that's cool.
They fit perfectly.
Thank you.
Right, we're gonna go get this.
What is it?
200 shells.
I better not be full with shells.
No, I'm not.
That's fine.
I don't wanna waste shells.
I'd rather go gamble.
Yes!
Right, okay.
I guess I'm just not allowed to have
a certain amount on my person
or the game is like that's too many
and not fun anymore.
Grass cutting simulator.
Simulator, grass cutting simulator.
I don't wanna go back to the guy with only one.
That's so small.
That's so little.
What's over here?
Oh, we don't have access to it yet.
Did I go as far as I could back then?
Or am I gonna have to go to that area?
Just to cut grass.
Literally making my way over there just to cut grass.
Dingle, dingle, dingle.
Am I going extra crazy?
Oh my God, I'm going extra crazy.
This is where I'm supposed to go.
I don't need to do anything.
Ah!
Strat.
This is it.
So, this must be, sorry,
I'm burning myself with my whole war ball right now.
So this must be Caster Wilds.
It's a nasty dank place filled with swamp land and mirror.
Mirror, mire?
But we know there's an element waiting for us.
Come on, Link, let's go.
I don't think we can walk fast enough to cross the swamp.
We're gonna have to find some way to get across safely.
Okay, I think now that we've done that,
it means we can go to the shoe shop guy again.
Kingstone can be grander than RuneScape, honestly?
Right, now the shoe shop guy will entertain us.
Or the event will occur, like, that's supposed to happen.
Oh!
They dropped 20!
Parish right now, give me more money.
So then what was down here?
Did I just get to be?
I don't think I can go any further when I can.
Kingstone, kingstone, kingstone.
Is that?
Am I losing it?
Did I just think I couldn't go any further when I could?
Oh, my guys.
I'm not gonna make it.
Hello?
I planted it being near my house,
but it just doesn't seem to grow.
No, it won't, because I need to kingstone it.
Wow.
The mysterious shells are worse.
I'm almost there.
Doomsday, Dan, thank you for the tip.
You didn't put a message though.
Find and read out.
And delay lover, I don't think I said your name again.
Delay lover, be a lure.
I'll figure you identify yourself.
I'm almost there now.
You're gonna have to put up with my tune, okay?
I can't.
I can't do everything.
I don't know.
I just don't know.
You didn't go any further.
Just assumed you couldn't.
Oh, my God.
Talk about giving up, Mentale.
Wow.
Oh, it's like choke.
I'm swallowing, I'm swallowing, I'm choking, I'm choking.
You want a bite too?
You most certainly can have a bite.
Go, ah.
Here comes the airplane.
I've always done any itch, my eyelash.
It's always on my left eye, my first eyelash.
That's four.
All the food is gone.
We will now go back to the shoemaker
because we need the shoemaker in order to progress.
Oh, ow.
My butt, I was looking at chat
and that gammy sniped my butt.
Delicious, delicious, delicious.
Goodbye.
No.
Chewing the mic and you shall be forgiven.
No, people hate that.
It's like, there's something called like misophobia
or something.
Oh, here it is, this is the event.
Okay, we're doing it, we're doing it.
Oh, sleepy little, oh, yeah, I worked in too hard.
There we go.
Hello, hi.
Hey, hey, you're Link, right?
You're the one who brought the sword to Master Merlari.
You're on a quest to help the princess, aren't you?
I wish I could go on a quest,
but then who'd make Rem's shoes for him?
Notice how he's called Rem as in Rem's sleep.
Like that one beach it better from.
V4, Rem, yeah, Rem, get it.
Hey ho, is that Pegasus boots?
We just made a pair while Rem was sleeping,
but only Rem can put the finishing touches on them.
Ha ha, that sleepy head.
Rem is nearly impossible to wake up.
If you wanna wake him up,
you'll need to get an item from Syrups Hop.
It's a little bit of a trek,
but we'll mark it on the map for you.
So now we need to go up into the right.
Um, oh, I feel freaking detailed all this is.
Who is Rem?
From the other VTuber agency for V-Reverie.
I can, no, not reverie.
Not reverie, hold on a minute.
Not that one.
It's like V4 Mariaeus.
There, V4-Me-E-Ret-Ail.
Look, I'm gonna be honest,
I don't know how on earth to say it.
You guys are gonna have to spell it out for me
if you want me to say the name of that agency properly,
cause I ain't got a chance.
I ain't got a chance.
Okay.
My-Rae.
My-Me-Rae?
Mer-Rae.
V4 Mer-Rae.
It was supposed to be a V0 though.
It said like, me-er-ae.
Me-er-ae.
Hello?
Oh, what's wrong?
You wanna fuse Kinstone?
Sugar, I don't have it.
Oh, you wanna quit too bad.
Oh, just milked him.
I'm so sorry, sir.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir, sorry.
I didn't mean anything by it.
I lost my keys and I can't get inside.
What pain?
I think I'm going into town to serve Lon Lon milk.
Oh, well, I can get in the whooshed nae-ball there, didn't you?
Didn't you mind me?
Girls are so cute when they're a little,
when they're a little rere-ere.
Okay, we need to find the key.
Or just on the other door.
Oh, there is.
Okay, we got the key, so now we need to go back
and be like, hey, we touched my goats' thumb, but...
We totally found it.
And it wasn't through any, not nefarious.
We had didn't have malicious intent behind finding the key.
Hey, sir, here's your key, all yours.
Oh, our one and only spare key.
I don't know how you got this,
but I can't thank you enough.
Tell me your name, Sunny Jim.
Link, that's a great name.
If you ever need to go to Lake Hyalil,
feel free to cut through our house.
Yes, that's exactly what we need to do.
Thank you very much, Link.
Shut up, little man.
Hello?
Come visit us again at any time, lady.
I'm just a wee lad, are you?
But if a lady invites you in our house,
who am I to know a blight?
Hello, cow.
Yes, of course, this is me.
Wait, I'm not getting any more Kinstone drops,
so I think we're at the limit of orbit gains
when we give those.
Oh, I'll tell a lie, I'll tell a Feverruni.
If she needs milk?
No, she's the one with the milk.
We're just a...
How tranquil, and those cows look so delicious.
No, we're not eating the cows.
Here we go.
We're not eating the cows.
How...
How is it?
Islo?
If you can't see Mariah,
can you see purple burglar out or did it?
One day we'll get through a stream, one day.
That stream is not today.
Yes, I can see it, but if I put on a heavy accent,
I can't see it.
What is that for?
Uh, there is a teleportation.
Like, hiro.
I'm so sorry, by the way,
for the purple burglar alarm corne meant.
I'm sorry if I sounded like so defeated.
I'm not like upset or anything.
It's just...
You're not the only one who asks about such things.
Wait, can I not get up there already?
I think I can.
Astrony is adorable.
Thank you.
You know who else is adorable?
You, please.
Exactly.
There's a heart.
Oh, no, but we can't reach it.
We need some to...
Oh, we got a serious.
We got a red one, though.
Do we go in a tunnel and try and get up?
Now, I am 99% sure there is an event,
a tamed event that comes up,
and I really don't want to screw it up.
Wait, I'll just go straight down.
And it's to trade that guy back in the one
that I tried to explode his house by accident.
So we might actually have to go back
because it's a tamed event.
And if you don't do it properly,
well, you're done, so...
Where am I going with this?
There better be a secret down here.
Oh, wow.
But I hope this is the right way.
I've just gone off the map.
Lake Helio.
Please see.
It's like, this way to Mayor Hagan's
Lake State Cabin.
Have I gone the wrong way?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
I'm just going to have to play the game
even more with you.
Let's see it.
Okay, I have gone the wrong way.
I'm pretty sure.
No, that's not true.
That's not going to stop me.
Wait.
No, well, I did go the right way by accident.
Ah, welcome.
Care for some of Granny's homemade blue potion.
One sip and you're full of energy.
Please look around.
I need this mushroom, please.
Oh, yes, a fine choice, my dear.
That is a limited time article.
One worth and you're wide awake.
That is why it is called a wake-up mushroom.
Would you like to buy it for 60 rupees?
That's for you.
You got a wake-up mushroom.
It's a nasty stench.
She chases away the sleepyhead.
Just face the sleepyhead through that
and press the button and he'll...
and the little eyes will pop right open
right out of the skull, yeah.
Thanks, Granny.
Please don't ever interact with me again.
You're terrifying.
Okay, if we're going back to town,
I'll try and do that.
But I don't want to miss out on the timed event.
Okay.
If you don't do it,
a gentleman actually perishes
and that's true.
Would you drink my blue juice?
You would.
Admit it.
I know you would.
No, you don't even have to admit it
because I know you just...
Sorry, I said that.
Whoa!
What are you doing here?
We got another heartbeat by accident.
I forgot.
See, exploring pays off
when you play legends of Zelda games
like they're soon forgiven.
Lon Lon Ranch.
I really need a fart right now.
I don't know, I shouldn't...
But I'm going to hold in.
I assume this is where I was supposed to go.
No, I was supposed to go up!
No!
How did I get back up there again?
Ow!
Let's do that.
Just me a...
Let it rip.
Very question.
Would you drink the 20s Aimee?
Um...
I don't know how easily I can master this.
I'll be honest.
What are you guys?
Hello!
You don't look aggressive,
but I don't feel like you're angry.
You're not.
You wanna fuse?
Sure!
Hey, go buddy!
What does it do?
It's a Goron!
His name is Goron.
Eh?
Oh!
No!
It's been a long time since the last time
I visited Hyrule.
I think I'll stay at this place
and I can sell my Kinstone.
Yes!
This is exactly what we need.
We need to throw our money into him.
Wow, hydration check.
I need to start slipping my tear.
It's gonna get cold.
Hmm, they fit perfectly.
That's so good.
Are you okay?
This is one solid wall.
I need a few friends to give me a hand.
I will get you those friends soon, TM.
But not yet,
because I need to do other things.
Hold on.
Let me just cut down your produce for you.
Hello!
Oh!
Riplings!
They're farmed!
There's no one here,
so it's ours!
Oh!
Cosmo.
I love working in the garden.
It makes me feel so close to nature
and sometimes I dig off a Kinstone.
Right, okay.
We know what we're doing.
Hee hee hee.
Please, CJ.
I'm drink tea.
I drink tea.
Oh my god,
we already helped them out.
I feel so much stronger now.
Here we go.
Sorry, I'm drinking my tea.
It's about time.
Looking good, though.
I'm going in.
That's what Ripling said.
Look at that.
A perfect fit.
Okay, what about you?
Do you have one?
You do!
One a few Kinstone pieces?
Let's rock and roll.
Yes, please.
Oh, hold on.
Wait!
What?
I did it!
Sorry, sorry.
I'm trying to play one-handed.
It's not that kind of game.
That comes later.
Okay, that comes in July.
I do remember seeing that.
The wall.
Okay, we're not going to go back to the wall.
That is very far away.
Look, I'm helping you tail the soil.
Oh, there's a sneaky poo.
We will hurt the sneaky poo.
But I want to talk to the guy first.
Hello.
Hello, I'm at a client.
Oh, no, you need a new buddy.
This is a solid wall.
I'm going to need a friend.
Okay, okay, okay.
We need to just keep doing the Kinstone
to unlock more events.
And I just realized we unlocked something back here.
We will go and get it right now.
Wait, what's over here?
Veil falls.
I don't...
No, we're not to be here yet.
Rit.
I saw that.
Spelunking.
No, I can't run.
I want to escape the word spelunk.
And he fell.
Spelunk.
Wah.
Okay, hold on.
Is the games being kind and giving me them again?
What's it?
I'm a fellow spunker, I have to admit.
Spunks all over you.
They're top left one, I think we unlocked.
Sorry, I keep taking damage
because I'm like hardly paying attention.
But not in a bad way, just like...
Mm-hmm.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's something in that chair.
Oh, red, that's perfect.
Mm-hmm.
No, no, spelunking means cave exploring.
That's what we're talking about.
Right, can I finally trade the freaking guy?
Oh, we need to do this.
Wait, it does disappear and he gets a fright every time.
We get it.
It's the same dialogue.
The dialogue hasn't changed.
Oh, she's selling her milkies.
I'm selling creamy nutritious llama milk.
It's Azura.
Don't buy, sorry, I'm not that rich.
I'm a child.
Do you want a fuse?
Yes, please.
I don't have the freaking one you seek.
What about you?
Yes, I do have what you seek.
Finally, one that I have.
Oh, this is at the castle.
Goat milk, yeah.
I remember when I teased Azura,
everyone was like, a cowgirl?
I'm like, no, that's far too obvious.
What other thing produces milk?
Goat.
Um...
I thought it was clever anyway.
I thought it was good.
This one, yes, I want to fuse.
This is the time-gated one,
so we're going to do this right now,
so no one passes away due to my foolishness, okay?
Mm.
So this is right above our house,
we're going to go back to our house really quickly.
Goth boy, cleat at the castle.
Fusing stones with Malon.
Mm.
Wait, is she actually called Malon?
Is that supposed to be because of her melons?
How's your name, Malon?
Yeah, you can tell her names.
You know, I don't think I've ever tried goat milk before.
If Azura didn't have an upset tummy,
I think it would be adorable
to get her to try all the different milk.
But unfortunately, Azura has an upset tummy.
Okay, are you ready?
You have to do this, or else you perish on a fire,
and this poor gentleman passes away.
So, hi.
Goodness, we rarely get visitors.
Tell me, how did you get here via teleportation?
Are you okay?
Nobody believes me, but I saw a ghost that's taken over Granda.
Yes.
If you do not suck away the ghost,
he literally passes away.
I can't believe old Greggal is sick.
He was looking so healthy,
I guess something just took a hold of him.
Literally, if you do not do this.
Okay, now that thing's strong.
Well, well, well, look at how the colours come back to his face.
How can I ever thank you?
I still have a hard time believing he'd been possessed by a monster, though.
Well, I don't find it hard at all.
What, an evil spirit had taken a hold of me?
And you drove it away?
You might be right.
I already feel my energy returning.
I'll be able to get out of bed soon.
What's your name?
Link.
Thank you, my boy.
You saved me.
I'm a hundred shell.
If you do not do that,
before you unlock this area,
the non-teleportation way,
he is no longer in the game.
And you literally cause him to perish if you do not do that.
Now, all is good and we can go back to the main quest.
80% forehead.
But he's just an elder and he's smart.
Okay, where's he going to put all the knowledge and wisdom?
Exactly.
So you didn't think that far ahead, did you?
Oh, I forgot to do the wee bird.
Hello.
Are you going to teach me something?
A new sword.
Fantastic.
And you seem to have acquired new skills with it.
I'm going to train you again, young swordsman.
Will you accept?
Yes, we will.
I will now teach you a technique called the rock breaker.
So pay attention.
First, swing your sword to break pots.
Actually, that's all there is to it, young swordsman.
Do you understand?
Yes.
Yes, good.
If you had said you didn't understand, I would have serious doubts about you.
Yes, you must feel the technique.
But one must feel the technique, not just hear about it.
That's why I will now possess your body and do as to demonstrate the technique.
That is the secret of the swift blade possession technique of training.
Watch this.
Position.
Poof.
Now you must try it for yourself.
Break the pots with your sword.
That's all.
Yes, fine work.
Fantastic even.
I now give you the tiger scroll.
If you ever forget the technique, you can read it in the scroll.
Rock breaker fighting technique.
Shatter pots and pulverize boulders with a single blow.
Is there anything else I can do?
Come again when you learn to run like the wind.
Hmm.
I suppose.
Wait, how did I get to that chickadee?
I don't know.
I actually don't know how to get into the shuffle though.
There's a singing thing.
I don't know what that's about.
I want to do this, but I don't think we're there yet.
Hello.
Bring whatever piece you'd like to shape.
You're like a simple amount of personal taste.
Goodle.
Oh, he wants to do it again.
Get again again.
Okay, I'll see, I'll see.
Oh, unlock something in the room.
Hi, Jason, hi, Jason.
They fit perfectly.
Oh, I expect my sales will be tripled by this.
So did they, did they just go in order or what, they need it?
Oh, that's up north.
There might be life inside of that.
I think we'll go do that like right now because I think there's going to be an extra life in there.
Like a heart container, pardon me.
I know, I'm sorry for people who want me to just do the main quest,
but that's the fun thing about the Zelda game,
is you get to do all this fun side stuff.
Oh, it's a fairy.
Sure.
You found a fairy, a reliable ally to cleanse your health.
If you trap a fairy in a jar.
Not like that, Riflin.
Um, this wing friend will come to your aid.
Don't put the fairy in the jar for other reasons.
Do I make myself clear, Riflings?
Good.
The fairies are so cute in this game.
Yes, this is a very cute pixel game.
Is there, so can I just keep like Kinstone into the same,
I can, just over and over again.
I guess it mustn't really matter.
Oh no, I can't do you.
Is there anything here in here?
A boomerang?
Hello, how much is this?
300!
Oh, he's got a jar behind him.
Wait, how did I get here?
He's got a jar, I need two jars.
Ah, sugar, I can't do it yet.
I must be after this one.
You're going to need a lot more zinc tomatoes and pineapples.
Remember to have tomatoes.
This is good for you and your, your twins question mark.
Can I choose you because you're so cute.
You're so adorable.
What do you unlock, little trick-a-dee?
The other fountain in the, the...
Castello.
You can push it, you've got to be big.
No, I need a ring, it's like a special ring.
Bye-bye, I'm going to finish, I'm not like my brother so I'm going to look at it.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Uh...
That's what it is, I need the library to open up and put me on the book quest,
but that's not yet, it's after the swamp break.
We'll go pick up our shoes because I have been dilly-dallying enough.
Wakey-wakey.
If I recall correctly, and I guarantee that I do, my boy,
I think syrup said to stand in front of the sleeping person and press the right bumper.
It was literally just the interactive key.
What is that terrifyingly bad smell?
It's just me, sorry mate.
I wake up mushroom, I should have guessed, so you woke me up.
Thanks, I just remembered I have something urgent I need to do.
Oh, what now?
There are more new shoes, you probably won't believe this,
but I have a strange habit of making shoes in my sleep.
So you must have come here because you want some of my shoes, right? Tell me.
What, because you're so nice enough to wake me up, you can have them,
hold on a second though, I just need the finishing touches.
And there we go, here, take these.
These are my special Pegasus boots.
They're so light, you'll feel like you're practically walking on air.
You got the Pegasus boots, hold the button to run faster than the wind.
Oh, I need to hurry up and get working on that special order,
the king asked me to make some shoes for Princess Del D.C.
Thanks for waking me up, come back if you ever need help,
or if you have any shoe problems.
Now we don't actually have any shoe problems.
But we're gonna go back to the swordsman,
because he will know teachers and new moves.
Got them Jordans on.
Ah yes, you have the Pegasus boots,
and you seem to have more skill too.
Yes, I am ready to train you again.
I got almost just one minute there, huh?
You will now learn a new technique called the dash attack.
First, equip the Pegasus boots, equip your sword,
third, run like crazy, that's all you need, do you understand?
Yes.
Yes, yes, you are my finest student.
Just equip the sword and the Pegasus boots,
and any button you like, but one must feel the technique,
not just feel about it,
that's why I will now possess your body to demonstrate it.
Watch this!
Position!
Bonk!
So now we can dash like crazy while having it out in front of us.
We don't have to do anything else.
Yes, fine work, you now take this tiger stroll.
If you ever forget, just reach the stroll.
We now know dash attack.
Run like the wind and attack.
Do you have anything more for me, or am I coming back?
Come again when you can jump further.
Got them jays on my feet.
I'm sure there was something we could do.
But I forgot.
Out my way, out my way, ya bam.
Wasn't there a special fairy tree over here?
No?
Yes, I knew there was!
Whenever you see a tree sparkle, do that.
And then become tiny, and then we can go explore.
We're just so good at exploring.
Garfunkel, thank you for coming a member.
You moved the rock for me, great.
I thought I'd never get outside.
Aw, poor little guy, we're stuck.
Look at his wee decorations.
Got wee knick knacks over here,
his wee cutlery set,
all alone in my room.
I love what you've done with the place,
with a little rope on the wall.
What you're into is fine.
A little leaf like this stuff.
I just want to play a cute little pixel game like this,
and I don't know, maybe it's like making the townspeople happy.
You know what, I'm just going to straight up develop it.
I think I've said, um, not a,
kind of after a reveal or, um,
maybe going into fucking games.
It's a game published in, where like, I pay a studio
and make my game.
Maybe doing that, basically.
Um, but I'm happy to show the behind the scenes.
I mean, fuck me, I can never be quiet
whenever I've got a project going.
I'm like, and this is what I'm doing right now,
this is how I'm doing it, right?
You guys do this, this is how I do it.
Um, literally, I can't even keep my gob shot
when I've got something going for me.
Um, I'll just see how it goes.
I do have an idea.
I want to work with a studio,
but the problem is that you need to get, like,
fucking lawyers involved and everything.
I had to, I felt so bad.
So the VLR game, I feel really bad.
I had to get a fucking lawyer's piece of shit contract
because of the game.
Like, because obviously I had to pay for it to be produced.
It's not out yet for anyone that's like,
huh, how are you talking about the game?
I'm not playing the game from VLR.
It's not out yet, it's not out yet.
It's been developed, we're in the last stages.
We're just waiting for the animation of the art to come through.
Um, which is taking a bit more of a,
um, it takes longer for that kind of side of production.
Um, but I've got a good deal.
Thanks to the developer I'm working with
because, uh, I cannot go that way.
Will it be on Steam?
No, it is an itch-y-o game.
It is wildly inappropriate for Steam.
Haha.
Ah, Sneaky's.
Go away.
Leave me alone.
Uh-uh-uh.
I don't want to hear it.
Where the heck did I go?
I don't know.
I will buy it.
Well, speaking of buying it, it's completely free.
You do not need to give me any money.
It was a developmental decision
in order to promote the girls,
and everyone can get a bit of a taste of the girls,
if you will.
Um, I opted to make the game free.
You do not have to pay for it.
It cost a pretty penny to produce,
but that, ultimately, was my decision.
Um...
It's definitely a good learning experience.
Oh, it's bugging me, sorry.
Meekoo's big fan, thank you very much for the 10 gifted.
Congrats to who gets that.
Yeah, it's definitely the girl.
Um...
Hello?
I am just a child.
Leave me alone.
Hello?
I don't...
Okay, I can hit his back if he does that.
Right.
Oh my gosh.
What if we want to pay for it anyway?
Um, just support any of the girls then?
Um...
The publisher can also be tipped
if you really like his work.
Um...
Oh, it's golden.
It's golden, why would it be golden?
Um, but yeah, it's free.
If you want to tip and be like, thanks for the game...
What if we want to pay for it anyway though?
Um...
If you ever felt so inclined, support any of the girls
or if you want to directly do it to me,
then do it to me, like on stream elements
is the best way to do it.
Or Patreon, to be honest.
Like, even if like...
Some people are like, oh, I feel really bad.
I've only got like five bucks to give.
You don't, like...
What's the word?
It's like such a cascade in effect.
I don't know where the heck...
I'm supposed to go.
I'm like rambling through the swamp section.
I'm so sorry.
Um...
Like, it adds up incredibly...
Oh, I'll take that, thank you very much.
Um, it adds up incredibly quickly.
Like, never be like, oh, I feel bad that I can't like,
give any money, I can't do this, I can't do that.
Like, don't ever feel like that because
the money like adds up so fricking...
Here's my pre-order in the game.
The game is free.
You don't need to give any money.
Right, I've got a golden piece.
Is it here, I'm supposed to go?
Oh, I'm getting all turned around now.
There's a cavern here.
Oh, how much do you want?
I want to sell you arrows, but you don't have a bow.
What was I saying again?
I've already forgotten my fricking subject!
Right.
I don't think so, at least.
Um...
Bro, where am I supposed to go?
I'm going like, all the wrong ways.
I assume this is a dead end until I get yours.
Oh, I don't know how I've successfully gone the wrong way.
Like, eight times now?
I've already been here.
You know...
Did I come down here?
I did.
Is there anything else here though?
I think I'm special needs.
Hold on.
Sorry, I need to try hard.
I don't know where I'm to go.
I've got a keystone piece that was golden, right?
No, that is one nasty looking statue that I had evil glower to.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm genuinely unsure what to do.
I've already been down there.
I've already been here, and then this looks like a dead end,
but I don't go down it, so maybe this isn't a dead end,
and I'm just the top of the damn thing?
So it is a dead end.
Hold on.
Processing.
What?
It says get a bow, but I didn't have a bow.
The wee mushroom guy.
The business scrub.
Which is me, by the way.
Oh, idiot features!
Pegasus boots to get me across here.
Oh, not the water though, Link.
Not the water though.
Yeah, sorry, that...
That must have been painfully obvious.
I do apologise.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Go across the swamp water.
Okay, what is this?
Ah, we're working this before.
Sorry.
Oh, look at the flowers.
What's beautiful.
Um...
Yes, I made the decision to make the game free for promotional reasons.
The game is not out.
Thank you for the money.
I do apologise, the lay lover,
but thank you for the money.
I'm getting spanked about.
I'm spamming, I'm spamming.
Oh my god, is this a bow and arrow?
Oh, thank god, we've got a bow.
Right, we've got a bow.
The game...
It will be tweeted about from all the girls' accounts
and all of that jazz, so don't worry.
You'll know when it comes out.
It's still in development,
but the base is there.
Waiting on animated artwork to come back.
And then I just need to hand over the audio.
I need to break all the audios down.
But it makes the game cheaper if I do the work, so...
I'm not going to outsource the work,
but thank you again for the tip.
The name of it is a pun.
Is anyone surprised at this point?
The answer is...
Okay, let's go back this way.
Okay, okay, now that we have the bow,
we can poke them in the eyes.
Oh, that wasn't very nice.
I'm going to have to admit that wasn't quite mean.
Let's outsource the audio.
No, it's like more money.
I spent a lot of money on the game
to get it produced.
I think...
Oh, I don't know.
Should I say it out loud?
It's over 10,000 US dollars.
How about that?
It took me 10,000.
And I know someone's going to play
and be like,
this game's shit.
I can't believe you paid that much money for it.
And it's like, bro,
I'm going to just fucking relax.
Oh, yeah.
Game development isn't cheap.
It isn't easy.
It isn't fast.
It isn't this.
It isn't that.
What the heck is this?
Hello, Mr. Gravestone.
Two more.
10K.
Oh, it's a bit more than that,
but I'll say it's 10K.
Though my body may have perished.
Strongly be voicing by Chris Pratt.
No.
Someone was like,
I don't have a male voice in the game.
I was like,
why on earth would the male voice be in the game
if the entire point of the game is to
be allure?
Why would there randomly be a male voice?
Moment is too generous.
Though my body may perish,
I'm still a true swordsman of Hyrule.
Swiftblade, the first spirit of a swordsman.
If you train with me,
I will teach you skills that,
hmm, it seems you're not ready to train with me.
Come back when you have...
I'll come all this way in a swamp.
And you're telling...
Okay, I'm not that mad,
because there was a Kinstone piece outside the Gravestone.
I'll let it slide this time.
Bitches.
I already know
what game
I want to produce
for Gen 2.
Every generation is going to have a free
access kind of game.
And I already know what
the...
I'm drowning.
I'm drowning again.
I already know what the other game types
are going to be.
I hope people find it humorous,
because it's kind of a parody of...
Oh, that's what the golden...
Oh, we need to go back.
We need to go back.
We've gone too far.
Wait, so there's going to be voice acting?
Yeah, by us.
By all the viewers,
the girls have already recorded their lines.
Now, I will say one thing.
The lines were very important
to be recorded first.
So, before you're like,
this person doesn't sound that confident.
Yeah, probably because it was very early
into knowing each other.
And I sent them the script,
and some of them have good experience.
Some of them are kind of new to it,
but are aware of the...
I'll push that down.
Does he come after me?
I don't know.
Is it an FPS stereo?
No.
It's not like a full, developed AAA title.
It's literally to play one-handed.
There's not much more to it.
Where am I supposed to go?
Am I supposed to go down?
No, I'm supposed to go over here.
Overwatch 3.
No, I did not produce Overwatch 3.
Literally, it's just a one-handed game,
but games are not easy to produce.
Easy or cheap to produce.
And I still need to pay the artist.
I forgot to pay the artist.
Is it other 50%?
Oh, right, we just need one more piece now.
That's fantastic.
We can go back up here.
Then we need to claim up.
If Blizzard had any sense,
Overwatch 3 would be a one-handed game too.
No, that's so good.
That's terrible, but that's not good.
Let's do this.
Okay, the Pegasus.
Probably see there's only one thing about this game
is we have to constantly go in the menus.
I need to push this down, actually.
Question mark, we did it.
Yes!
Okay, we can go straight back again.
And we don't need arrows from that guy,
because we're already full.
Yes, the Overwatch industry
is probably bigger than the playable...
Oh, I do not doubt it.
I'm sorry, they absolutely ran that game to the ground.
I'm like, hope it was worth it.
I genuinely hope it was worth it.
Although it's saying that...
What's that game?
Valorant?
All they do is sell...
It's a free-to-play,
but all they do is that skin stuff as well.
And they've found pretty good success,
so...
Maybe...
Is that what I should do?
I should put skins behind a paywall.
That's ridiculous.
Then what's behind here?
That noise.
Wait, don't he coax them to me?
Okay, now come this way.
He does look awfully venison.
Oh, it's just for a chest.
Oh, okay, it's blue.
Oh!
I'm too skilled.
I didn't trust that when they popped off.
I was like, they did not come out of the grass.
I knew they didn't come out of the grass.
Probably because Valorant was sold as a PvP.
So it didn't have hint for the camp.
Wait, you're still in my way?
Oh my god, stop for real, for real.
Can't go that way, which is...
Fane.
I've already forgotten how to get...
I think I need to go up again,
and then do that swamp route in order to get where I need to go?
Yes, I do need to do the swamp route, which is fine.
Huh?
I don't know.
I forgot.
Wait, how did I get up there?
Ah, okay, okay.
Stab them in the eye.
Yeah, honestly, I'd be pretty enraged, too,
if that happened to me.
I'd be mad.
Can I get any cannons?
Please.
This one, please.
Thanks for joining.
I say that as if I'm not about to go off in 20 minutes,
because I need to do my forbidden tier stream.
Whoa, I made that by a centimeter.
By a millimeter.
Wait, no, this isn't where I'm supposed to go.
But it's near here.
I just need to get done.
Okay, okay, we did it, we did it.
Two Kenstone pieces fit perfectly together.
Bunk.
And they're last, but certainly not least.
Don't forget to eat a set of me.
I absolutely will not forget.
I actually need to get the thumbnail to put up the member stream.
I'll put it 15 minutes past,
because I might need to squeeze out a loaf of bread.
I think the painkillers are making my loaf of bread
severely impacted.
That's terrible.
And a couple more hours of member stream.
No.
I'm going to redirect into Emmy when she goes up,
and then 15 minutes later, the member stream will be there.
Like, I'll put it up, don't worry.
The heck with you.
Ooh.
Oh, I don't like you.
Oh, I can perish you though.
That's fine.
Okay.
Yeah, just stay stuck on that.
That's fine.
You don't scare me.
Is the tier list at the same time as Emmy?
Yes, but it'll stay up.
Whoa, what was that enemy?
I saw that.
We'll grab it.
We need all the moonies and...
Ah, perfect.
We got a red one.
Hello.
These soldier statues here were built by the Minish ages ago
to help humans.
It's kind of a secret,
but there's a switch inside that turns them on or off.
A switch, you say?
Conditioning, you say?
So nice.
I was going to say,
I'm sure you can climb these guys.
Right, now that he's activated,
he will wake up and you just stole his stuff.
Literally, hi!
Opens chest first, doesn't even greet him.
Oh, he actually bounces me back.
He's that much of a talent.
Honestly.
I see that thing.
I see it.
I actually don't think we're going to have enough time
to do the freaking dungeon.
What's Emmy doing today?
Be honest, what game's Emmy playing?
Is she doing a two-hour stream?
Or is she doing ASMR?
Do you want me to do the member stream
two hours after Emmy starts?
Because Azur is off
and Mercy's off.
And I don't think Emmy would do ASMR
more than two hours because it gets a bit
really sore in the voice after two hours.
Brainwashing ASMR, yeah, it's my Emmy.
Shibuya's at eight.
Wait, I thought Shibuya was off.
Wait.
Oh, is Sheepster's a bit later?
As much as I would love to watch the member stream,
I want to watch Emmy.
If that's the case,
I can play this game for another two hours
and then whoever wants to watch Emmy
can go watch Emmy.
I don't know, this game is nasty looking.
We are so back.
What a name!
Oh my god, your icons!
We ace the call.
That's so precious.
I love when you guys have like
the girls'...
Let's get rid of the snakes first
because they are scary.
I love when you guys have the girls'
oh-she-marks or like their profile pictures
them or their name is there.
I'm just like, oh, my bye-bye.
I'm so glad you guys can enjoy it.
Draco, thank you for coming.
Remember?
Oh, I'm glad I caught that grass.
I didn't realize.
I thought it was going to restart.
I heart you very much.
Yes.
It was concepted that A.C.
So I've...
I haven't said it.
Obviously only the development team
could see the designs.
And A.C. by far was voted
the most well-liked
designer...
whatever...
whatever.
So...
we popped her
in my
lore video
and it was a cute little kind of like cameo.
I can even call it a cameo.
She would just...
she's the muse
because obviously my lore
was people had already
hypnotized themselves
to
be watching VTubers,
which was a quite like the...
the charisma
of the charisma.
We just turned everyone off.
It's that easy.
I think that A.C.
smart in gameplay capture
to different audiences.
Yes.
If you...
if you want to watch Immers,
my little Immers...
Wait a minute.
Wait, a diddly dying minute.
I think I need to perish those guys.
I don't know.
Maybe another time right now.
Let's just get there.
The Conqueror?
A.C. having a rough day?
Is she alright?
Oh, I can destroy these with my sword now.
Sorry, I'll just do some edging
on the grass.
If you didn't know that
is actually the terminology,
cheeky edging.
Wait, who...
Oh, I do have to defeat
the other guys right there.
Did I do it?
Am I going to come back to this area?
Probably not.
It is called A.C.I.N.
If you're a gardener,
it's called A.C.I.N.
That's called A.C.I.N.
Just a little...
no, literally like on the...
fortress of wind.
What is all...
Well, there's so many rooms
you can explore.
Okay, do not touch that.
Let's not do that again.
Hmm.
To think the rooms were hidden
within this cliff the whole time.
Watch your step, Link.
There may be traps in here.
Hmm.
Well, there might be traps here,
but what about the Fen Boys?
Okay, well...
I tried, I tried.
Geez.
Can't impress them all.
Hydration check.
Um...
Right, I will tell you
when Amy goes live
and YouTube mods you have
permission to talk
when Amy does go live.
Um...
And we will play...
Oh!
Oh, no, this can't be.
Oh, please don't touch me.
Wait.
So, what does the other lever do?
Jump on someone else's head.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, I'll take that.
Another keystone,
keystone.
Don't mind Father.
Oh!
Stop, please.
Sorry, a green chap.
Do you think Amy
has happen sizes?
No.
Whatever she does is completely
on her.
The girls make the content
they want to make.
They do what they want to do.
And that is the lovely
jiggly way we do it.
And...
An unnatural...
Well...
Ah!
I see what I have to do.
No!
I just got walloped
by freaking haunted skulls!
Fucking get up,
you lazybump.
I can't go that way.
You can deactivate those
electricity skulls
with a boomerang.
Oh, I never bought it.
It was 300 rupees.
I can't believe it.
Poverty strikes again.
I said get the tinfoil hat on
right now.
It's tiring.
Great.
Yes.
That would be the plan.
We'll play menace
for another cheeky two hours
because we're cheeky cheeky.
Also cheeky bricky.
And then
we shall...
do the forbidden members here.
And then that way
everyone's happy.
And everyone is happy.
Can I make everyone happy?
I don't know.
I sent from the Australians
because this is
probably the worst
time
we could have asked for.
A key!
Can I fall at the bottom
without taking fall damage?
Hmm.
Did someone just fall down
or was it my imagination?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
Let's just take fall damage.
Speed things along a bit.
Emmy's going live now.
I don't know.
I knew...
I didn't know you could
do that with a boomerang
or something to do with a boomerang.
Hi.
What are you getting at?
Because I'm asked for showing up.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, there's so many stompers.
No, get away.
I'm no fighting you
as if you're just going to
keep respawning.
I don't have what...
That is so a rope snake.
I can tell.
No fall damage.
Nah.
Oh, these are happy.
Are they?
4am.
I guess it's maybe...
Oh, forget the stick.
Oh, I'm going to
freaking run out of health.
These don't have health.
Oh, for goodness.
I suck at this game.
But your mom swallows at it.
No.
Oh, no!
Did I?
Please tell me they're
not all going to respawn.
Okay, they didn't.
Thank goodness.
The one time where
clearing out stuff actually works.
I zoned back into that.
But don't zone out.
Are you going to...
Can I actually perish these guys?
Can I?
Oh, you can!
Wait, can I, like,
fully perish you then?
That was 2...
3...
4.
Okay.
I didn't even know that.
Hello.
Are you the compass?
You're the dungeon map split school.
Well, AC is really going through it now.
What?
Did I need to check the disc?
Did she tweak something?
Oh, no, she can't tweak.
She's got her can band.
One more.
Am I missing?
Yeah, she's got her can band.
My cat is not me on it,
so I better figure that out.
Oh, AC got it.
Damn.
Hold on, let me find her.
Oh, I follow so many girls.
Oh, Dr. Nova followed me back.
That was kind of her.
Hold on.
Is it, like, the Any End Stream?
Or...
I don't know.
I don't have the Discord account,
because I don't know anything.
She was showing me something.
Oh, it's just her filming.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Okay.
I think it's okay.
Okay, I think it's okay.
I think it's just...
Yeah.
Okay, I think it's...
All right.
The Uji-Sans will...
Oh, it looks like I'm moving on my health here.
Gimli, I can hear you now.
Shut the fuck up.
There is not the time, darling.
Okay.
Phew, we barely made it.
I'm starting to run out of time.
I'm not trying.
I'm going to bed.
Oh, God, these are the hugger things.
Sorry, I might have to get Gimli in a minute.
She will not stop me on.
But I know...
He named your cat Gimli.
Am I going to call my cat Gimli?
So you're going to...
You're going to fart and clap?
Wait, no, that's not the same.
I think the same is like...
I'd rather...
go number two in my hands and clap
than do whatever...
or something fun.
It's a she, yes.
She's got a bit of ginger on her,
so I named her Gimli.
I know, so for you.
Ah, yes.
The floor masters,
or the masters, depending on you.
Just kind of go in here
and do something.
I don't know what,
but we're doing something anyway.
Wait, what?
Is that supposed to go somewhere?
Wait,
have I gone too far ahead?
I think I have.
Wait, have I gone too far ahead?
Have I done wrong?
I wouldn't mind getting a wee health bar.
I'm getting a wee cheeky heart.
I called my cat, baby.
Unlock the door.
I can't.
Oh, my God!
I'm not supposed to get killed for that.
Oh, no.
Close one.
Oh, I know, I know.
I comprehend, I comprehend.
No, don't.
Wait, what is this?
I don't know.
Oh, I need a zigzag.
Okay, I understand, I understand.
Sorry, it took me a...
a momento.
Right, if I do one there...
One, two, three, four, five.
Five, one, two, three, four, five.
Okay, up there and up there.
Right, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry, sorry.
It just takes me...
It takes me a moment to catch on.
It takes me a wee moment.
It's alright, it's alright, though.
It's alright.
We're here for doing it.
I don't need anybody.
Um...
I was actually thinking of getting...
What's the game called?
Ah, that's exactly what I needed.
I was actually thinking of getting...
the buckshot roulette highlighted
just to show how dumb I am,
but like in a humorous way,
not like a...
you know, like pity party,
oh my gosh, who's brainless type of way.
And then I need to be small down here.
Okay, that looks correct.
It looks like I need to be small now.
And what is down here?
I'm curious.
If there's anything at all.
Amy just went live with brainwashing.
She has already got a warning,
so I'm nervous for that stream,
but hey, huh?
We're all adults here.
How'd I get up?
I can't use the stairs,
so I'll have to go all the way back
and shrink down an income.
I am getting very low health
and I don't like it,
and the game is currently refusing
to spawn one heart for me.
I do have a theory.
Yeah, I don't really need money right now.
I need a heart.
The game already needs a heart.
She's just following my misexample.
I just get so nervous.
I'm like, oh my god,
I wouldn't want them to jeopardize
their income or anything like that,
because YouTube makes up
such a big chunk of income.
As well as passive income,
because I almost made it.
I was going to go it,
but I don't have enough health
to be messing around.
But yes, Amy is live
for any pinpals
who are wanting
the tingly ASMR experience.
Please do check it out.
Um...
What happened from here?
I'm just a bit of an irritant, okay?
What did those do?
Right.
Again, my question is,
what did those do?
I dropped a key
that I can't get access to.
Ray...
Right, if I want to become big,
I can take a shortcut this way.
I am missing an item,
and I've gone the wrong way.
Okay, I've definitely missed an item,
because...
What was here?
Again, I need an item.
Right.
There must be another way.
Top ten times
Pastrani
shot herself with a shot
that I didn't believe number four.
What?!
Would you prefer to be punned
with Pastrami or something?
Friggin' Azura's accent is so funny.
She calls me Strani.
And I'm like,
are you calling me Minestrani Sue?
But it's just the way she says it.
Okay, this is exactly
what I needed.
This friggin' room right here.
Give me the heart.
She's a Gastroni,
and I'm like...
Oh my God, Azura.
I literally sound like Minestrani Sue!
That's very cute.
I like it.
That looks like Archery,
if I've ever seen something like that.
Yeah, and it gives you five in a...
Okay.
We will get the super secret item.
Right, I'm just gonna take the HP damage
because I know there's infinite heals.
Oh!
Do we have Invis frames when we spray?
One of them is a rope.
Yeah, fuck me.
Damn right, give me that coin.
Right, where is that electoral thing?
Is it the red one?
It is.
See, you can get me to this.
You got me before,
but you'll never get me again.
Azura's been absolutely killing it
on the Star Jew.
She is a dick.
It's eight.
What is this?
Oh!
True.
Oh, I need to go on that platform.
Oh, I need to do a little cheeky trickshot.
Oh, I missed.
Hey!
And then...
There we go.
Both sides are open, that's why I like to...
Yeah, see,
imagine if you drop more hearts consistently.
How easy would this game be?
But no, no.
If I push that,
doesn't that block me?
I'm a bit too scared to touch anything
in this room...
unless I'm going crazy.
She said she has, like, two key arrows in it.
That is...
Am I going mental or is that just going to block me?
However,
I think I dropped down onto it instead
because that doesn't seem right at all.
I'm actually losing that...
Game!
You knew exactly what I was trying to achieve.
Okay, let's go.
Well, I assume this is going to turn them on.
Hmm, gee Wilkers,
I wonder if standing on these buttons in this room full of two enemies
is going to activate enemies?
Surely it's a mystery.
Truly.
Truly a mystery.
I'm not stuck.
Oh, I missed.
Okay, now he's looking at me.
Wah!
I missed.
Right in your eyeball, bruv.
Ta-da!
No, wait, you got it.
Compass!
The heart's in here.
You know, there's ammo, though.
I'm full ammo, I didn't even get it.
It's correct, no push up.
Pegasus boots across the gap, no push up.
He gets trolling.
I'm pretty sure I have to drop down and it's a troll.
Nintendo are very trolly,
but this does not seem correct at all.
I think we dropped down.
I want to say we dropped down because...
Yeah, this doesn't look right.
Push!
I can only push.
I can only push again.
And then I can only push again.
I don't have a choice.
Like, I can push that back.
That doesn't do anything.
Oh, push it up!
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
Like, if I can't see the solution, then it doesn't work.
You know what I mean?
I'm so sorry.
The reason why you push it that way is so you can do them horizontal.
I apologize.
Literally never played this, so I can't offer any advice.
Well, I'm pretty sure you probably called out though.
I am so sorry.
Oh my god, I must be painful watching me do anything.
Okay, we have a key.
Let's go grab it.
Yeah, we're just going to go back down again.
You're so adorable.
Isn't it not frustrating though?
I feel like it'd be frustrating watching someone being like,
No, that's impossible.
And the solution is literally right there.
I feel like...
I get it, I get it.
Right, we finally have the second key, so we can just come up here
and go straight into the...
We would watch you...
Oh, this reset.
Oh, but I didn't reset those guys.
Watch paint dry.
Right.
Let's just do this.
Steady.
Easy. Steady.
Whoa, you've never seen anyone move faster.
Are these going to vibrate?
No.
Whoa.
Naughty.
Oh wait, that's like the enemies in Isaac as well.
He wasn't kidding when you said this game was inspired by it.
Oh, fight room, fight room.
It always scares other way, Link.
Jeez.
Okay, he needs to attack,
and then I can wallop his chest.
Wallop.
Oh, I missed.
Ah, there we go.
Take yourself out, mate, you suck.
Oh, we're already halfway through the dungeon, so just unlock the portal.
Okay, yeah.
Just a reminder to anyone that wants to watch ASMR,
Amy Bezu is live, her link is in the description down below.
Everyone's link is actually in my description.
Go subscribe to everyone, and go watch their shorts.
I spend money on their shorts, so please watch them.
Please watch them, please help the girls.
Actually, big news that I completely forgot to mention,
Sheeby is going balls to the wall.
She's full-time now, I feel her.
She had a job, on every hand, and she's full-time now.
Feels good now.
So definitely don't be afraid to sign up for the girls' picture-
Oh, that's what I was saying before I interrupted myself.
Because someone-
Ah, piss!
My rupees are full.
I didn't see a bag at that shot to increase my rupees.
Yeah, she quit, she's now full-time.
Yeah.
Oh, that's just how I progressed.
Yeah, she's full-time.
Definitely don't be afraid to support the girls I'm pretty on.
As I was saying, when I was mentioning that the game is free,
I was talking about people being like,
I only have five dollars to support.
I feel so bad it's not enough.
So, what's the word?
It comes together.
So you give five bucks, and then someone with your mentality gives five bucks,
and then someone goes on and on and on.
And that money adds up over time.
It's kind of like-
I don't know if you've ever heard of the OF Rhetoric where it's like,
Oh, you sell your do-do-do-do for pennies type thing.
But it adds up, though.
You don't need to charge 70 or four.
It's just not needed.
I'm going to get an exact-
I'm going to get-
Please let me out, jeez.
Wait, where'd I go with Keto?
But it all adds up and it adds to their income,
and it's stable income as well.
As long as I have told the girls,
I've been very serious with them.
Am I going to get-
Am I going to get touched?
I've been not in the business.
I have told them, like, it's of your utmost importance to give me these audios in time,
because if we have to pause your Patreon income,
then it's probably you're gonna be-
There's no point in picking up rupees.
Of course I get a red and two blues,
literally 30 rupees in one pop when I'm like full.
What are these guys?
How do I hurt them?
I'll just spam them in the corner.
Money compounds, yes, basically.
Can you come here?
Is that four hits, jeez.
Yeah, yeah, of course I get tons of money now.
In game.
Wah!
Nah, Sam's just skipping.
If you're not coming towards me, I'm skipping.
Ah, piss, left or right.
Left or right.
Whoever types left or right, I'll do your first-
Do your first saying.
Don't blow it yourself or not, then eat and come on through.
Don't be meanly, literally.
Alright, first one said left.
Mods, execute that man.
Left or right.
No, you know what?
You know what?
I'll do it myself.
I'm gonna time you out,
for giving me the wrong say-
I'm not even kidding, I'm timing you out,
because you gave me the wrong say to go on.
You will be timed out for a whole,
a whole minute.
For your, your dissatisfaction.
Where are you?
No!
Where is it?
Wait, I need to time them out.
I need to time them out.
Put user in time out.
Who was it?
Right, put user in time out.
For ten seconds, confirm.
There, you've been timed out for ten seconds.
Take that time out.
Your insolence towards the cause
will not be forgotten.
Don't ever cook again.
Teasing you.
So cruel.
One whole minute of no-
No, I said ten seconds.
I said ten seconds.
Is he back?
I'm gonna start panicking,
if a mod actually did ban you for real though.
Mods, whenever I say ban this man,
I mean in humorous way.
Where the heck is the dungeon thing?
Based AF.
Oh no, there you are.
Guys, it hurts.
Yeah, okay, he's back, he's back.
Right, where was the dungeon entrance?
I actually don't recall seeing the dungeon entrance.
Is it back this way?
Oh, they're dancing.
Oh, it must be this way.
Yeah, surely, surely.
Check them out.
Personal attention.
Refling.
This should have been me.
No, it shouldn't,
because you get timed out for doing that.
Wait, I'm gonna do it.
The chest spawns there,
not the statue has to go there.
Me making my thingy.
Doomsdaydan,
what if I wanna pay for it though?
I never read out your name.
God, it must be really weird
when I don't read out your name when you don't know,
and then 15 minutes later,
I'm like, oh my god,
Oh my god, Duly Lover,
thank you so much,
because I keep forgetting.
I wouldn't mind getting a full heal.
Do you have hearts?
Yeah, that's what I like to see.
That's what I like to see,
a video game that's stocked up.
Right, we're ready.
How long are you going today?
We have T-minus less than two hours,
and then we will continue
our Zelda shenanigans tomorrow.
I don't feel that.
I don't feel everything, honestly.
Shoot his hands with an arrow?
That looks correct,
so let's do that.
Oh, okay, let's not do that.
Oh, okay, let's just completely miss.
Ah, let me go, let me go.
I'm just a tiny boy from the pool.
Whoa, he took so much health.
That is an insane amount of health he just took.
Am I supposed to have more health by this?
I think I might need to do more side quests
than after this.
He took so much health in that.
Oh my god, oh my god.
He's got a little thing on his nose.
Oh god, what happens in here?
Oh, okay, we did it, we did it.
We're being extracted.
Any extractors?
Me, me, I'm being extracted.
Why did you take so much health though?
Oh.
Can you drop a heart maybe instead of arrows?
That'd be great.
I'm totally not strawwetting right now.
I'm getting a bit nervous.
Oh, what, there?
It's not that one, it has to be...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I can't do any harder.
Alright, again, extracted.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
We're gonna do it, we're gonna do it.
What's that?
I'm low health.
It's fine though.
Ow!
Alright, I said we're dropping the fairy.
Bring the fairy in.
Ring the guards, ring the guards.
The guards have been rang.
Oh my god, I'm like spamming so hard when I do that.
I'm not even kidding.
Can we do it?
Can we do it in this perfect three or are we gonna have to do it again?
Because I don't have any more heals.
I don't have any more heals, bro.
Wait!
What are you doing?
Link!
Link, you're stressing me out.
We're under a timer here.
This guy doesn't stay down forever.
Sorry, sorry.
Ugh.
No!
Oh, we're gonna get extracted before we even...
Done a lick of damage!
No!
This is why I don't gamble!
Oh, we did it.
Don't gamble, home kids.
This is why we don't gamble.
Let's go free in a row.
And a healthup.
I don't know why I just turned Russian there.
A healthup.
Okay, we got healed up.
Now we go upstairs.
Oh my god, it's Gami's colourful family.
Hello.
Check.
We are the tribe of the winds.
Long have we lived with the winds.
We have mastered them.
Now we join them together with the great winds at our backs.
We head for the skies.
Those who come seeking our power must play the note Zafa teachers.
Zafa teachers.
May they lead you onward to the power that you seek.
Aw.
You got the ocarina of the winds.
North, south, east and west, they're all just a breath away.
I do believe this is where the tribe of the winds once lived.
Hmm.
So they've left for the heavens and taken their element with them.
It looks like the wind element is beyond our reach for the time being.
We have no choice but to press on.
Let's get out of here.
So we did all of that for fucking nothing.
The element was not here, but at least we now have a clue to its whereabouts.
You must use the ocarina of wind to open a new path.
Well, there's no point in standing around.
Get that last element.
Last element.
We only have two.
Are we?
Um, are we supposed to go to the graveyard now?
Yes.
Ah, so that mysterious mark we've been seeing is the crest wind.
If you play the ocarina of wind, Zafa comes to pick you up and fly away.
That means we can have Zafa carry us to any other wind crest that we've seen.
Are you following me, Link?
Don't hurt your brain thinking about it.
Just give it a try and you'll see what I'm talking about.
That's just the map from...
That's just the map from a link to the past.
Is that actually?
Right, no?
Do you wonder what's going on?
I wonder what's going on too.
Uh, right.
We never actually...
Hello?
Stamp, stamp.
Even if we hire more people.
Welcome.
I'm selling issues of a helpful, adventurous guide.
It's called The Swordsman's News, and it's full of device right now.
You can buy the latest issue.
It's only 200.
200?
That's extortionate for a piece of paper and a bit of ink, mate.
I'm not lying, but that's a bit much, don't you think?
I'm going to see if we can get a bigger...
A bigger money pouch.
Use the Ocarina to fly to the lake.
Ice temple.
Oh, you're right.
Wow.
Money, money, money.
Oh, wonderful.
They fit.
I'm so happy.
Oh, I can just keep using these guys over and over again.
I've got two red.
I assume red is like a major math update.
Okay, money pouch.
Total.
It's a golden total.
I like totals.
Gears, the sh...
Oh, the arcade's open.
What happened to the arcade?
Netto?
I can buy a bigger quiver?
I don't know.
I'll buy the boomerang.
That boomerang is not a bargain, but I'll take it since I need it.
Yeah, you're...
Well, you're a big spender.
Wait, does the boomerang get replaced by a money pouch?
How much is the money pouch?
600?
Eh?
What about you?
I don't have this kind of money.
I can't even hold it on my persons.
Jeez, you're extortionate, mate.
I'm a child.
Surely I get some discount.
I want to play games too.
What's in here?
What do you do?
Ah, he's finally open.
I can't wait to get cracking.
I don't know what this is.
That's like four languages.
What are these inflation rates?
Yeah, real child labor.
Speak.
Oh no, a customer.
Why did I even start a treasure game shop anyway?
Alright then.
Well, welcome to the fascinating world of treasure, blah blah blah.
In this wonderland, you can test your luck and win big bucks, maybe.
I don't really recommend it myself, however.
It's your wallet.
It's 10 rupees for a try.
I don't even have that money.
I fell over because I don't have the money.
Oh, good, good.
It really is your lucky day.
You don't have enough rupees.
I'm telling you, this gambling nonsense is no good.
You're better off without it.
Wait, Nintendo kind of pitching the masses, huh?
Right.
Can I learn a new move because I can do this?
Come again when you can jump further than any other.
Okay, my bad.
It doesn't have 10 bucks, could you glad?
If you aren't playing on a Game Boy, you can scam this game?
Now, the implications of that just don't work.
I don't...
No, this isn't where I'm supposed to go.
Even though I'm supposed to technically make my way to the air temple.
Oh, goodness.
Yay, okay, right.
I'm not supposed to be here yet.
We will now go top right, but not too top right.
Like middle right.
How about that?
We do middle right.
Deal.
We now have Pegasus boots.
What is that?
I don't know what that changes over here if we have access to Pegasus boots though.
Oh, I just fucking ruled them.
Fucking hell.
There's too much going on here.
I can't handle it.
I'm getting ruled.
Jeez, would you perish already?
Gosh, galley.
Jeez, I'm getting absolutely obliterated.
I think you can use a Steve Star.
You can scan the game by saving and checking and loading and clicking right.
Wow, I didn't know that.
I feel like there's something I must have access to.
This?
Oh, this looks okay.
Reach go a little to the right.
Oh.
Or not.
Oh, a new fairy.
Hello.
I'm Link.
And I'd like to link up with you, baby girl.
Hi.
Wow.
Welcome to the adventure spring.
I have need of many rupees.
Please throw all of yours into the spring.
Sure.
All yours.
I don't need it.
Really?
You know, I don't even have one rupee on my person.
You know that.
If you do this, you will have absolutely no rupees left, right?
Will you really throw them all in?
Yes.
You are most kind.
I do not really need your rupees,
but I must reward such a kind adventure with some of my power.
You got a big wallet.
Complain and you shall receive.
May light shine on your quest.
I got exactly what I wanted.
Wallet upgrade.
Don't mind if I do.
Literally exactly what I was needing.
Sorry.
I'm going to have to get like Gimli in this room.
Because she's going to absolutely hate shit.
Sorry.
I need to get rid of the plastic in the room, girl.
Because she'll chew the plastic.
Won't you get more?
I can chew the room, Gimli.
Then I'll put it in.
No, there'll be inside by the money.
I'll be coming right now.
Sorry.
Oh, and now I'll open the door
all the time.
She'll be interested when we're coming in.
I'm getting out of here.
Why are you here?
I need to go.
Come on.
You need to push through the door.
Oh, hold on.
I'm going to open the back gate.
Garden 4, I'll be back for a sec.
Sorry.
See these cats, man.
See these cats.
Oh.
She's coming out of me.
Oh, do you want out?
No, do you want...
What do you want?
I've already fed you.
Obviously she wants treats.
So, I'm now reinforcing that behaviour
for her to come me out and annoy me.
So, she's not looking good.
She's not looking good.
So, I'm now reinforcing that behaviour
for her to come me out and annoy me.
So, she's not looking good.
She's not looking good.
Do you want to do pin stones?
No?
Oh, wait a minute.
We have the mitts.
No, we can do this.
Fuck.
That's just the money.
No, the game knows I'm too scared.
Well, there you go.
To keep out money for doing a wee bit of exploring.
Stranny new.
What?
What does it do?
Oh, she's going to start me on a hell of a lot more now.
Oh, well.
She...
Honestly, you can spoil a cat.
What's the worst of him?
Is it me?
I was a bit more...
There's none of them.
It's up or down.
I think I may actually be up.
You know what?
This way to the lake.
So, what's up?
Shhh.
Aw, I'm going the wrong way.
Mmm, I may have gone the wrong way.
I am going the wrong way.
I'm going to have to go all the way on.
Cats deserve all the treats.
I didn't mean to spoil them.
Weed gimmels.
Or we go.
My cat doesn't stop me at one.
Literally, I don't know how much you could hear
because I was away from the microphone and, like, standing at the door.
I was like, right, come in then.
Come in then, you win.
Come in.
And then she's looking at me like...
I'm like...
Bruv, you've literally won.
Wait.
No!
I thought I unlocked the shortcut there.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Okay, we're on the right track.
That ace thing, if you noticed it.
Whoa, whose house is this?
Oh, Tiddly Wings.
Let me dug here.
Oh, how's it going, wee man?
Rough, rough.
Oh, great.
Can I go talk to it?
You're right there, mate.
My master, Sokwell, has been coming home far too late to play with me.
I'm so lonely.
Okay, let's fuse these two.
Guys, I'm still recovering from the time that I forgot what duration was left.
My cat doesn't...
Minish Village?
No, not Minish Village.
Thanks for that, Tiddly Wings.
For that, we just...
Let me just find...
Can I run on water?
I don't think I can.
No, I can't.
The mayor's secret house, maybe?
I can't believe I forgot to freaking do that.
You know that?
Right, I'll remember this for now.
However...
Where the heck?
I'm a bit confuzzled.
No, you need to keep...
Left is the one that's not right, I think.
Now you go back down.
Right, I think maybe...
Is this the library quest yet?
I think the library quest is what needs to happen next.
Oh, sorry.
My apologies.
Oh, there's a staircase down there.
That mustache-y old guy strikes me somewhat unreliable.
There's something fishy about this room, too.
I hope I don't sound like I'm bragging, but I have a certain cabin in Lake.
It's a gorgeous little place where I go to enjoy my hot...
Okay, I think that's the hint.
You want to fuse?
Yes, I want to fuse.
Can I run on water?
Jesus, girl, confirm Gen 2.
Oh, your name's not Stroneys Remove Tornail, bro.
No way you called yourself that.
Holy sh...
Oh, my God.
Brutal.
Absolutely brutal.
The pick?
Is that my foot?
Is that a picture of my toe?
Have you got a picture of my toe as your profile picture?
No way.
That's funny as fuck.
That's amazing.
Yeah, I would talk about the experience.
This person loving here is the mayor, very important.
Doesn't it just sound also official?
The mayor, like, strange mask sometimes even makes his own.
There's a mayor evil.
Just for a week, okay, okay, okay.
I would talk about, like, what happened in that,
but if I'm going to be honest, it was pretty, like...
A rough experience, so I'd rather just...
It's TFE.
Oh, you about it, because I had a bad time.
But I'm okay, so you don't have to worry.
No doom, no doom, but it was pretty...
Not nice.
So I don't really want to talk about it.
Right, I think the cabin in the lake was a hint.
There's no way it was.
Under construction, digging, prohibited.
Oh, yeah? What are you going to do if I do this, then?
Yeah, you're going to fart and clap.
The bandage gets changed, I guess, technically, after this room.
There's, like, a chest here.
Ah, I'm actually so smart.
I'm, like, 10 out of 10 smart.
There's a spider there.
He humped me!
He wasn't even hurting me. It's just...
It's a huntsman!
They don't hurt, but they just, like, look terrifying and stuff.
Where on earth am I going?
This is under the town.
Oh, we're getting red pieces, though.
I'm not complaining.
And 100 rupees.
Hold on a minute.
Oh, something's happening.
I don't know what the heck all this is, but I'll take it.
Looks like it's a team effort.
The library quests, by flying to the lake,
you can't reach the Minish house otherwise.
Let's fly to the lake.
Ah, that's really good.
This is a lot of digging.
I am a dwarf and I'm digging a wood.
Diggy, diggy, wood.
Diggy, diggy, diggy, diggy.
There's a chest.
Wow, three red pieces.
Don't mind if I do, honestly.
Under construction.
Yes, that's fine.
Oh, we can go into the back of the bakery if we get small.
Can I go in here yet?
But I can't access the thing.
I've already forgotten what I'm supposed to do.
I'm to fly.
Ah, I am.
What the heck?
Hello.
Oh hi, a visitor.
How are you?
But you have phoned me.
The wisest of the wisest of whys.
You...
What?
You want to enter the temple you can see in the lake.
They call that place the temple of droplets.
I've heard rumors that one Minish actually did find a way long ago.
That Minish is Elder Libri Rari.
And he is in semi-retirement in Towns Library.
Yes!
Okay, thank you.
Towns Library.
There we go.
Luckily we just picked up that piece because we can actually use it.
What does it do?
That is at the swamp.
We should go grab it.
Yes, we will go grab it.
Hey, they fit perfectly.
Yes they do.
What are the odds?
Can I trade you again?
No.
He lives in the Towns Library.
Towns Library.
Library.
Let's go.
I still have the best feet for me.
Oh, sorry.
I accidentally backed out.
I picked that up though.
Stop.
Travel to the library.
Absolutely.
Let's see what we're working with.
Yes!
We can get in.
It took us long enough.
Hello.
Who is blocking that entire town?
Oh look!
Oh look at all the wee baby footprints from the minnish.
Sometimes these books move on their own, I've seen it with my own two eyes
and don't tell me I'm crazy, I ain't crazy.
Oh he makes quite a unique noise.
Right.
Let us begin.
He was raging at them books honestly.
It was down here.
I can't swim so I can't do anything.
And I'm gridlocked.
Okay I can't do anything yet because I don't know.
Oh there's a wee guy down there!
Hiya!
Americaia!
Clean this.
Hello!
Oh we can clean this, find the books.
Hey hey, it's no good, no good at all.
The humans have checked some books out of the library.
Thanks to them, none can get back to the elder.
How, I'm so worried, I'm sure the library knows the books.
I wish they were big, why I'd walk right up and ask if we're in them books where.
Okay.
You want a few pieces, yes please.
He's just happy you got to meet his mummy.
Oh.
A little cavern has been unlocked.
Any cavern unlocked?
Hmm it fits perfectly.
We're like two peas in a pod for how did they fit.
It's for lunking ahoy.
You better not.
Right I need to go talk to the lady.
Yeah.
I'm in charge of checking her book.
charge of checking your books so it's not my problem still I feel too bad for the
girl over there checking oh right okay other one welcome to the library see
aren't you the Smith's grandson link hmm the book's missing from the bookshelf
on the set yes they've been checked out for a while they're very overdue take the
Hyrulean Bistory for example been gone for ages check out uh checked out by a
girl with a cat she said she had a new cat at her house want to learn more about
it I have to do it one at a time okay okay we can do one at a time and the
girl with a cat we actually did walk in on her oh excuse me
thanks for getting away don't ever do that again wait does anyone want to
anyone want to link you know anyone anyone want to do the things yeah you
want to do this with me oh sorry sorry sorry I got excited there I pressed the
wrong button do excuse me hi Jason check make sure you're drinking not alcohol
we've had enough alcohol for a while
oh that's up at the school okay do you want to link nope the you know the you
know the girl with a cat is this one I don't think I need the strength for you
guys good huh a book from the library is that the one yeah check that you came
all the way get it wow you're dead kid but I don't know how to tell you this is
back at my house would you make going to get it I just can't leave right now you
see they're too busy making it well can we read the paper oh we can dear mom I'll
be next door if you need me hmm say look at that link there's a book on top of
the bookcase but how are we gonna get it we can't reach it we have no ladder and
I don't think shaking the bookcase will make it fall this presents an interesting
problem we didn't see if only we already knew what to do
wow how about some nice cold coffee hi puppy oh the way he looks at me the
boarder oh wait wrong way sorry sorry I'm to go up the chimney call me Santa
cuz oh wait no he goes down the chimney well I guess he goes up the chimney as
well cuz he needs to come back so the cat will swipe at you so if you get a bit
too close why dodged it correct what that really startled me everything's
scary when you're small what I'm so strong okay there we go just need to get
around the cat look at it shaking his little butt they actually put so much
detail into this game they could have just done like swipe motion on cat but
no they like actually did the they did the nature of the cat correctly okay we
have obtained the first book you got a library book called the hurry on me
sorry there's one of three books because this game follows the classic rules
which is as you know wait oh it's open I did not realize it was open almost
the cat under the book cats are really they're such a silly animal I don't
sense weird to say but they hate their pain and stuff so if there's something
wrong with them they won't even tell you oh hello oh here we are you've come to
the fabulous Simon simulations would you like to hear about it sure well
certainly now how shall I put this we offer you the chance to be the hero of
your dreams we allow you to fight grand monsters without any danger this is our
unique same risk but I can't say it if you dispatch the monster skillfully enough
you might get something nice now even though there's only a simulation it's
still not for the faint of heart if you should die in the simulation why then
well I don't know it's never happened did I get a heart for doing this see so
you're going then let me sorry you're getting very sleepy so very sleepy oh
hee-hoo how's that I think I might get a heart of this
just drop me right in it why don't you
okay I back in dispatch of some of them oh I'll kind of want that keep because I
can't want that key piece I'm gonna be honest mate okay holy moly they just
obliterated me right at the gate
please don't okay we can kind of get a double kill in up well accurate enough
holy moly oh sorry I just I just rolled into that attack there my apology is that
heart piece it's not the other moderate thanks for a couple of it but you don't
need a mouth you need moderate member streams there's nothing to moderate
because it's just me I just every band someone if I see anything I don't like
I just straight up ban how is it did you enjoy the raid come back yeah that was
interesting don't do that again can this open the door still shot hmm but
thanks moderate but you didn't have to do that all right we are delivering the
goods oh actually I need to feed my refunds hold on I'll get you the pie this
time welcome slice of pie yes cuz you guys are hungry so I need to give you
some pie there is nothing inside it but we still got to enjoy the food though
so it's not a big deal that there's nothing inside hand in the first book
hello look at that long-last link are you returning the book thank you I can't
begin to describe how much I'm looking forward to putting this back okay what's
next the next overdue book is let's see legends of the poor it's been out forever
I checked out and it's somewhat a scholar ah this is the guy that told us to go
away well you can't say go away cuz he's like he's literally our quest right now
let me in huh what a book I guess of course I do need to grab some water
hello good bye hello right what's you I am a researcher of PCORI legend and
Lord my name is dr. left you're here about the book legend of the PCORI aren't
you well I hate to say this but I haven't seen it in several days perhaps a
mischievous little mouse has taken it well I'm sure in this house somewhere I
don't know where but I'm very busy right now so why don't you look for it
yourself okay thanks for nothing mate appreciate it here so if we go right
here what can I know okay I can't I thought he was gonna maybe change the
it's pie flavored pie what was that song I'm a muffin I want to die die die or
something like that it was a very silly song hello I really like this house this
is best place in the whole town I want to stay here forever I want to fuse yeah
what you got for me
are we back but like a good old doctor wait that's well right from the
Nintendo some city game wait is it they fit perfectly I wonder what it goes
okay now we can do this crazy side quest hello hey I've heard about you so
you're gonna go ahead are you well onward to glory then just don't die out
there you don't really have to tell me twice okay these cats do want to hurt so
just be careful oh it's not good I just can't get anywhere man oh man okay just
get on oh there we go took a wee bit of damage was fine oh who knew there'd be
something like this behind one of the town's fountains well let's get moving
and see if we can find the item those Minish mentioned was there an item
mentioned I'm just kind of going for it too I'm just sending it up no this is
like a jump down okay
you know the muffin I'm a muffin well I'm not but I'm a muffin girl I need you
get in the ball I don't know you can have a fairy and a thing wait how many
items have we got well we're only missing two items and then does the game
speed up it like and the next like sequence or something fight if we're
only missing two items I feel like we're like steamrolling this game maybe
tomorrow's stream is going to be like two hours and that's it I mean it's good
that I get to be direct into the dealer draw so I don't mind at all just so you
know that I mean is live with ASMR and she be as live power bracelets you're
filled with strength even when you're so tiny yeah you got enough strength to
plop even we're tiny that's terrible I'm sorry I don't know why I said that I
don't know why I said that I'm a deviant okay we now have the strength to push
stuff when we're tiny oh no no that cat's gonna mess it up no oh wait oh wait
good you good you okay we did it yeah you made it no way
oh my god I've never even told you one of my favorite fucking a cafe stories so
three Japanese girls came in and and they ordered hot chocolate and obviously
me being a weeb and like they were using Google translate it was like the
cutest thing ever and and I gave them their hot chocolate like I made them
type thing and and all I heard them say was like oh come on I was like oh my
heart I'm so fucking happy and it was very good loved it and that's that's my
cafe story that makes me happy and what's going on here hmm let's see that
makes sense human books are so interesting and that guy doctor left
living down there is great taste in reading material and I was so precious
hello thanks for clearing up no that dust is gone yeah what do I need to do here
okay okay I see you see god I just want to play like a cute little freaking game
it's not super long I think they're like three-minute dungeons left sorry
sorry me aim but me aim but yeah like I feel like I've kind of gone through this
game like so fast well I found the book hello what should I do I stay or go
you've already found the bracelet that makes one strong on you I'd be I'd be
stumped for so long I knew it was it all it must be him that tells me sorry that
was my mouth if you saw actually took for really sorry brap rose that was my
wait for my donut on you'll be laughing with me
sure it was wait I need a book give me the book a book fell with the third a
little while ago yes sorry if I give you any right legend of the core was that
a bird sorry sorry mr. puppy I didn't mean that I did apologize this was my
favorite part in childhood this sequence it's a copy of the legend of
Picari it's been checked out for so long link you deserve a medal I moved deeply
deeply moved by the thoughtful gesture oh she's just really thinking don't know
I'm gonna go hard and the last week we still need a history of mask I think it's
checked out by the mayor how can he keep up library book for so long he's a
public official that's all streamers say it was my chair no see you know how you
know it's not real I'd make content of a home I yes me Hagan I am the mayor of
this town what's that you want a book and you checked out do you need or did I
well absolutely please don't ever speak again right now we go to the mayor don't
set your goal for the donut on too low on well as zero I believe is going to do
her donut on plan a live and I was probably gonna do the same as my
birthday comes up and we can all kind of decide like all that seems fair or like
well what's done here what why is it oh wait do we have full wallet now I think
we may do honestly oh I keep them up keep them up keep on the wrong way I need
good time excuse me mr. Co's but no no rupees are never max yeah but we'll
only have 200 but it's this is where I need to go right and if I go up there
wait oh I'm getting so turned around and right not going that way again where's
the shortcut I'm supposed to make them so confused honestly all right the mayor's
office is here
wow let's go should be a chest yes yes yes yes perfect whoa that's a rope yep you
wish you could do that
can I give you a what check on the girls in this game what I got caught cuz it
didn't have a freaking thing attached to it you suck oh I remember mysterious wall
oh mysterious oh we're helping your friends
discord date was drawn in for a million no I am I am going to focus on public
access and goals I'm also gonna recommend the girls to the same and because I
think that's the right thing to do but that's just me the girls is the one
of thorns will be like related to like moving out potentially or that kind of
thing I don't know how to how the delivery date is gonna go because it
seems like it might be a bit why oh I need to be we Hagan's words of wisdom if
you can't solve a problem just ram your head into it oh that wasn't it I need to
be we ah I need to be we okay we need to go all this way right let's try and yeah
like mine's all like public stuff and stuff for the girls like artwork or
collapse I'm looking forward to that and it'll be I'll be nice like getting
everyone involved and thank you Lily pad for perfectly synchronizing yourself to
go that like that okay we don't need to ram the book off okay there we go last
book we did it we did it and then we can deal with the ace fortress although
instructions me why you weren't here why you weren't here were they there when I
came off you don't have a favorite maybe the green fairy she looks good
history of masks remember them be my new school me this game so mean I can see
those hearts but we can't achieve any of them oh wait what we're doing I can just
fly back to town instead of taking the long way you can just do a little cheat
see short okay that was super duper quick and we did it we have unlocked the
books would you look at that I can't believe it that mirrorverse is a real
piece of work isn't it it must have been quite a challenge to get back you are my
new favorite person like thank you so much you know link you know you've never
turned all over over do now I can finally get that bookshelf on the second
floor hey sergeant books shelves yes yes here I am I'm here I'll have these
books put away like a split what I thought was gonna be that other old man
he just came out of work the bookshelves are back in order and I feel so renewed
enjoy your browsing oh there's such a cute game be in a mini boobini I'm so
strong I think there's something we can unlock in the end maybe when you check
out
grandpa's built for speed I am speed oh wait I'm dumb sorry I'm dumb don't look
at me it's the blue book please excuse me a little guy I like that they look at
you and like interact with me and stuff and go down and it ends safe oh look at
the lucky book is cute it's a little door and everything it's got everything he
needs in this little room oh I don't have what you need oh you want to quit such
time oh visitor for many long weeks even Jotari has been away for so long I've
gone over slowly what was that what do you need hmm you want to visit the temple
of the droplets very well you are the first such a brave person in a long
while stand on the globe in front of me all right all right you kids today no
patience for an old man well you just stand right there like that like I told
you oh now open the secret mystery panel
it was not that fun now that's up to you to pass this trial safely and recover
the item you require everyone thought I do love the real integrity of adventuring
all right old man living by curiously oh I just smacked my hip on something well
not my hip my oh whether it is I have no my brain whether oh that old man must
just love sending people and dangerous missions and how did that guy get into
the temple of droplets anyway I guess that answer lives up ahead let's get a
move on maybe okay okay we're stuck it's fine no we're stuck that's fine okay
there we go in the corner I think we are about to unlock the ability to swim but
that's just my hunch the tips are precious cargo I think I'm getting over
the refling PSD have been called stinky wait thank you oh fairy just came out
where are you whoa whoa what unique design oh I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
done I'm gonna get done what these guys have a lot of HP it's such a unique
design I'll get paid good money for it though you got the flippers price a to
go out through the water and be to die hmm yes yes my only sense now doesn't a
boy he used these flippers to swim to the entrance in the temple so if you put
these on you should be able to swim to a remarkable right we're off is there
anything under the waterfall hey come on it's a legend of Zelda game you already
knew there's something in the waterfall
and that swim noise oh wait wait I'm sure there's something back here I feel
like there maybe whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh I don't have what that is any raid big brother raid no you're not yet that's
the quiet part you're supposed to say pin pal raid okay backtracking if you
wanted to backtrack oh wait hold on no how are the pin pals how is the stream
are you all adequately mind-broken yet did any do a good job I believe she be
caught in boom is live if you care to take a gander at your oh my god we can go
like so many places now this is fantastic
Emmy is too good oh yeah she did great oh yeah she completely mind-broken yeah
yeah oh no are you completely mind-broken sorry not any Emmy's the one that's in
control emanate get pimped out do you want to use she's not live until 10
ah okay okay okay well redirect into she be at 10 and then I will do hi I heard
you adequately broke the pen pals that's why I like to see that's why I like to
see do it again and do it again I am I am just gallivanting about I have no
unlocked the ability to swim which means I can reach so much more stuff I may be
able to trade someone in here with a can store no oh the lady sure let's fuse
I'll fuse with you any day brainwashing works like a charm and be sure
some cool stories about childhood I've been thoroughly petted that's substitute
for the G word they fit perfectly yes they do do you want to oh we can now
access the little guys up here because we can move the furniture around look at
this we were so strong hello oh they have their own cafe up here
this is so cute my little heart can take it our reunion with them every union
with the forest menace is still in full swing oh my god they're all mingling are
they gonna have babies little menace babies oh my god oh no good what go it
this is good this is we are renovating this place for menace so they can upgrade
their cafe size okay get over here get over here you hooligan I'll bop you on
your nose right now bop bop bop bop bop all enemies will be perished in the name
of the cafe oh my god they even have like old beds left over
get 10 series shells were there any cool things I was gone we're very hello is
anyone back there oh well guess not how odd it's me I'm back here give me this
jar I knew there was something back here where did you find your way back here
this ears from boys only that's to say me and me alone well give me this I'm sorry
my good lad but that is not for sale that bottle contains food for my dear
little dog Fifi what you want the ball that's highly unusual well fine if you
feed Fifi then I guess you can get the bottle yes I'll do it just excellent
excellent here's my home you got the bottle of dog food now go on your
Aaron okay well go feed the dog let me to mark the location of my house I've
actually already been to your house and I've already met your dog no to this
like no to make it weird and I believe there should be a doggy dish for my dog
back at the house just face the dish and press okay Fifi is not a good name for a
dog I accidentally cracked a button so it made me big again wait can we fuse
Kinstone's no we can't
risen the baby oh no they couldn't turn it into a cafe such yeah you stinky is it
he fell off the map and didn't die I thought this could get extended no I
don't get extended come on they can extend the cafe what would you mean it's
super dangerous to balance across a beam I mean wrong every union is in full
swing that's so cute I want a red hat what do you say I want a blue hat you'll
never guess what you guys can do to consummate your marriage swap hats super
easy peasy what happens if I go outside no this is an outside all this is me
gushing about how adorable the map design is in this area you can still buy the
money back I've completely forgotten what I was doing oh the dog so we can have
two balls yes the dogs the dogs will someone please think of the dog you're
purring starving man it's down down no I'm not doing that farm again so I was
doing farming it's wrong already been in this case wait oh no this can't be this
is the witch isn't it I've gone the wrong way it was up north it was up north I've
been I've been at the mockery I've been made a fool all back in swing now so I
can get there super fast oh Prize be I'm gonna scurr aim oh this game really said
going this awkward way oh wait no see this see this game making fun of me I'm
getting absolutely walloped by everything on the way there kind of help
themselves you guys have a heart in these no okay sorry I broke all your
pottery I'm sorry I didn't mean it you can also simply fly there don't say that
don't say such things I'll believe it get me to this man yes okay fee fee where
the heck are you get your child you've got an empty ball fantastic oh he's loving
give him a little pet did you finish it oh you finished it rough okay you're
happy that's right now that we're here we go for a swim yes whoa look how many
containers we have see you you can see me they can't see me I'm invisible okay
spanks me on the way up look my bad my bad 50 rupees don't make that it just
the money I'm trying to figure out where to go let me cook wow I'll happily
accept you oh my god we finally found the frickin shortcut oh give it up give
it up I thought my sword would actually increase those guys
couldn't do that right wasn't here oh oh it's a heart take a piece of my heart
now hello I have found oh you have found the true master swordsman of Hyrule
wave blade if you train with me I will teach you things you have never seen
before hmm it seems like you're not ready come back when you have ten hearts
I'm at one two three four five six seven eight nine nine hearts I'm literally one
off come on me make an exception make an exception for an old boy right I think
I have to go we hear actually I'm like 99% sure there's something down here yeah
there is wow what we're doing here oh no it's like separate lady okay this is
not gonna go well I'm gonna lose so much HP I'm so I'm so bad on slight missions
and I've got fallen so okay they know exactly what they were doing for can
making these maps no the slugs make it worse the slugs make it worse steady easy
easy right there we go actually just look at this game what is this oh okay
it's just a I mean I'll take it it's not problem it's not problem okay take it
easy easy easy now I'm gonna be slipping and sliding off that map or if a
slug just drops on your head okay progress has been made easy there's a
slug up ahead but don't worry talk about Tokyo drift oh my god
oh I'm stuck okay there we go excuse me easy drift Queen easy peasy lemon
school easy oh I thought there was a thing there wait am I supposed to go in
here big or small I'm not to go in we okay that's fine is there something else
are my going crazy oh my god it sounds like voidberg hello do you want
can't on no talk what is this what do you want from me you're after my bean art
no but I suppose a few things I'll tell you how is that how was I did I sound like
an elder I've been practicing my elder means how random don't ever speak to me
again all right I'm gonna go check I still have two cats and not one cuz
Gimli it likes to fly over the fence so give me just a moment to check on
I thought she jumped the fence I just thought had a heart attack oh my god I
looked out the window couldn't see her went in the garden was like him like
him like him like absolutely nothing my heart is racing right now I thought
Gimli got out oh my god okay come breathe everything's good everything's
fine the cat has not escaped my SCP cat has not escaped contamination
containment sorry contamination oh my heart can't take that I started going
fucking nuts there I was like out in the garden running a bit whoa I don't have
what need for this right okay let's go big and then go into the ice palace and
then we will gain that the third elemental which is fantastic the SCP cat
let's just leg it I don't I don't think you need to like get anything here
for me yeah we get to be tiny you will be do the fight
running about hours a running about looking for that cat that I'm freezing in
here if you don't find that element quickly I'm gonna turn into a hatsicle
hurry up link so the last place was too hot now what the floor is made I speak
careful not to fall and freeze your backside on the floor link oh no not
logic puzzles with ice cubes in my biggest weakness anything that requires
a bit of rain oh no I'm gonna get me here get me here I'm getting rolled
endless Eden thank you for coming to member I appreciate it and t-minus 40
minutes until she be streams and I will take a 15 minute break I'm gonna get a
cup of tea and go and try and see if I can drop a fat loaf of bread and then
praying that a refling has sent me the link to that hey the sunlight shining
through mm I feel so nice and warm I can feel myself starting to defrost and then
we'll do the most forbidden to your list known to manual I'll put the stream up
as well the stream isn't currently up so you won't be able to see it and on it I
said one earlier thank you reflings I appreciate yeah hey why don't you go
take a look yes let's push this down the classic
perfect you got a small key love mommy's voice I can send it man I love you
why is it cuz I'm dumb be honest right I'm freaking scared of this room stop oh
my gosh I don't even know how to make these fires not fall corner dumb well
we only have one way we can go down one of my menu oh no this is a big logic
puzzle oh there's the master key already well pardon me sorry well I'm
special let's open that up again so we can actually melt this let's open that
up again please link thank you for your strongy plus the sigmic yeah right
letters comments for oh I already can see it holy crap I don't know how my
brain like already sees it what I mean this is a child's game at the same time
so maybe I shouldn't give myself too much credit but here it is oh I tell a lie
I tell a lie I tell a lie I did not see it I thought it was on the same plane
field but it's not right what I do then shrink shrink shrink gets caught so what
it has to go up here no I can't oh no this can be oh my think I see it hold
on hold on this might be wrong this might be right but you know what we can
always reset if I get it wrong and cuz the game so old there's plenty of future
tutorials to help me do I need I'm stuck I think it's this and then I just send it
down the corridor oh we did it we did it on to me to try all done you got a
big old key all right now we close it so we can walk across the room you can do
it before first try yes first try wink wink nudge nudge for I am the the
mightiest gamer ever
easy club right now that I've got the key I can just go through there there's no
way we're at the boss fight already because that's the boss door and we've
not unlocked any red portals or anything so I don't believe it hold on let me oh
would you stop with the ports coming at me oh hey well done link this looks like
to this looks to be the element all right but what will we do we can't even
touch it while it's trapped in that ice we'll need to melt off somehow yes well
I can see the enemy I can see what the enemy is I actually quite like that oh
wait am I not
map dungeon Skyrim on legendary I am good at Skyrim aren't I I'm so talented
like that being able to scour me if we get a new heart we need to go back to
that guy so the lunches we need to go back to the guy in the swamp as well
because he was gonna teach us something what's this way I need a key to
progress that's fine we don't have that yeah but claim ha ha
there's a little switch here I will ever push it that good then the waterfall
oh skill what is this thing the way forward is hidden in the bottom of the
oh it's like a pot thank you for letting me play children's games so I don't
actually have to play wait then you go all the way back to unlock it I do have a
key now though I think I do okay hold on hold on let me cook your Skyrim pro I
need you to teach me the legendary way to plug in that 360 controller and I'll
possess I don't know how anyone plays legendary on scour them I don't some
people like always oh I can't believe it people have different preferences to me
shocking behavior and but like I just enjoy like playing a wee story and like
going through it I'll say that as if I didn't really enjoy Elden Ring with you
guys though and so but I only enjoyed Elden Ring because you guys can hold my
hand through it but like I enjoy like a kind of calm like fun experience it's
just casual and like you gotta be story and it's like so cute and you can admire
the the visuals you can admire the sound design the music all of that I just
think it's rather lovely you know I didn't want to be sitting you know
playing dark souls replaying I say that I'm kind of saying dark souls but I
just play Elden Ring and get carried through it so I can't really check anything
I need to just send this single wow I do that's actually quite humorous um okay
now we have a platform so we can just I'm sure there's a switch over here often
they cheese it with self-archer paralysis today we're learning the strap
hey you yeah you oh sorry well I got what I wanted so I'm actually not that
sorry is it upper left sorry I'll be faster to manually swim to do this
it looks like it's up okay it's up or right sorry I totally know my left and
oh
Lily pad hello it's all the way at the start
well excuse me
how was I supposed to know it was gonna despawn if I wasn't standing on it
excuse me mr. Lily pad as if I had just missed you from business oh my god
that's so far to come back with it ah right lesson learned don't go off screen
without being on the Lily pad oh hell yeah like when Stevie was playing the
crab treasure game I said this before I thought it was just a casual fun game
no it's supposed to be like dark souls like I like what cuz I was gonna play it
and oh I did manage to watch some more about true gameplay I think we can do a
about true gameplay so a full house is when you have three of any card and two
of any card and oh I'm gonna get hurt here my apologies oh I didn't need the
house okay stop geez and straight is when you have a missing one from a flush
no a flush is when you have a missing one but a straight flush is when you have
five that are correct in the sequence and then you can do like two doubles or
you can play quads and so I think I think we can successfully do a
about true stream without perishing too much what's this what's a royal flush when
the flush has King Queen and Jack in it I'm gonna get turds dropped on my head I
think I don't know I'm not sure but I have enough knowledge to try and win at
the game a ball true is one of those games where if you lose you lose but
it's fine I'm gonna slide in any I'm gonna sneeze sorry sorry and down Ray
south west go down Ray and then south and then west and then off okay flush is
seems to straight is in any sequence royal flushes a oops okay I got close
close to the answer was a perfect place to see what a wonderful scene yes also
I'm such a kawaii name game whichever huh I'm so kawaii name no short to scare
yes you're more than welcome you're more than welcome I'll sneeze in your open
mouth anytime you need not ask with me for I will deliver I cannot do anything
about him I'm covered in dookie I went brown there lol actually covered in dookie
they're not I mean I have to leave now link where are you are you so under me it's
so dark I can't see my beak in front of my face and watch your step I don't want
you to trip over anything very dark I'm not supposed to be able to see at this
sure oh well I'll can see no actually get shown I'm getting rolled in the
child's game can't believe it I'm so excited for you up in the next month
and cameo we can start collecting our gamers oh not these guys these guys are
actually pretty troublesome especially when there's a room full of them hurt
myself by accident I suppose on purpose what have I got to hell I'll maybe do a
bit of exploring after this because now once we are not whoa okay we're we're
almost finished the dungeon if we've got that and we'll definitely go exploring
after this one to get like fill hearts and all the items and stuff because I
think we're supposed to have more health by now and like do like more of the
swimming because now the swimming's unlocked and digging is unlocked we have
so much more access to stuff unless we go get the last item of course sunlight
once we get some sunlight or melt the ice the element is as good as ours okay
that's perfect that's okay strongy we can believe it that you can be rolled in a
child's game can't I was so good at least I know where to get all the element of
fruit this time I still cannot believe I reflow and went back and watch my
gameplay to freaking do one by one I was convinced it was the chinchilla glitch
on one of the ones in the ceiling but no they've master ugly gives you a like
tooth as much as I love rupees I really unless there's a key inside that I'm
gonna have to do this aren't I what okay maybe that was worth it maybe I should
go for chests and I see them I remember the tournament thing literally all you
need to do is take there my and just go balls to the wall with them am I gonna
make this sure sure I am it's fine I don't know if it's left or right but
we'll just take a left because I can hug the wall well we actually pick the
right one believe it or not and even those the left one haha okay I can't
please use all can you please use all of my jokes why is it beeping they're
going I'm at a draw no one to let the light in let his light inside you Isaac
boo tomato tomato Cavio was the first game I 100% wait did anything happen
oh I just
ah okay okay okay and then go back to opening it up again I understand I'm not
anyone else that play cameo getting the egg smokes explosives that were me dad's
I'm really rare studios is just I always done a good game like Conqueror's
Friday the diversity of the studio as well I got a smokey in the yeah the
diversity of the studio at rear as well and they came out with rear replay where
they had all the games
am I being special I think so
no I got key yeah I got key so I can progress sorry I'm having a well this
looks like a battle done with ever seen one what my son okay an ice flame ice
flame girl confirmed gentile we already got an icicle okay bit bit stronger than
the last slime wait I can't if he's zapping actually can't suck them up oh I
sent it I thought I could ah by like what three three little okay I think I'm
like literally doing it as fast as the input will even allow okay when he's
electricity mode I can't do anything so just play safe yeah I can't do anything
oh now you do it whoa no no no no don't get your spark back no oh actually I
tell you one thing I wouldn't mind an electricity scene girl and in Isaac
there are is a an item called jumper cables and I wouldn't mind some sort of
design incorporating that in an electricity girl wait you hardly were
down for like a second that was like a millisecond chance no go wait no don't
jump oh we got him right can I get a chance to actually perish you this time
no wow that's real I guess it's supposed to be like pretty hard boss he is not
letting me breathe
yeah I don't know oh there we go jeez that was not easy hydration check
hmm
the flame lantern a handy item that lights up the night oh I love it love it love it love it
love it I love it give me it whoa just like that ice has no match now for me what's down here
a chest you have to tell me to use the door that's locked wait so what was up
if this makes me
they actually have to kill these guys
thanks one I guess you can't do it if you don't clear the room again
oh they actually frisbee back to them
man you're lucky that one protected you you got a free hit in
I just maybe I just suck at this
I'm getting trolled okay I'm getting trolled oh they're not supposed to stay on
uh right let's try this
feel like I was getting trolled there by the dying game
so I will only see not a cheeky five bombs
okay a few enemies in this fucking sec oh jesus
very sound good at end of this
oh bomba bomba
whoa okay visibility low but there's an enemy and a bomb behind me
this isn't getting any better if anything is getting worse
oh my gosh oh I wouldn't mean that hard
oh I got key we had to do it to progress
100 oh no they respawned
nonsense nonsense oh sorry went the wrong way excuse me pardon me out how embarrassed
oh went the wrong way
got red piece okay more more strategic eventful momentum
maybe cash thank you for perishing I appreciate it
I think I can come complete it in 20 minutes let me kick
a little bit
you can do it in 20 minutes surely surely surely have faith in me reeflands 20 minutes
it's all I need and in a 20 minute adventure reeflands
oh me arse is on fire don't and I can't I can't
it wouldn't let me attack either because me arse is on fire
got heart back I'll take that easy
easy easy
wow I'm allowed to see again
I assume push it sideways no oh push them into the wall too much
wait 20 minutes that's like 10 times more than the usual
oh if I can do it in time I can actually push this
one bit more
what will we do with the other 19?
savages these are savages no not savages savage
uh why is that excuse there is it upset my day question mark
hold on there's a logic puzzle
but why is it
hold on there appears to be some sort of logic puzzle
but I don't like it because I don't know what it is
give me a second to figure out right if I do that and then
I'll do these
right uh-huh
uh wait I need to go on the boat one or the other one one two yeah
and just send it don't send it send it send it
okay we did it we did it oh my god
that was oh
just kept jumping just kept forcing me in
just kept forcing me to go straight back in it I'm like alright thanks mate appreciate that no
no no it's fine keep doing it
I lost so much health on that free I'm doing free hearts now
I'm not gonna make it
I don't even need to fight so I'm not gonna border oh come on on the ace you would as well
oh forgiveness link link you knew for a fact that I was trying to brush on these
don't no no don't start this no I refuse I refuse I refuse I refuse okay thank goodness
we got that done that was gonna get frustrating that was gonna get frustrating first breathe
and then not breathe breathe oh my god I'm just
is there anything in these that I should know about is there like a heart under these
that we're doing no no hearts no hearts for me
yeah I'll go perish in a fire then won't I oh it's that big jobbies
I don't stop making me a jobbie I like how the arrows also pointing on the floor like here if
you really need help go here oh there's two of them in here that's cheating
okay they're raging I need to burn the walls because it's making me bounce into the enemy
it's not okay that guy's gone just good
that's a good burn oh I was lucky I would definitely have got some hp you ain't talking
there if I uh I need to save him up
okay we're almost there we're almost there
we're getting so close I don't want to miss she be starting but I'm taking so long to do this mission
she be
I think I can just avoid him no he's like right on the stairs oh wow I don't know how did that
the game was thinking oh my god we actually did it unreal unreal engine
wait was it unreal engine that came out and was like the gate it's free but if you if we find out
you have like x amount of sales you have to pay us a part of your game sales or something and everyone
was like oh oh oh it was unity it was unity we got the element but wait a minute we did it link
now we can take the element that was a lot of trouble but we finally did it and what in the blazes
hey something's not right here oh yeah beastie
are you gonna suck he's joint it give me my element back
what was this that stupid octo rock oh octo rock stole the element well didn't he just stand there
we're gonna go get it link jeez you even care son look that is a lot of talk that's a lot of
smack talk coming from a hat on my head right now I'm not gonna lie give me my element back
you know what bigger in person
what um what am I to do I have an idea I think I'm to burn the flower on his
butt at least I can break the boulders
oh I'm not sure I'm gonna just let them do whatever face this is because I don't know what to do
oh I'm to shoot it back in time I can do that you say PJ lemon PJ yes yes yes yes
oh no it's slippery careful it's slippery when wet oh I got this up it's slippery when wet I can't
keep up I can't keep up you're too fast
oh so close
am I supposed to go counterclockwise why are you so fast no he's mimicking oh this is
cheating now how am I supposed to burn hey there we go oh no don't suck me
what no oh is that the attack
yeah okay and then just do it again oh no you're coming after me
are you getting closer oh do we suck it I thought you was gonna throw a boulder out me
burn his plug
oh wait how am I supposed to okay this one no I thought he was gonna throw a boulder
how am I supposed to guess between a boulder and the suck
okay well that worked is it like a dance look
is it boulder dance look and then suck some boulder
no no sugar no no no no no no no no no no no no
yes okay okay okay I think it's just luck I don't know I just won't get too close to the aiming of it
it. Oh, I missed. And I shot and I missed again. And I shot and I missed again. So this
is the second one. Okay, I can handle that. We already got them. Oh, things are falling
on my head. I don't like it. Easy. Take it easy, buddy. Oh, is he just spamming it? I'll
take it. If you're just spamming it, I'll take it. Is it a dry bite? Wow, we did it. We
have 10 minutes to spare for Shabby. Let's go. We get the element. What is it? The water?
It must be water. Ice element doesn't make sense. You got the water element. Water quenches
thirst, ends droughts and nourishes life. The water element is the embodiment of that power.
I love and a heart. Oh, we can go to that man. That will teach us properly. One, two, three, four.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's get the heck out of here. I won't be here anymore. Here we go. Shabby's live
right now. Wait, I thought it was a 10. Oh, it is 10 already. Oh, young one. Child who
seeks to aid the princess of Hyrule. My name is Gustaf. I was king of Hyrule countless ages ago.
Stand before me. Only then will the path be open to you. Huh, was that just a dream? He said he
was the king of Hyrule. Wait, look at your map, Link. There's something marked on it. Huh, I guess
that means it wasn't a dream? We should head there once we've infused your sword with that element.
To the elemental sanctuary at once. Okay, then it's graveyard, then it's
airtop, and then we're done. Yeah, we made some fast progress. Holy moly. I definitely think we
should be exploring now. Because we're definitely getting close to end game content. What time is
that? Okay, I am going to end there. And then for members, I am going to do a membership stream.
In like 10 minutes, I will put it up. You cannot see the stream right now because I've not put it up.
But don't worry, I will put it up. If you give me 10 minutes after I end the stream for any members
of the channel, we are going to be doing the forbidden, the forbidden tier list. I'm not sure
how long that's gonna take. We'll see, we'll see. As for any, any what? Any notes? I'm going to try
and upload my special 2000 thank you. Today, I'm also going to try and see if I tomorrow I can
upload the first collab with Mimosa. She has been waiting so patiently. I mean, Denpah's been
waiting patiently. And so is this third person that I haven't told yous who I'm collabing with. I
don't think. Your hint is like wolf. Right, customization, redirect, and to none other than
Shibi Quarrenboom. Oh, Shibi is doing smash her pass with Toma Keys. I actually don't know much
about Toma Keys, but if Shibi knows her, then we are in good company. Shibi has fantastic friends.
Right, in 10 minutes without strany. Yes, give me 10 minutes. I'm going to see if I can drop
a loaf of bread. I'm going to make a cup of tea and all of that. But give me a few minutes and then
the stream will pop up. Don't worry. For those of you who are unable to member, please don't worry.
I always have free content daily and not only are you getting the stream, you're also getting a
video today as well. That will come up on YouTube soon to you. Thank you so so much for hanging
and we will finish this fantastic childhood game tomorrow. Nothing, nothing but fantastic nostalgia
this stream has been. And I will see you, if I don't see you in 10 minutes, I will see you tomorrow
to finish this fantastic game. Thank you so so much, Reflings. Please do say hi to Shibi for me.
I'm going to run away and drop a bomb in the toilet. Well, you guys can get comfy with Shibi, okay?
Thank you so so much, Reflings. See you until tomorrow or until 10 minutes, okay?